Wie kommen wir denn auf so ein verrücktes Thema? Wer würde das denn tun?
Zum Beispiel Dunja Hayali. Sie ist ja die kritische Journalistin par excellence,
so wird sie zumindest immer präsentiert im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen.
Und da fand ich plötzlich bei Twitter und auf Instagram ein Selfie mit Söder
zusammen. Söder hatte es gepostet.
Söder und Hayali zusammen lächeln in die Kamera und Söder hat dazu geschrieben,
Ich habe ihr heute einen Preis verliehen, also der vom Staat gefördert ist,
vom Freistaat, einen journalistischen Preis.
Es gibt so einen blauer Panther Award, heißt der glaube ich.
Der wird auch mitgesponsert dann von Sky richtet das mit aus und BMW und naja
und Söder hat also diesen Preis überreicht und ich habe dieses Selfie dann bei
Twitter einfach nur mit einem Trüko, also mit einem Drüberkommentar versehen.
Und habe geschrieben, kritischer Journalismus Symbolbild, weil ich grundsätzlich
sagen möchte, dass Journalisten nicht von Politikern Preise entgegennehmen sollten.
Zumal, wie es ja hier mit einer Journalistin zu tun hat, die regelmäßig Söder
kritisch befragen muss, das ist ja ihre Aufgabe.
Und dann ist das ja doch eine schwierige Gemengelage, wenn man von diesem Herrn
auch noch einen Preis überreicht.
Daraufhin ist dann Marie von der Benken, von den Benken wild geworden,
die dann mir natürlich irgendwie so Querdenkertum gleich vorwarf.
Irgendwie so, ich bin ein Selbstdenker
oder irgendwas. Also man wird ja gleich, wenn man diese, diese.
Klardenker.
Ja, wenn man diese Heronen des Linksliberalismus kritisiert,
ist man natürlich gleich irgendwie in einer ganz merkwürdigen Ecke.
Dabei ist ja meine Kritik eine ganz andere.
Und dann hat auch noch Dunja Hayali sich eingeschaltet, die dann schrieb,
ja, ich habe ja offenbar ihre Rede nicht gehört und da wäre sie doch mal gespannt,
was ich dazu sage. Das hat Hayali dir dann geschrieben?
Aufgrund noch eines Dritten, der sich Markus Mittermeier, heißt der auch so
ein Großprofil, also mit viel Reichweite.
Und daraufhin habe ich mir dann diese Rede angehört, die ja gar nicht verlinkt war dort.
Also das heißt, man muss ja erstmal bei einem Medienprofi wissen,
ein Bild geht seinen eigenen Weg. Also wenn ich jetzt heute ein Selfie mache
mit Markus Söder, dann kann ich ja nicht sagen, ja, aber ihr hättet mal wissen
müssen, was ich da irgendwann mit ihm gesagt habe.
Man weiß, wie ein Selfie wirkt und man muss auch ein Selfie nicht machen,
selbst wenn man einen Preis von jemandem entgegen nimmt.
Die Öffi-Logik ist ja so, wir hatten ja damals Elmar Thebesen im Aufwachen-Podcast
und haben ihn auch zu ein paar Sachen befragt.
Er, auch als Medienprofi, weiß, wie ein Bild funktioniert. Und hatte damals
auch schon das Zitat im Umlauf, die Menschen machen um die Nachrichten Slalomfahrten.
Ja. Also Einschaltquote, irgendein Tatort oder so was läuft.
Dann kommen die Tagesthemen, Einschaltquoten sinken.
Danach, wenn die Leute wissen, Nachrichten sind vorbei, steigen sie wieder,
das ist die Slalomfahrt.
Und trotzdem kommt er dann mit dieser Analyse uns gegenüber.
Naja, Thilo und Stefan, ist ja schön und gut, dass ihr das kritisiert.
Wir haben das am 7. Oktober im Morgenmagazin behandelt.
Irgendein Thema, ja.
Aber ich habe doch da auch eine Rede gehalten. Und im 5.
Absatz habe ich doch gesagt, dass ... Und das wird dann von den Leuten,
die genau wissen, wie es funktioniert, in Konkurrenz zu so einem Selfie auf
Twitter, das Markus Söder noch selbst verbreitet.
Diese Veranstaltung wurde im Fernsehen übertragen, entweder Bayerischer Rundfunk
oder Dreisat. Wo man ja auch weiß, die haben Topquoten immer.
Und ich habe mir dann den Livestream angesehen, der hatte bis Sonntag dann 490 Aufrufe.
Also ich bin einer der wenigen, würde ich sagen, die diese Rede dann jetzt rezipiert haben.
Und klar tritt jetzt Dunja Hayali nicht dort auf und sagt, lieber Markus Söder,
ich wünschte, Sie wären König von Bayern, sondern sie sagt, ich will Ihnen schon
klar machen, nicht alle Muslime sind Antisemiten und wir dürfen das Klima nicht vergiften und so.
Also was man von ihr erwartet, sagt sie. Was aber auch Söder ja erwartet,
wenn er sie mit einem Preis bedenkt.
Und das ist ja genau dieser Punkt,
dass man eigentlich nur noch so ein pseudokritisches Spiel da aufführt.
Ja, Söder weiß, was er kriegt, er kann aber zugleich sich auch damit brüsten.
Seht her, wie offen ich bin. Ja, ihr habt mich für den Aiwanger kritisiert,
aber seht her, ich kann auch die Journalistin, die eher links ist,
Dunja Hayali auszeichnen.
Du hast jetzt ihre Rede gelesen. Ist sie dann noch mal im Kontext der Zeit?
Das fand ja jetzt die Tage statt auf die Aiwanger und also Aiwanger Wahlkampf.
Eiwanger-Wahlkampf mit dem Flugblatt und dann unterschreibt man trotzdem den
Koalitionsvertrag, also von Söders Seite aus. Hat sie das da irgendwie noch mal ...
Nein, es ging nur um die aktuelle Debatte, dass bei der CDU jetzt ja eine gewisse
Islamfeindlichkeit zu konstatieren ist.
Und das hat sie kritisiert, das hat sie, meinte ich, auch zu Recht kritisiert.
Aber ich finde, wenn man sowieso schon die ganze Zeit diesen Vorwurf der Staatsmedien
hört, dann muss man doch erst mal selbst das Missverständnis ausräumen,
dass man sich nicht in diese Nähe begibt.
Und man muss klarmachen, dieser Staatsfernsehen-Vorwurf stimmt nicht,
da nicht die Politiker den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen finanzieren,
sondern die Bürger. Und nicht mal nur die Bürger mit deutschem Pass,
sondern alle Bürger, die hier leben, Haushalt angemeldet haben.
Und ich finde, man sollte eher, wenn man über Umstrukturierung im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
nachdenkt, mal überlegen, wie kann man den politischen Einfluss minimieren?
Denn das ist nicht das Fernsehen der Politiker. Und das hat ja Küppersbusch
bei der Palastrevolution so schön gesagt,
Tatorte sind Quotenhits, 10 Millionen, 11 Millionen, 12 Millionen Zuschauer
und dann kommt Annel Will und 8 Millionen sind sofort weg und jeder Programmmacher
würde natürlich sofort entlassen werden.
Aber das ist quasi der Deal des Öffentlich-Rechtlichen mit der Politik.
Wir bieten euch jederzeit eine Bühne für euren Käse, den ihr da verbreiten wollt.
Und deswegen würde ich nochmal ganz klar unterstreichen, man sollte grundsätzlich
nicht in Preisentgegenung nehmen.
Und ich möchte auch nochmal besonders herausstellen, nach allem,
was wir jetzt für ein Theater von Söder erlebt haben, um das mal so neutral
wie möglich zu schildern, aus den letzten Monaten, sowieso nicht.
Also sowieso sollte man jetzt mit Söder am besten gar nicht auftreten,
egal in welchem Kontext auch immer.
Richtig. Und du hast die Pointe, die ich machen wollte eben schon nochmal,
Medienpreise einfach gar nicht annehmen.
Es gibt von Claudius Seidel diesen Text, ich habe schon ein paar Mal darauf
hingewiesen, oder war es ein Text? Ja doch, es war ein Text,
wo er beschreibt, wie er zurück in die Redaktion kommt von so einer Medienpreisverleihung
und seine Redaktion sagt, Leute, ich habe es jetzt erlebt, das Spiel spielen wir nicht mit.
Und die einzige Medienpreisvergabe, die ja stattfand, von der ich sage,
die lohnt sich nochmal nachzugucken, ist Marcel Reichardt Nitzke beim Fernsehpreis.
Ja, er möchte niemanden verletzen, aber das Theater war da jetzt.
Ich nehme diesen Preis nicht an.
Genau. Und zwar vor allem mit diesem Fokus auf, nicht der große Kontext,
sondern er saß da einfach eine Stunde vor und hat sich das Theater angeschaut
und hat gedacht, auf diese Bühne soll ich jetzt gehen, das soll eine Vorbereitung für mich sein.
Nee, Leute. Ja. Und dann nimmt er sozusagen kontextlos einfach dieses Ding da
nicht an. Ja, das war sehr gut.
Wir können an dieser Stelle schon mal darauf hinweisen,
dass wir im nächsten Salon, also der jetzt Anfang November erscheinen wird,
die fünf Termine bekannt geben für die Live Shows in Frankfurt,
die also dann im März, Juni.
September und Dezember plus einen Sommertermin im August, die wir dann machen.
Also wir machen diese vier regulären Veranstaltungen in der CASE und dann gehen
wir im Sommer nochmal in eine viel, viel größere Halle. Da passen dann glaube
ich sogar 800 Leute rein, oder? Ist das ein Saal? Ja, ist das ein Saal?
Gut, wir sind noch nicht im Eventbusiness, wo wir Halle gehen.
Also ein Saal, ein sehr großer Saal und diese Termine geben wir dann bekannt.
Das heißt, wer im Salon ist, hat dann den Vorzug bei den Karten.
Da sagen wir auch, wie man an die Karten kommt.
Und wir können auch an dieser Stelle schon mal sagen, dass wir im nächsten Salon
Hyperpolitik von Anton Jäger lesen.
Ein kurzer Essay erschien bei Surkamp, der sagt, warum wir eigentlich kein großes
politisches Engagement erleben, obwohl alles so unglaublich politisiert ist.
Und dann eine größere Studie, Triggerpunkte Konsens und Konflikt in der Gegenwartsgesellschaft.
Was ist es denn jetzt mit der Cancel Culture, dem Genderstern?
Warum regt das alle auf und gibt es das überhaupt? Genau, regt das denn alle
auf? Regt das überhaupt alle auf? Ist das ein Scheindiskurs?
Steffen Mau, Thomas Luchs und Linus Westhäuser sind dem nachgegangen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, sehr, sehr wichtig, da mal genau reinzugehen,
damit wir auch selbst viele Inseln gleich umschiffen können.
Brauchen wir überhaupt nicht mehr drüber reden. Haben wir dann abgearbeitet. Genau.
Man übersieht das ja schnell, dass es nicht nur tausend Leute im Fernsehen und
auf Twitter gibt, sondern auch noch 80 Millionen. Ja, ja. Rest Deutschland.
Das ist sehr wichtig. Und darüber werden wir heute ja auch mehrmals reden,
dass die Realität von Twitter doch nochmal eine ganz spezielle ist.
Jedenfalls der Hinweis, also das wird dann im Salon stattfinden.
Der Salon ist wie immer buchbar über.
Steady über Patreon und über Apple. Wir bevorzugen und empfehlen Steady.
Das ist alles ganz einfach auf der Seite zu finden.
Neue zwanziger.de beziehungsweise wenn man uns über Apple hört,
kann man dort direkt bei Apple buchen oder wenn man uns über Spotify hört,
kommt man da auch schnell zu der Steady Seite.
Es ist also sehr einfach, das einzurichten und für alle, die zuhören,
die Möglichkeit oder die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen.
Das würde uns sehr freuen.
So ist es. Also dieser Oktober hat es in sich.
Ja.
Und wir wissen natürlich alle, das Topthema ist ein zweiter Krieg,
mit dem wir es plötzlich zu tun haben. Ja.
Bei dem man relativ zügig feststellt, okay, wir wurden erstens überrumpelt und
zweitens, Aja, der hat auch eine Vorgeschichte.
Das war ja bei der Ukraine auch. Plötzlich kam das Jahr 2014 immer so ins Spiel
und so weiter und so fort. Also es mündet dann immer alles in so solchen großen
Themenlagen, wie die Journalisten sagen.
Aber, also wir werden natürlich auch viel darüber reden, aber ich will auch nochmal erwähnen, am 7.
Oktober gab es auch ein mega, mega, mega Erdbeben in Afghanistan,
das wirklich tausende leuten das leben gekostet hat
und naja wir wissen wie das ist bei erdbeben gerade
in solchen ländern wie in afghanistan in
denen nun die letzten 40 jahre kein haus so gebaut wurde dass es irgendwie aushält
wir haben ja das letzte erdbeben da in der türkei und syrien gesehen wo man
auch klar sehen konnte wie solche naturkatastrophen noch mal besonders wirken
wenn vorher einfach auch die zivilisation so ein bisschen gelitten hat das sieht
man jetzt in in Afghanistan.
Allerdings nur wenn man hinschaut, weil 7. Oktober, das war zeitgleich mit den Angriffen der Hamas.
Und dann haben wir am 3. Oktober in Amerika einen Ausfall des Parlamentarismus
bekommen, den wir hier auch überhaupt gar nicht thematisiert haben in Europa,
obwohl der so weitreichend ist.
Die Amerikaner hatten sich ja im Januar oder Februar darauf verständigt,
okay, in unserem Parlament, das ja anders als so ein modernes,
spätes, festgeschriebenes, nach Satzung arbeitendes, mit Geschäftsordnung und
so weiter, wieder Bundestag.
Bundestag, sondern da ist einfach, ja, haben wir jetzt einen Speaker,
also jemanden, der dem Ding vorsteht oder nicht. Und wenn nicht,
dann haben wir gar keine Regeln.
Also dann gibt es zwei Abgeordnete, aber die sind gar nicht handlungsfähig.
Die können weder eine Tagesordnung beschließen, noch Mehrheiten durchzählen,
weiß nicht mal die Regeln, was ist jetzt eine Mehrheit, einfach gar nichts geregelt.
Und es war dann bezeichnend zu sehen, dass selbst eine Woche später in Fernsehinterviews
Abgeordnete noch sagten, ja, wir sind so und so weit handlungsfähig,
wir können das schon machen, zum Beispiel die Ukraine-Hilfe oder so beschließen.
Und dann hinter ihnen Kollegen standen mit dem gleichen Mandat,
die dann sagten, nee, können wir nicht.
Also die haben auf offener Bühne ausgetragen, ob sie jetzt beschlussfähig sind
und zwar innerhalb einer Fraktion.
Also es war völlig irre, als ich das mit Thomas im Fernsehpodcast,
der ja Politiklehrer ist, besprochen habe, war auch die Frage,
wie erklärt man das denn als Lehrer, Schülern, was da abläuft,
wenn die Parlamentarier selbst nicht im Bilde sind, was hier gerade gilt.
Und wir wissen ja, Rule of Law und so, wir sind ganz stolz auf,
wir haben den Gurt rausgeräumt und die Gesetze rein und dann gelten einfach keine.
Das war ein Zustand, der fast drei Wochen in der Amerika anhielt und jetzt ja
schon wieder nach denselben Regeln wie vorher, nämlich ein einziger Abgeordneter
kann einen Antrag stellen auf Abwahl und dann reichen da kleine Stimmen.
Also in dem Falle waren es ja vorher bei McCarthy irgendwie neun Abweichler
und so weiter und zack war er weg.
Es sind völlig absurde Zustände, die alle mal reflektiert müssen,
aber sowas kann man dann auch im Salon nach, weil da ist es auch gar nicht unentscheidend
eine Textgrundlage zu haben, um dieses Problem mal auch in seiner Dimension,
was das für uns alle heißt.
Zu befassen, weil wenn die Amerikaner nicht mal einen eigenen Haushalt beschließen können,
dann muss man sich um die Amerikaner übernehmen Verantwortung für die Welt,
weil sie einen Militärhaushalt haben, der neun, also der größer ist als die
nächsten neun in der Top 10 der größten Militärhaushalte zusammen.
Nicht handlungsfähig sein.
Ja Biden bittet den neuen jetzt, dass Hilfen ermöglicht werden für die Ukraine und für Israel.
Aber genau darüber ist der McCarthy gestolpert. Ja. Da sind nämlich Zugeständnisse
und Kompromisse mit den Demokraten gemacht.
Und bei dem Neuen, wie ist nochmal sein Name? Ich hab's auch schon wieder vergessen.
Aber da muss man auch dazu sagen, niemand kennt ihn. Man hört den politischen
Podcast und alle fragen sich, wer ist das? Und man hat mit Absicht Nicola Benkler.
Und er hat mal so mal so abgestimmt. Also er ist nicht gegen Ukraine-Unterstützung,
aber auch nicht wirklich dafür. Und deswegen glaubt man so ein bisschen, dass es...
Ja, also er ist schon ziemlich dagegen. Und es ist so Maga-Trump-Style.
Also das ist ein absoluter Trump-Piss.
Er hat Trump ja... Hat die Wahl auch nicht zertifiziert von beiden.
Hat die Wahl nicht zertifiziert, genau. Hat dort Prozesse angestrebt. Also...
Es ist dramatisch.
Fraglich, wie das weitergehen wird, aber ja, wir müssen jetzt selbstverständlich
über das große Thema sprechen.
Der Terroranschlag auf Israel, beziehungsweise man kann sicherlich auch mit
Foucault und Reich von einem Pogrom sprechen und dann die Folgen daraus.
Es ist eine sehr aufgeheizte Debatte. Ich glaube, wichtig ist da auch bei aller
Emotionalisierung, die verständlich sein wird, möglichst ruhig und distanziert
auch, soweit es möglich ist, drauf zu blicken.
Wir können ja noch eine Stufe früher anfangen. Wir können ja überhaupt erst
mal fragen, haben wir es mit einem politischen Problem zu tun?
Also das zum Beispiel für einen politischen Podcast wie unseren sich eignet.
Wir haben ja sehr viele politische Podcasts in Deutschland, die so ein bisschen
auf, so wie unsere auch, unabhängig auf eigene Faust sozusagen gemacht werden.
Indem man einfach so reinstolpert in das Thema. Man kann jetzt ruhig noch mal
ein bisschen abstrahieren. Also hören wir mal den einen politischen Podcast rein.
Apokalypse und Filterkaffee, also Micky Weißenherz-Podcast, der ja täglich morgens
einfach so einen Überblick liefert.
Und er hat sich Hilfe geholt von Leon Windscheid, 18., der ja,
ich kannte ihn weniger, du meintest, du hast schon mal eine Sendung von ihm
gesehen. Ich hab ihn nur, als er Maitis Elternzeit mal vertreten hat.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht mehr, welches Thema. Ich habe nur kurz reingeschaut,
als ich gucken wollte, wer ist denn Leon Winscheid? Und ich so, ah ja, der macht so was.
Ja, so ein bisschen Psychologie bringt er da mit.
Genau, in der Öffi-Schiene und dann so Psycho-Kram. Und er ist bei Micky Beisenherz
und das ist ja nun ein politischer Podcast. Also redet jetzt ein Psychologe
in einem politischen Podcast über ein Thema, das ihn beschäftigt.
Und anhand dessen gehen wir mal, legen wir mal die Grundlage,
die grundlegende Unterscheidung und von da aus kann man dann,
glaube ich, gut loslaufen.
Erstmal muss ich sagen, wenn ich mit jüdischen Freunden oder Bekannten spreche und,
wirklich auch Sprachnachrichten mit Tränen mir dann anhöre oder von anderen
jüdischen Freunden schon vor längerer Zeit gehört habe. Man fühlt sich hier
in Europa, in Deutschland auch ganz konkret, mit den Werten der AfD nicht mehr sicher.
Und dann Israel so eine Art Zufluchtsort ist, wo man jetzt sieht,
was dort passiert, dann schnürt sich mir alles zu.
Dann denke ich an diese grausamen Bilder, die wir alle in Social Media zum Teil
ja auch ganz ungefiltert präsentiert bekommen, von Granaten,
die in Bunker geworfen werden. Immer wieder diese absurden Fragen,
ist das jetzt echt, ist das nicht echt?
Und gleichzeitig dieses Mitfühlen von Töchtern, die auf irgendwelchen Festivals
verschleppt werden, das macht richtig viel mit einem, das geht mir nicht aus dem Kopf.
Und da muss ich auch sagen, bei allem weiter so, und das Leben muss auch weitergehen,
das will ja keiner in Abrede stellen, ist das etwas, was mich seit mehr als
einer Woche total beansprucht, gedanklich umtreibt, auch fertig macht.
Anders kann ich das eigentlich nicht sagen. Ich denke, und das ist jetzt wieder
der psychologische Blick, den man ja auch auf sich selber haben kann,
das gilt für uns alle, dieses Halte durch, zeigt keine Schwäche.
Ein Indianer kennt keinen Schmerz. Das sind diese ganz furchtbaren Sprichwörter,
mit denen wir groß geworden sind.
Aber wenn wir uns jetzt mal vor Augen führen, wir kamen aus einer sowieso schon
wirtschaftlich schwierigen Lage.
Dann kam diese Corona-Pandemie aus dem Nichts. Mehrere Jahre Lockdown,
soziale Isolation, gesellschaftliche Spaltung, all das.
Und dann kommt wieder aus dem Nichts dieser Ukraine-Krieg,
damit du jetzt aus dem Nichts, wo das andere kaum verdaut ist,
beziehungsweise noch läuft, diesen Terror-Horror,
der Hamas erleben muss, da möchte ich uns einfach mal allen sagen,
wir leben nicht im Vakuum und dass jetzt Menschen sagen, ich kann nicht mehr,
das ist zu viel und im übrigen einige Psychologieverbände, wie ich finde,
sehr, sehr passend heute einen Brandbrief an Olaf Scholz geschrieben haben,
es geht so nicht weiter, wir brauchen mehr Therapieplätze, wir müssen was tun,
ihr habt das zugesagt im Koalitionsvertrag und noch nichts gemacht.
Das finde ich ist sehr, sehr treffend, sehr, sehr wichtig in einem Moment,
wo ich, wenn ich mich in Deutschland umgucke, das Gefühl habe,
die Menschen sind psychisch an ganz vielen Stellen, gehen extrem auf dem Zahnfleisch
und das gilt für mich auch.
Also ich bin natürlich total für diesen Appell. Wir haben ja auch nicht zu wenig
Psychologen, sondern zu wenig Kassensitze.
Wenn man jetzt einfach sagt pro so und so viele Einwohner kann man einfach 20
Prozent mehr Kassensitze machen, dann gibt es sofort Psychologen,
die die besetzen und dann wäre alles gut.
Also das sind reine politische Budget-Fragen, warum wir zu wenig psychologische
Hilfe haben für die, die es brauchen. Aber für die Themen, die hier aufgezählt
wurden, brauchen wir keine Psychologie, sondern bessere Politik.
Wir können uns die Folgen eines Krieges, von dem wir uns sagen,
okay, er findet ja nicht vor unserer Haustür statt, sondern nur im Fernsehen,
er belastet uns trotzdem, können wir nicht sagen, ja, dann brauchen wir jetzt
einen Psychologen, der uns dabei hilft. Sondern nee, wir brauchen ein Ende von den Kriegen.
Und das sind nun mal politische Fragestellungen, in denen uns die Psychologie
gar nichts nützt, weder für uns, noch als...
Aber der Putin ist ja so und so drauf oder so was.
Die Psychologie kann nachträglich mir helfen. Wenn die Politik es verbaselt
hat, kann der Psychologe mir helfen, dass ich damit klarkomme.
Wenn ich eine nicht so gut gemanagte Corona-Politik habe, wenn ich einen chinesischen
Staat habe, der zwei Monate lang Informationen verschweigt, dass das zu all dem kommen kann.
Wenn all dies passiert ist und ich darunter zu leiden habe politischen Entscheidungen
oder Missmanagement, dann kann ich im Nachhinein mir einen Therapieplatz besorgen.
Und die versuchen, das dann in mir wieder gerade zu biegen. Aber damit hat man
ja immer nur nachträglich etwas gemacht. Und hier, das sind ja politische,
also eminent politische Themen
und Probleme. Und die können sich ja nur politisch lösen. Wie denn sonst?
Ja, also die grundlegende Herangehensweise, man soll sich Hilfe holen,
wenn man vor allem die Einsicht hat, ich kann ja die Welt nicht verändern,
sondern nur meine Einstellung zu ihr.
Nein, hier bei diesen Sachen müssen wir die Welt verändern.
Da führt nun wirklich gar nichts dran vorbei. Und das gilt insbesondere auch
für die Corona-Pandemie.
Denn die war ja nun wirklich so unaushaltbar und für viele so triftig,
jetzt nach psychologischer Hilfe zu suchen, weil man eben feststellte plötzlich,
ach ja, erstens bin ich individuell mittellos,
zweitens wurde einfach aufdiktiert, was jetzt hier systemrelevant ist und was nicht.
Und ich will nur auf den einen Beispiel, aber der illustriert ja so viel,
dass man dann innerhalb von einem halben Jahr feststellt, was ein Friseur eigentlich
leistet in der Gesellschaft.
Dass es da natürlich nicht nur um die Haarlänge geht, sondern für alte Leute,
einen Ansprechpartner und so weiter, jemand der nicht flüchtet für eine halbe
Stunde, wo man nicht wie an der Kasse weggeschickt wird oder beim Arzt,
du hast nur sieben Minuten für deinen Patientenkontakt und so weiter,
sondern da sitzt man halt eine halbe Stunde, bezahlt einen Euro pro Minute, kriegt eine.
Kopfmassage und so weiter und geht halt als leicht verbesserter Mensch da raus,
bis man eine Woche später dann irgendwie wiederkommt oder so.
Naja, also das kommt alles nicht aus dem Nichts. Das finde ich auch schon mal
einen ganz wichtigen Hinweis. Und der gilt auch nicht nur jetzt für so Diskussionen
wie, wenn der Koterisch sagt, das findet in einem Vakuum statt oder nicht.
Da kann man auch einfach mal sagen, das sind so alberne Diskussionen.
Wie kann man überhaupt von irgendwas behaupten, es finde in einem Vakuum statt?
Ich meine, Vakuum ist ein rein physikalischer Begriff, der einfach sagt, da ist nichts.
Und in unserer sozialen Welt ist nirgendwo nichts. Also das ist einfach sowieso
total schräg. Aber sowas passiert dann halt, wenn man zu schnell in so Diskussionen reinstolpert.
Da finde ich ja doch dann Harald Schmidt sympathisch.
Der war beim Deutschlandfunk zu Gast bei Combinian Frenzel und wurde auch dann
auf Israel angesprochen und sagte folgendes.
Ich bin einer der wenigen, nicht aktuell entstandenen Nahost-Experten, ja.
Als die Meldung von diesem Massaker der Hamas in Israel rauskam,
musste ich erstmal nachgucken, wo ist eigentlich im Nahen Osten was?
Es gab früher diese Stempel mit den Erdkonekarten, wo man Länder einzeichnen
sollte, ja. Da hätte ich nicht mal präzise Jordanien, Syrien,
Gaza-Streifen schon mal gar nicht zu reden. Mir war auch nicht klar, wie klein der ist.
West Bank, Golan-Höhen, dann komme ich auf Golda Meir, die nach dem Yom Kippur-Krieg
zurückdrehen muss, und zwar keine Ahnung davon.
Ja, und das aber immer alles in so einer Gemengelage, wo man dann mit anderen,
die sich das nicht so zutrauen, einfach zu sagen, ich bin sprachlos.
Sorry, Leute, wir hören gleich noch ein paar andere Beispiele.
Es ist so ein interessantes Paradox, dass gerade Journalisten und ihre Kommentatoren,
also es ist immer einer, der die Fragen, einer braucht irgendwelche Antworten
und es ist dann eigentlich stellvertretend für dieses,
okay, Man beschäftigt sich damit zu Hause und möchte dann so einen externen Input,
also hört man irgendwie beim Fabulieren zu und so, aber es ist wirklich wahnsinnig
irre, wie man immer in dem Moment der größten Krise, weshalb man über Sachen
spricht, also journalistisch werden Sachen aufgeworfen, weil es gerade eine Katastrophe ist.
Ja, so, weil es gerade absolut outer space irgendwas stattfindet.
Und genau in dem Moment hat man dann den größten, also lösen wir das Problem jetzt mal, Impetus.
Wo man sich denkt, naja, dein Auskonflikt ist mehrere Jahrzehnte,
wenn nicht Jahrhunderte.
Wir können ihn jetzt besprechen, weil da gerade wirklich wieder katastrophale
Zustände sind. Aber ihn auch jetzt noch gleichzeitig lösen zu wollen,
da überhebt man sich. Und zwar alle durch die Bank. Und das sehe ich aber auch
überall, genau so. Ja, ja. Alle, die darüber reden, überheben sich gerade.
Und kann natürlich auch sein, dass ich jetzt ein bisschen vorgeprägt bin durch
dieses, okay, seit einem Jahr bin ich alle zwei Wochen irgendwo und rede über
die Alten Republik und sag dann so nach einer halben Stunde erstmal,
Leute, wir reden hier nur über ein Problem.
Wir lösen es nicht. Vielleicht gibt es gar keine Lösung. Wir finden auf jeden
Fall heute Abend nicht die Lösung. Wir reden einfach nur über Zahlen,
die halt sind, wie sie sind.
So und das würde ich doch mal empfehlen grundsätzlich.
Es empfiehlt sich da sehr zaghaft zu sein, auch würde ich empfehlen,
von einigen Experten mal Abstand zu nehmen, ich will da beispielhaft.
Ich will jetzt mal canceln, also ich weiß nicht, ob man weiterhin laufend Amin Nassih zitieren muss.
Er hat da in der Zeit, Patrick Barnas hat darauf hingewiesen,
einen Artikel geschrieben, wo er sagt, am Ende werden es aber die Jüdinnen und
Juden sein, die das Nachsehen haben gegenüber westlichen politischen Akteuren,
die die Kosten der Unterstützung womöglich nicht mehr in der gleichen Intensität
hinbekommen, wenn diese steigen.
Gegenüber einer migrantischen Realität in Deutschland, die zumindest im Hinblick
auf dieses Thema derzeit kaum zivilisierbar erscheint.
Und gegenüber Linken, die die Juden endlich in die Schranken einer internationalen
Kapitalismus- und Kolonialkritik verweisen können.
Also ich will nicht gänzlich widersprechen manchen Aspekten,
die da drinstehen, aber dazu kommen wir jetzt gleich noch.
Nur ich finde, dass sich das doch als Soziologe vielleicht verbietet,
von einer migrantischen Realität zu sprechen und da zu sagen,
im Hinblick auf dieses Thema seid sie derzeit kaum zu zivilisieren.
Also ist das der richtige Tonfall, den man an den Tag legen sollte,
wenn man von Zivilisierung der Migranten spricht?
Also wenn man die migrantische Realität meint und dann aber auf Muslime abstellt.
Ja, das meint man ja auch alleine. Es gibt ja sonst offenbar keine Migranten.
Also zum einen das, Migranten sind gleichzeitig Muslime.
Und dann, er gehört ja zu den Beraterkreisen, die für die Politik immer wieder
Handlungsempfehlungen, mal so ein paar inspirative Texte und so weiter raussuchen,
formulieren, wie auch immer.
Und das größte, allergrößte Problem der letzten Jahrzehnte war doch,
dass die Muslime in Deutschland von der Politik so gerne angesprochen werden
möchten, aber sie keine Adresse haben, weil jede kleine religiöse Gemeinde so
sein eigenes Ding kocht.
Dann kommt noch die ethnische Herkunft dazu und dann hast du so ein großes Wirrwarr
und man blickt eigentlich nicht durch.
Und selbst in so Stadtteilen wie hier in Frankfurt am Main, die ich kenne,
ist es wahnsinnig komplizierend, überhaupt mal zu wissen, wenn man sie zu einem
politischen Objekt, Subjekt, wie auch immer machen möchte.
Bei den Rentnern ist völlig klar, wie man die anspricht. Die sind zwar selber
nicht organisiert, aber die haben einfach eine politische Adresse.
So und da ist das anders. Und da finde ich es immer wieder so überraschend,
wie man auf der einen Seite uns diese Geschichte erzählt, wie Wolfgang Schäuble damals.
Die Muslim-Konferenz gegründet hat und so weiter, um die Nachwehen des 11.
September mal politische Bahn zu lenken.
Wie dann Christian Wulff kam mit der Islam gehört zu Deutschland und man von
selbst dieser konservativen Seite eigentlich immer das Angebot gemacht hat,
wir sind schon für euch ansprechbar, macht euch doch auch mal ansprechbar.
Und man dann festgestellt hat, Nee, so einfach funktioniert es dann doch nicht.
Außer man möchte sie verkommentieren, wie Amina Zeyi macht. Und dann ist plötzlich alles eins.
Also dann ist das alles, wird einfach vergessen.
Die ganze politische Herausforderung, die man eigentlich adressieren müsste,
gibt es nicht mehr, sondern gibt es einfach eine migrantische Realität in Deutschland.
Und diese Art von Pauschalisierung verbittet sich einfach für Soziologie-Professoren.
Diesen Streit, also auslösend von diesem Screenshot, den du uns vorgelesen hast,
Barnas hat ja darauf reagiert, dann hatten die ja noch persönlich,
privat, hat er mir jetzt eine Klage angedroht oder nicht, die sie noch mal expliziert haben.
Und Barnas hat dann zwei Stunden später nochmal einen 20-Tweet-langen Thread
dazu geschrieben, wo Nasehi da einfach falsch liegt und so. Das empfiehlt sich
sehr nachzulesen, für diejenigen, die noch Twitter in ihrem Leben drin haben.
Ganz kurze Anmerkung, ich habe den Eindruck, ich habe, vielen Dank,
ich habe Codes bekommen für Blue Sky, jetzt einige, aber ich habe den Eindruck,
jetzt wirklich mit dem Terroranschlag ist sofort Twitter wieder die Quelle.
Ich habe für Blue Sky fast nichts mehr gesehen in meiner, also davor, bis vor dem 7.
War meine ganze Timeline nur noch mit Hallo, ich bin jetzt bald im blauen Himmel
und danach eigentlich nichts mehr davon.
Absolut, so habe ich es auch.
Ich will noch eine Expertin jetzt heranziehen, die wir auch mal vielleicht überdenken
sollten. Und zwar Marie Agnes Strack-Zimmermann war zugeschaltet und sagt Folgendes.
Und man muss eines klar machen, diese beiden Konflikte, diese beiden Angriffe,
Russlands Angriff auf die Ukraine, der terroristische Angriff der Hamas auf
Israel hängt unmittelbar zusammen.
Im Übrigen war das am Tag von Putins Geburtstag, der 7. Oktober.
Das sind alles keine Zufälle.
Also wollte die Hamas Putin ein Geburtstagsgeschenk machen? Jetzt kann man selbstverständlich
sagen, Putin ist immer froh, wenn im Westen Chaos ist. Ja, das stimmt generell.
Aber ist die Hamas, hat die nicht ihre eigene Ideologie?
Also braucht die noch mal irgendwie Putin dafür? Oder können die auch selbst
grausame Taten verrichten? Und dann hilft es einfach, bei richtigen Experten nachzulesen.
Richard C. Schneider zum Beispiel, der hat in den Blättern jetzt einen sehr
guten Artikel geschrieben.
Israel's 9-11 heißt der. Und da schreibt er, dass der Angriff ausgerechnet der zum 50.
Jahrestag des Yom Kippur-Kriegs erfolgte, dürfte kein Zufall sein.
Vermutlich führte die Hamas ihren Angriff sehr bewusst fast exakt an diesem Tag durch. Damals am 6.
Oktober 1973 waren Armee und Regierung auf den Angriff der syrischen und ägyptischen
Armeen nicht vorbereitet.
Drei Tage später stand der jüdische Staat am Rande der Niederlage nur mit größter
Mühe in erbitterten Kämpfen und mithilfe einer Luftbrücke von den USA Israel
mit Waffen und Ersatzteilen.
Dank derer die Armee ihren ungeheuren Materialverlust wettmachen konnte,
gelang es den Israelis die größte Katastrophe doch noch abzuwenden.
Doch der Preis war hoch. Mehr als 2600 israelische Soldaten fielen,
über 7000 wurden verletzt.
So, da würde ich sagen, diese historische Kontextualisierung ist sehr sinnvoll.
Klingt plausibel. Putins Geburtstag. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Ja, nur wenn man das jetzt wieder aufwirft, kriegt man natürlich,
also wir hätten jetzt jetzt als Tweet geschrieben, dann würden wir wahrscheinlich
jetzt ganz viele Antworten bekommen, wie auch in Russland gerade,
wie soll man sagen, anti-jüdische Programme versucht werden.
Ja. Also Kameras so dabei sind, wenn da so ein Mob einfach durch die Straßen zieht.
Also es gibt natürlich diesen Antisemitismus, der überall jetzt getriggert wird
durch diesen, weil es eben nicht kontextlos geschieht, sondern weil es diese
Kontexte gibt, wird es alles wieder warm. wieder warm, wie so ein Eimer in die
Mikrowelle geschoben, der ganze Ausgang fliegt einmal durchgehitzt.
Und ja, über, also wenn man das so eine Woche lang sich damit befasst,
käme man wahrscheinlich zu dem
Schluss, dass Agnes Strack-Zimmermann doch wieder recht hatte mit sowas.
Aber sie hat sich das einfach nur so mal schnell aus den Fingern geleiert,
so als kleiner Medienstunt.
Und da spielt man dann so mit dem Feuer, das ist wirklich merkwürdig.
Und nicht zu wenig davon in Russland gibt es ja nicht zu leugnen.
Aber die Hamas ist da schon ganz alleine für zuständig.
Und diese Ideologie ist nicht von Putin dahin geschleppt worden,
zum Gaza-Streifen, sondern das haben die schon sich selbst kreiert.
Aber ja, das ist katastrophal, wenn man diese Diskussionen verfolgt.
Und ich muss, also vielleicht können wir uns auch mal, es ist ja ganz,
es sind so viele Aspekte.
Was mich vor allem jetzt mal diskursiv interessiert hat,
war wir hatten im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine so eine neue,
für uns recht merkwürdige Allianz von NATO-Falken, von Linksliberalen und den
Boken, die alle sagten mehr Waffenlieferung oder überhaupt Waffenlieferung. Jetzt haben wir.
Den Angriff der Hamas und haben dann auch einige Tage später entsprechende Reaktionen von Israel.
Und dieses Lager, das da erst in völliger Eintracht war, ist nun zerstritten,
zerteilt, bekriegt sich, bekämpft sich auf Twitter und sonst wo, ganz erbittert.
Und das hat mich ja erst mal gewundert, was ist da also los?
Wer da eben noch freundschaftlich beieinander stand, ist sich jetzt Spinnenein?
Und vielleicht kann man das schon mal versuchen, ein bisschen aufzudröseln.
Dass wir ja auf der einen Seite immer noch, sagen wir mal, Leute haben,
die NATO-Positionen vertreten.
Ich glaube, dass wir dann aber im anderen Lager,
also die jetzt ganz gegen die Interventionen von Israel sind,
die aber zuvor für Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine waren und so weiter,
deren Argumentation ist ja eine andere.
Das sind ja die aus der Woken Decolonize Bewegung, ja?
Und die sagen ja, Putin ist ein Kolonisator und deswegen Decolonize Ukraine.
Und die machen aber jetzt auch diesen Kurzschluss, Israel ist der Kolonisator,
also Decolonize Palestine.
Und deswegen sind jetzt dieselben, die also noch eben zusammen mit Karlo Massala
mehr Waffen gefordert haben,
stehen ihm jetzt nicht mehr wohlgesinnt gegenüber, weil die jetzt die colonize
sagen und das ist ja etwas, was sich dann durch auch nochmal aufsplittert in
verschiedene Kräfte, aber daran kann man glaube ich auch sehen, warum,
Die Fridays for Future Bewegung, also die globale und die deutsche,
die jetzt gerade gespalten sind, weil wir von Fridays for Future global dieses
Decolonize Programm gefahren bekommen, das ja auch an amerikanischen Universitäten ganz populär ist.
Wir haben ja über das Buch von Susan Nyman auch geredet, also diese Art der Identitätspolitik.
Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir dann die deutsche Fridays for Future-Bewegung,
die nicht so sehr von diesem Deutsch-Colonialist-Gedanken geprägt ist.
Die dann sagt, nee, nee, also wir müssen auch hier Klarheit schaffen und können
nicht einfach nur so einen Israeler-Stater plötzlich darstellen.
Und da merkt man, wie jetzt alles so, was erst mal durch den Krieg in der Ukraine
gekittet wurde, was jetzt gerade so diskursiv völlig auseinanderbricht und was
dann natürlich auch eine große Verwirrung stiftet.
Genau. Und Verwirrung ist ja das Gegenteil von Orientierung.
Und Orientierung ist ja besonders schwer, wenn es so dramatisch wird.
Und eine dieser großen Dramen ist ja, dass wir das so auf zwei Ebenen haben.
Wir haben so diese erste Beobachtungsebene und dann sofort diese Reflexionsebene,
eine drüber, wo dann solche neuen Assoziationen, Allianzen, Phalanxen,
wie auch immer, durch Kommunikations-Auffährten auf Twitter und so weiter durchgeprügelt werden.
So, und wenn dieses Verhältnis zwischen erster und zweiter Beobachter-Ebene
unklar ist, gerät alles durcheinander. Und das erleben wir ja immer wieder.
Und von daher lohnt es sich, glaube ich, hier mal auf dieser ersten Beobachterebene,
was allerdings ein bisschen belastend ist,
weil man dann wirklich darüber reden muss, was zum Beispiel diese Bildleute,
diese Bildjournalisten, muss man ja jetzt wieder sagen, viele kommentieren,
aber der eine oder andere Bildjournalist ist ja doch vor Ort und ist dann auch
in diesen Leichenkammern, wo einfach die Opfer in Israel da mal,
wo man so ein bisschen erfährt, was da vorgefallen ist.
Also wie grausam. Ich habe es auch wirklich mir nur selbst angeteasert und habe
es sofort wieder dann sein lassen. Genau.
Also man kann einfach nur sich das anschauen, um dann möglichst schnell für
sich so eine Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, von all den Sachen und wir haben ja nun keine.
Arme Geschichte an Ereignissen, was Gewalt gegen Juden angeht.
Das geht ja zurück ins Mittelalter, wo man, das sieht man heute noch in so Burgen
oder so, in so Folterkellern wieder gegen einzelne Menschen, was angestellt wurde.
Und eigentlich dachte man ja, okay, das ist so Geschichte, Geschichtsbuch,
das ist nicht mal Schwarz-Weiß-Fotografie oder so, sondern das ist so lange her.
Man kriegt es eigentlich gar nicht mal visualisiert, sondern steht nur noch
in so einem Volltagkeller aus dem 8. Jahrhundert und denkt sich so,
okay, also das ist so weit weg.
Ich bin jetzt nicht wie, also ich habe jetzt keinen physischen Mitvollzug davon,
weil das ist nicht gestern hier in Aktion gewesen oder so.
Ich renne jetzt nicht durch Abu Ghraib, sondern das ist Geschichte.
Und jetzt stellt man fest, ah, ist vielleicht doch nicht so Geschichte.
Also das, was man da hört, scheinen ja doch dann so die schlimmsten Gräueltaten
zu unseren Lebzeiten zu sein.
Wenn man sagt, okay, auch in afrikanischen Konflikten oder so,
wo es auch krasse Massaker gab. Aber da gab es nicht so dieses gezielte auf
die eine Person mit der absoluten Demütigung, die Humanisierung und so weiter
und so fort. Also da haben wir es ja so ein Ausmaß zu tun.
Das ist nicht hier ein Amokschutz der Leute, weil das tut etwas,
was schlimm genug ist. Aber hier werden bestialische Taten, Folter und alles verübt.
Nicht nur gegen Menschen, sondern dann auch wirklich gegen die Menschheit oder
wie wir im Deutschen sagen so die Menschlichkeit.
Wie nennt man das? diese juristische Dingsdabums, Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit, da heißt es ja.
Und dieses Ausmaß zu haben, ist ja schon mal, also das ist ja einfach so ein
Fakt für sich. Den kann man auch wirklich, das ist der 7.
Oktober, so wie wir den 11. September einfach als Datum so markieren.
Und da haben wir es mit solchen Verbrechen zu tun, bei denen man auch wieder
sagen muss, selbst wenn wir das jetzt kontextualisieren im Sinne von,
wir behandeln das als Kriegsakt oder sowas. Also wenn man so sagt,
die Hamas hat angegriffen, dann ist das ja so im Kontext der, okay.
Kennen wir ja, Putin hat auch irgendwo angegriffen, es gab so einen Überfall.
Und dann stellt man ja immer fest, ah ja, eigentlich haben wir ja da noch so
Regeln, Völkerrecht, Kriegsrecht, gehen wir damit um. Und dann sehen wir aber,
nee, die Hamas hat aber gezielt genau diese Regeln verletzt.
Also das war das Ziel, diese Regeln einfach zu zeigen, diese Regeln,
also macht man überhaupt Gefangene? Dann wie geht man damit um?
Schlachtet man das auch noch mal mit Jahres zusätzlich raus?
Es ist ein asymmetrischer Krieg und der wird geführt auch.
Also das ist noch nicht mal ein asymmetrischer Krieg. Deswegen hat es das Prokromhafte,
weil hier ja nicht eine Guerillatruppe losläuft, um Soldaten der anderen Partei umzubringen.
Genau, gerade nicht. Wir haben genau das Gegenteil. Wir haben einen Bogen um Soldaten gemacht.
Wir gehen in Wohnhäuser, wir gehen auf ein Fest, wo Menschen feiern und vernichten dort.
Genau, also da ging es wirklich um Vernichtung, nicht nur von Menschen,
sondern auch von Ideologien und Geschichten und so weiter.
Immer mit dem Wissen, das wird auch medial in unserem Sinne ausgebeutet,
um nicht zu sagen ausgeschlachtet.
Also ich habe bei der New York Times einmal, da haben sie so eine Analyse gemacht.
In der Woche vorm 7. Oktober hatte die Hamas auf Telegram so eine Reichweite
pro Post von 30.000 oder so. Und dann eine Woche später 300.000, 500.000.
Also ein unglaublicher Aufmerksamkeitszuwachs für die Hamas,
das ist dann auch keine exponentielle Entwicklung der Reichweite gewesen,
sondern einfach einmal rein explodiert in die ganze Welt.
Man kann ja ungefähr, wenn man jetzt die Zahlen so überschlägt,
1400 konkrete Opfer zahlen in der Anzahl, aber mindestens eine Milliarde Menschen,
die sich damit befassen.
Also ich würde das einfach abends in den Nachrichten sehen, wo man sagen muss,
ja, das ist dann einfach Faktor Million. Also man hat einfach zwischen Gewalt
und Terror, also diese mediale Schiene, hat der Hamas einfach so einen Faktor
von einer Million eingebaut.
Was ja nun wirklich das Ausmaß mal zeigt. So und jetzt ist die Frage,
wie geht man denn mit sowas um?
Wir haben jetzt schon so ein bisschen kritisiert, wie wir in Deutschland gesehen
haben, wie man damit umgeht.
Damit umgehen. Ich will mal, und will es ausdrücklich sagen,
also dieses Thema ist jetzt, auch wenn wir häufiger so Spielereien machen mit
dem einen oder anderen Thema, hier ist mal keine Spielerei.
Also ich spiele jetzt ein Clip von Holger, der für Übermedien sein typisches
Ich-rufe-mal-wo-an bei einem Experten, der und dann wird so ein 20-minütiges
mediales Reflexionsgespräch einfach geführt zum Thema AfD, AfD in Talkshows oder sonstiges.
Also wir kennen ja, Holger ruft an bei Übermedien.
Und Holger stellt hier mal so eine Frage, Von der ich denke,
das ist eigentlich erstaunlich, wie sehr man in 13 Sekunden alle Paradoxien
einmal unterbringen kann.
Also einmal alles, was eigentlich zu entfalten ist, so ablädt einfach.
Diese Polarisierung, die scheint ja bei keinem anderen Thema stärker zu sein.
Warum ist das so? Und vor allen Dingen auch gerade jetzt. Es ist doch gerade
völlig klar, wer angegriffen hat und wer angegriffen wurde.
So. Also, er kritisiert die Polarisierung. Es gibt Alternative A und Alternative
B, über eine Sache nachzudenken.
Und eigentlich, wenn wir Polarisierung kritisieren, dann benennen wir auch A
und B und fragen, wo ist denn der dritte Weg dazwischen? So,
und das macht er schon mal nicht.
Sondern er bleibt ganz beim A und legt das dann sogar noch mal mit so einer
gewissen ... Es ist doch völlig klar, dass A gilt und nicht B.
Wir haben jetzt schon im Kontext dieser Ukraine-Berichterstattung festgestellt,
für uns ist das total klar, dass A gilt. Aber der globale Süden denkt dann doch
irgendwie anders. Wir können uns das so gar nicht erklären.
Wenn unsere A-Politiker unserem A-Publikum, also uns, noch mal Botschaft A sagen
im Fernsehen, dann kriegt das die B-Seite nicht mal mit.
Eigentlich verstehen wir, kein Wunder, in Indien haben die vielleicht andere Probleme.
Sind irgendwie 45 Grad und die brauchen Öl und so weiter und wir stellen uns
so fest, da leiden einfach 200 Millionen Kinder unter Hitze und kriegen schon
Durchblutungsstörungen und so, klar kaufen die Öl in Russland,
um ihre Klimaanlagen zu betreiben.
Also eigentlich super simple, verständliche Sachen, die dann trotzdem so radikal aussortiert werden,
dass uns A-Leute die A-Alternative nennen und sich nochmal fragen,
warum das nicht jeder einsieht, dass A gilt, obwohl es ja eine Sekunde Nachdenken
gebraucht, um zu feststellen, ah, globaler Kontext.
Ich verstehe dein Argument, aber zugleich erleben wir auch nicht von der anderen
Seite, also von der B-Seite, dass die bereit ist, die A-Seite anzuerkennen.
Also ich sage das jetzt genauso pauschal, wie du das jetzt eben gemacht hast,
aber das erleben wir auch nicht und damit sind wir bei dieser Polarisierung,
wo wir das ja dann in diesen Kämpfen in Social Media nur so mal so leicht nachvollziehen können.
Aber wir haben ja schon den Punkt eigentlich, dass die Welt als Ganzes ja immer
eine Illusion war, dass sie gemeinschaftlich agiert.
Aber ich glaube, die Spaltung, die alles durchzieht, die ist doch jetzt so sichtbar wie selten.
Und das liegt sicherlich auch daran, dass die westliche Vormachstellung nicht mehr so stark ist,
also dass die anderen einfach mitziehen aus ökonomischen, geopolitischen Gründen,
sondern jetzt sagen, Wir machen hier unsere B-Seite, macht ihr eure A-Seite,
aber wir kriegen das eigentlich nicht mehr zusammen.
Und ich glaube, das ist ja der Punkt, dass wir zwar selbst hier jetzt,
zum Beispiel wir zwei hier in diesem Podcast, durchaus mal eine B-Seite bespielen
können, aber ich das tatsächlich von der anderen Seite ja auch nicht sehe,
dass da eine B-Seite bespielt wird.
Deswegen nennt man es ja Polarisierung. Ganz richtig. Also man stellt noch fest, es gibt zwei Seiten.
Und man ist aber gleichzeitig für sich so positioniert. Und das macht aber nur
Sinn, weil es noch jemand anderen gibt, woanders, der sich halt anders positioniert.
So, wir haben ja von Dominique de Villepin, former Prime Minister of France,
also der ehemalige Regierungschef von Frankreich, hat ein Fernsehinterview gegeben,
in dem er den Occidentalismus erklärt.
Und die fragt dann so nach, was meinen Sie denn damit und so weiter.
Es gibt es leider wirklich nur auf Französisch. Hier hätte man jetzt gerne diese
AI-Übersetzung, in der das schon mal auch in dem Tonfall von ihm so übersetzt wird.
Aber der Occidentalismus ist die Idee des Westens, dass man die eigene Vormachtstellung
eben nicht mehr reflektiert, sondern einfach immer so als selbstverständlich mitlaufen lässt.
Während wir jetzt feststellen, wir haben es ja häufiger thematisiert,
es ist nicht so, dass die Globalisierung gerade endet, sondern es ist nur die
westliche Globalisierung. Es ist jetzt Chinas Globalisierung.
Oder wie Adam Tooze sagt, naja, es gibt schon immer noch Kriege auf der Welt,
aber der Westen sucht sie sich halt nicht mehr aus, sondern sie werden ihm herangetragen.
Plötzlich macht halt Putin Krieg und der Westen muss trotzdem mitkämpfen.
Und man sagt dann, wir ignorieren das oder so. Sondern diese Vormachtstellung
unserer Alternative A auf der A-Seite der Welt kriegt jetzt so einen Grundbegriff
mit diesem Occidentialismus.
Wir hier im Occident und so weiter, weil wir dann schon verstehen,
es gibt ja einen Orient und so.
Also die muslimische Welt oder wie auch immer, kann man dann sofort so eine
Assoziationskette starten. Man versteht dann, okay, der globale Süden,
als die jetzt so meinten in der Ukraine mit der Solidaritätsbekundung,
das haut nicht so ganz hin.
Aber wenn man das jetzt mal so nimmt, ich habe sehr viel darüber nachgedacht.
Es gab ja dann sehr bald den beiden Besuch und Blinken und mir schien es so,
dass vor allem Blinken da die Federführung hat und beiden wirkte er sehr sehr
müde, machte aber erst einmal deutlich, bitte wiederholt nicht unsere Fehler vom 11.
September und das hat mich erst einmal sehr.
Erstaunt, dass das so öffentlich so ausgesprochen wird.
Also erst mal, dass die Fehler nochmal benannt werden, die eigenen damit und
aber auch so eine direkte Warnung vorgetragen wurde an Israel,
denn das ist ziemlich explizit, würde ich sagen.
Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, dass wir so eine Verschiebung haben,
wo der der Occidentalismus oder wie man es nennen will,
nicht mehr derart einflussreich ist, könnte man da nicht tatsächlich auch zu
der Schlussfolgerung kommen, dass also jetzt gerade die Existenz Israels gefährdeter ist denn je.
Also sind wir nicht tatsächlich, weil ich muss sagen, ich bin wirklich kein
Experte, ich ist vielleicht nicht ganz so wie bei Harald Schmidt,
aber mein Wissen ist gering, was das anbelangt.
Aber ich hatte mir nie Sorgen um Israel in dem Sinne gemacht,
also im Sinne einer Existenzgefährdung, sondern ja, ich wusste,
wie schlimm mitunter Terrorangriffe dort sind, wie prekär die Situation grundsätzlich
in einem Land ist, dass sehr stark angegriffen wird.
Aber ich hatte nie so diese grundsätzliche Angst, dass Israel nicht mehr da sein könnte.
Und wenn man jetzt zwar US-Unterstützung hat und wir gehen ja auch gleich darauf
ein, dass wir sicherlich auch Das kann nicht alles gut heißen,
was da jetzt passiert als Gegenschlag.
Aber man kann ja dann doch, wenn man sich diese Verschiebung ansieht und auch
wie schnell sie ging und das noch ein paar Jahre weiterdenkt,
tatsächlich sich fragen, wie existenziell prekär der Status von Israel ist.
Also auch da will ich wieder methodologisch noch mal markieren.
Wenn wir über diese zweite Beobachter-Ebene, wo so reflektiert wird,
und wir kommen gar nicht auf die erste, Reden heißt es nicht,
dass wir irgendwas auf der ersten Ebene, wo die Gräueltaten stattfanden, und zwar am 7.
Oktober, wo man auch sagen kann, ja, das kann man erstmal auch sprachlos so
hinnehmen, ohne auf den 6.
Oktober oder den 8. zu schauen, der 7. Oktober steht dann wirklich für sich,
so wie der 11. September. Kann man jetzt sagen, ok.
Haken dran, jetzt auf der zweiten Beobachter-Ebene, ja, dieses Paradox ist wirklich
wahnsinnig interessant und begegnet uns immer wieder, beispielsweise auch in
der politischen Diskussion in Deutschland.
Was ist jetzt besser für den Wohlstand Deutschlands, wenn wir an der alten Technologie
so lange wie möglich festhalten und sagen, okay, die FDP hat da irgendwie einen
Punkt mit ihrem Verbrenner-Ding, weil es ist ja unsere Technologie,
damit sind wir irgendwie weltweit führend und so.
Und dann kommen aber die Grünen und sagen, nee, um an dem Wohlstand festhalten zu können,
müssen wir so schnell wie möglich in die neuen Technologien,
mit denen wir dann nämlich die alten,
weil weltweit werden die abgelöst, auch in Deutschland so ablösen,
dass wir unsere technologische Vormachtstellung wieder als Exportmodell und
nicht einfach aussortiert werden wie Kodak, wenn die digitale Fotografie kommt
und so weiter. So es gilt also irgendwie beides.
Also Lager A und Lager B kann irgendwie sagen, nee wir brauchen E-Fuels und
nee wir brauchen jetzt neue Antriebe und so. Und so ist das hier natürlich auch.
Denn ehrlich gesagt, und da müssen wir alle sagen, wir sind alle auf Niveau
von Harald Schmidt und sollten uns das auch eingestehen, aber wenn man so ein
bisschen überlegt, was wollte die Hamas eigentlich?
Und die hat es ja wirklich für sich organisiert.
Schon allein um es vor dem israelischen Geheimdienst geheim zu halten,
konnten sie auch im Iran niemandem Bescheid sagen. Also Also auch dieses Boller
im Libanon da unter iranischer Fuchtel war wahrscheinlich sehr überrascht,
dass das gerade stattfindet und war auch gerade nicht einsatzfähig oder was auch immer.
Also du meinst, dass die das nicht wussten?
Ich weiß es ja nicht. Ich sehe nur...
Aber du würdest tippen, dass das eigentlich nur so lange geheim gehalten werden
kann, wenn man es nicht den anderen vereint. Ja genau.
Also wir kennen ja dieses Prinzip, wir brauchen da Schläferzellen und da wissen
dann die Typen selber nicht...
Weil danach war die iranische Regierung hat sich ja sofort mit der Hamas da gemeingetan.
Das ist ja immer. Also irgendwo basiert ein Anschlag und dann erklärt der IS
erstmal, also das waren wir.
Wir sind so klug, wir sind so gut, das ist dann dieses Google-Argument,
ja wir können Börsenkurse voraussagen, aber wir machen es nicht,
weil wir ethisch da Vorbehalte haben, wo man sich denkt, ach ja ihr seid so
klug, dass ihr Börsenkurse, dann investiere ich mal gleich in Google und so weiter.
Also diese Verstrickung über drei Ebenen und Banden spielen,
um da irgendwie sich in ein entsprechendes Licht zu stellen.
Ich finde es jedenfalls sehr erstaunlich, dass wir mehrere Kontexte,
kann man jetzt mal reinholen, Putin überfällt die Ukraine und wir sagen,
ja, aber das mit den Atombomben ist eine echte Drohung.
Und dann kommen Leute von außen und sagen, ne, der blufft doch nur.
Und dann sagen wir, ja, aber wie wollen wir das jetzt herausfinden?
Also wollen wir jetzt warten, dass die Atombombe auf Stuttgart fällt und dann
sagen wir, ja, guck mal, wir hatten recht irgendwie.
Wir hatten ja damals dieses tolle Katharina-Bahle-Interview,
in dem sie erst erklärt, dass Putin völlig irrational ist und danach gefragt
wird, ist denn diese Bedrohung durch die Atombombe real? Nee,
nee, also der ist völlig irrational.
Also wir sind ja nicht in der Stammzeit-Vorstellung, wo wir unendlich viel Material
haben, in dem wir immer wieder in der Laborsituation nacheinander testen können,
was jetzt funktioniert.
Das ist das eine. Und das andere ist, wir haben dieses Verhinderungsparadox
ja eigentlich kennengelernt während der Corona-Pandemie, was ja jetzt auch wieder gilt.
Wir sehen jetzt am 30.
Oktober, okay, es regnete noch nicht 30.000 Raketen aus Iran und Libanon usw. auf Tel Aviv.
Wie wurde das denn eigentlich verhindert? Nachdem wir doch den Muslimen immer
so viel Wut, Antisemitismus usw. unterstellen. Und dann noch feststellen,
wir kriegen es nicht mal in Deutschland contained, also in Teheran erst recht nicht.
Wir können natürlich jetzt Appelle machen, bitte Leute in Teheran,
seid mal nicht so antisemitisch.
Aber warum flogen jetzt nicht aus Rache um Gaza 30.000 Raketen nach Tel Aviv?
Und da würde ich mal sagen, ja, das ist die Sternstunde der viele Diplomatie,
die da einfach stattfand. Und da blinken beiden, blinken irgendwie mit 13 Stops
an sieben Tagen in neun Ländern, was niemand mitbekommt, weil das nicht reportiert wird.
Man achtet dann auf die Lippenbekenntnisse deutscher Politiker,
zu denen wir gleich kommen, zu denen muss man sehr viel sagen.
Sondern da wurde wirklich jetzt mal wieder die absolute Eskalation verhindert.
Und wieder stehen die Leute daneben und behaupten einfach, ne,
die hätten ja da nicht angegriffen.
Die würden sich das nie trauen, Israel anzugreifen. Weil wir verteidigen ja so toll.
Und ich denke, seid ihr wirklich sicher, dass so ein Michael-Roth-Spruch,
wie wir ihn gleich hören werden, irgendwem in Israel hilft oder darin bestärkt
zu glauben, ah ja, zur Not sind die Deutschen da mit, ja was denn,
die schicken dann wieder 5000 Helme oder was.
Also in Israel wurde auch gerade ein großer Vernichtungsfeldzug durch iranische
Kräfte und so weiter verhindert,
ohne dass das mal reflektiert und dann auch mit so einer gewissen Dankbarkeit
gegenüber so diesen Leuten, die das halt gerade machen.
So und das ist wahrscheinlich nicht Annalena Baerbock, so wie man sieht,
sondern das sind dann wirklich diese Hardcore-Diplomaten um Linken und so weiter.
Ganz erstaunlich im Übrigen, ich habe dann über diesen Monat sehr,
sehr viele Tageszeitungsartikel gelesen und muss noch mal herausstellen,
wie toll das war in der Financial Times.
Da wird dann doch sehr nüchtern darüber gesprochen, sehr realistisch wie mir
scheint und vor allem blickt man so sehr auf dieses Diplomatische,
was gelingen kann und was nicht gelungen ist.
Und da wurde auch dann mitunter der Biden-Kurs kritisiert, beziehungsweise sagte
man, naja, ob das so erfolgreich war?
Wenn man bedenkt, als es dann diesen scheinbaren Anschlag da gab mit dem Krankenhaus,
daraufhin hat ja dann Jordanien, haben alle anderen abgesagt,
mit Biden zu kommunizieren.
Dann hat man das von der Financial Times eher als eine Niederlage Bidens aufgegriffen.
Dann gibt es aber wieder andere, die sagen, nee, das ist jetzt gerade sehr erfolgreich
eigentlich, wie das läuft. Und das hätte man gar nicht geglaubt,
dass das nochmal so gut funktioniert.
Da sind wir natürlich auch im Dunkeln am Stochern, weil wir nicht einen Einblick
in die Diplomatie haben, aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass hier die Diplomatie
wirklich ganz, ganz viel erreicht, was ja bei dem Krieg.
In der Ukraine erfraglich ist. Da haben wir ein großes diplomatisches Versagen.
Hier ist es nicht zu konstatieren. Wir haben es auch mit einer anderen Konstellation
zu tun. Manche ziehen direkte Vergleiche.
Die, die für Verhandlungen waren, sind auch jetzt für Verhandlungen.
Die Konstellation ist eine sehr viel schwierigere. Wir haben es ja bei der Ukraine und bei Russland.
Mit zwei souveränen Staaten zu tun, wo sich theoretisch Zelensky und Putin an
einem Tisch setzen können und dann müssen die irgendeinen Kompromiss schließen.
Während wir es natürlich hier mit einer hoch brisanten Situation zu tun haben,
wo wir einen souveränen Staat haben, nämlich Israel.
So und dann haben wir ja wen denn? Die Hamas, wir haben Abbas,
der wie man irgendwie in jedem zweiten Artikel liest, offenbar nur noch schläft.
Wir haben dann noch andere palästinensischen Bürgervertretungen.
Also müsste man schon fragen, müsste da die UN dann mit rein?
Mit wem verhandelt man da eigentlich? Also dadurch wird die Verhandlungslage
natürlich viel, viel intrikater, als es tendenziell möglich wäre zwischen Russland und der Ukraine.
Genau, so und das bedeutet jetzt wieder, ich koppel das jetzt wieder zurück
auf unseren methodologischen Einschlag von eben, erste und zweite Ebene.
Und an Holgis Clip, also der erste Teil von Holger war ja, warum sind wir so polarisiert?
Und da würde ich sagen, ja, weil wir Beobachter zweiter Ebene sind.
Also die Welt, in der wir leben, findet nun mal im Fernsehen statt und wir wissen,
wir sind nicht die einzigen Zuschauer.
Und andere sehen das vielleicht anders und dann müssen wir mit denen darüber
reden. reden. Und dann sagt er, es ist doch völlig klar, wer angegriffen hat
so. Und dieser, nur dieser Teil, es ist doch völlig klar, ist dieser auf erster Beobachterebene.
Also die Gräueltaten an sich. Und da würde ich auch sagen, da kann man einfach
sagen, der siebte Oktober.
Und dann schaut man sich die Sachen an und dann kann einem wirklich kurz egal
sein, was den Tag davor und den Tag danach wichtig ist, sondern das fand statt
und es steht jetzt auch so in den Geschichtsbüchern.
Und zwar richtig in diesem Maße, wie wir heute über 800 Jahre vergangene Geschichtsereignisse
irgendwie, uns da noch Filme anschauen, die in 500 Jahren erst geplant und vielleicht
in 700 Jahren mal umgesetzt werden. Also so steht das jetzt in den Geschichtsbüchern.
Nur es ist eben trotzdem jetzt geschriebene Geschichte.
Es ist die Geschichte des siebten Oktober.
Auf zweiter Beobachterebene verhandeln wir aber jetzt gerade, was morgen am 31.
Oktober passiert. Und das steht eben noch nicht in den Geschichtsbüchern,
sondern Debatte, Diskurs und so weiter. Da kommt alles zum Tragen,
was politisch bedeutsam ist.
Und da würde ich eben auch sagen, wenn dann Holger fragt, warum ist das denn
so polarisiert? Ja, weil der 7.
Oktober ist, wie heute beschrieben wird und wie es in den Geschichtsbüchern
steht, für Israelis, ihr 11.
September oder ein neuer Auswuchs des Holocaust oder...
Welche Programme dann auch immer man nimmt. Es gibt ja dann noch Spezialkenntnisse,
die wir jetzt gar nicht so haben.
Also da wird ja anders erinnert, als wir, die wir ja auch in dieses jüdische
Leben und die jüdische Geschichte sehr tief einprogrammiert in unser deutsches Denken haben.
Da wird ja noch mal eine eigene Geschichtsschreibung betrieben.
Aber es gilt eben auch zum Thema Polarisierung, der 8. bis 13.
Oktober, also das innerhalb von einer Woche so viele Bomben auf Gaza abgeworfen
werden, wie im allerersten Jahr Afghanistan, auf Afghanistan.
Und damit ist mehr Zeit, aber auch mehr Raum genannt. Also Afghanistan ist ein riesiges Land.
Also da haben wir es auch in der B-Seite dieser Polarisierung mit Beschreibungen zu tun wie,
ja, das Schicksal Gazas in dieser Woche war eben das von Dresden am Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs oder von Hiroshima,
aber nicht als eine Atombombe, sondern und wir wissen ja auch Israel ist eine
Atommacht, also wir haben das zweite Mal mit einem Konflikt zu tun,
in dem eine Atommacht verwickelt ist und so weiter und so fort.
So und diese Art von Polarisierung kriegen wir einfach weder aufgelöst noch abgelöst.
Das ist halt einfach so. Das muss dann auch Holger einfach akzeptieren und alle seine Zuhörer.
Ja, der 7. Oktober steht für sich auf erster Beobachterebene.
Also da, wo wir einfach davor stehen, wie in New York vor den Gräben,
die da einfach gelassen wurden zur Anschauung des 11.
Septembers. Auf zweiter Beobachterebene entspinnt sich aber danach eine Geschichte,
die wir mal live verhandeln. Und da gab es natürlich auch eine Vorgeschichte.
Und es gab einfach vor dem 7. Oktober Geschichte.
Die muss man dann weder erklärerisch noch kontextualisieren noch irgendwas in
Verbindung bringen wollen.
Aber man kann nicht einfach jetzt mit so einem Impetus rangehen,
ja, wenn ich eine politische Diskussion machen will, blende ich einfach den
6. Oktober aus. Also das macht einfach gar keinen Sinn.
Und das ist ja das Angebot, das Carsten Linnemann macht, also er will ja alles ausblenden.
Und antizipiert schon die Geschichte, vielleicht können wir uns diesen Clip
mal kurz anhören, er war bei Lanz zu Gast und sagt also im Zuge des 7.
Oktober, was jetzt zu antizipieren ist und wie man sich zu verhalten hat.
Das gemacht hat, Herr Massala, der gesagt hat, ich erwarte jetzt von euch Solidarität,
dass das, was in den nächsten Tagen passiert, und das wird hart,
ich habe eben im Zug den Fehler gemacht, mir so ein Video auch mal anzuschauen,
mache ich nie wieder, weil das macht ja was mit unserem Gehirn.
Wir versuchen natürlich, Unschuldige nicht zu treffen, aber natürlich wird es
passieren und wir müssen so hart zurückschlagen, dass niemand auch nur im Ansatz
auf den Gedanken kommt, nochmals Israel anzugreifen.
Und das wird hart. Und diese Solidarität erwarte ich von Ihnen.
Und wir haben geklatscht, wir haben Respekt gezollt. Und ich hab wirklich Gänsehaut bekommen.
Ja, also was er jetzt uns hier erzählt ... Also, er hat Gänsehaut bekommen,
toll, prima. Aber was er uns jetzt hier erzählt, ist ...
Israel wird einen Gegenangriff starten. Und auch wenn das ganz schlimm werden
sollte, also die Folgen, die dieser Gegenangriff hat, das heißt,
viele tote Zivilisten, dann ist das quasi der Prüfstein unserer Solidarität,
dass wir das nicht kritisieren.
Und da fragt man sich dann schon, was ist das für ein eigenartiges Bild?
Also ich meine, wir haben diese Debatte ganz, ganz stark auf Twitter von Leuten.
Ja, zu denen gehört ja dann Massala und zu denen gehört Linnemann,
die uns seit 600 Tagen eigentlich erzählen, dass die Ukraine morgen den Krieg gewinnt.
Und die eigentlich auch wissen, dass ein Krieg gegen den Terror nicht zu gewinnen
ist, wie wir in Afghanistan etc. gesehen haben.
Also man muss es krasser sagen, er produziert den Terror.
Oder produziert den Terror, ja. Und dass man jetzt da schon im Vorhinein eigentlich
sagt, wir rechtfertigen, was immer geschieht.
Und das ist eine sehr, sehr schlimme Debatte, weil wir werden ja gleich Clips dazu haben.
Also ich finde, wir sollten wirklich strenger mit Lennemann umgehen.
Denn so ein Denken wie, egal was passiert, diese Menschen müssen weg,
ist das, was zum Holocaust geführt hat.
Und nicht als Erlösung davon weg.
Ja, das ist, als hättest du dich auf meinen Text vorbereitet.
Ich war sehr erstaunt, man liest ja dann zum Beispiel noch mal Adorno,
weil der Antisemitismus zurück ist in Deutschland und ich erlaube mir,
dass ich das vorlese aus der Minima Moralia und zwar,
Schreibt er nämlich dort etwas, und du hast uns jetzt gerade dahin gebracht.
Er sagt, wer, wie das so heißt, in der Praxis steht, Interessen zu verfolgen,
Pläne zu verwirklichen hat, dem verwandeln die Menschen, mit denen er in Berührung
kommt, automatisch sich in Freund und Feind.
Indem er sie daraufhin ansieht, wie sie seinen Absichten sich einfügen,
reduziert er sie gleichsam vorweg zu Objekten.
Die einen sind verwendbar, die anderen hinderlich.
Jede abweichende Meinung erscheint auf dem Bezugssystem je einmal vorgegebener
Zwecke, ohne welches keine Praxis auskommt, als lästiger Widerstand, Sabotage, Intrige.
Jede Zustimmung und käme sie aus dem gemeinsten Interesse, wird zur Förderung
zum Brauchbaren, zum Zeugnis der Bundesgenossenschaft.
Also genau das, was hier eingefördert wird von den Mann und Co.
So tritt Verarmung im Verhältnis zu anderen Menschen ein,
die Fähigkeit, den anderen als solchen und nicht als Funktion des eigenen Willens wahrzunehmen,
vor allem aber die des fruchtbaren Gegensatzes, die Möglichkeit,
durch Einbegreifen des Widersprechenden über sich selber hinauszugehen, verkümmert.
Sie wird ersetzt durch beurteilende Menschenkenntnis, für die schließlich noch
der Beste das kleinere Übel ist und der schlechteste nicht das größte.
Diese Reaktionsweise aber, das Schema aller Administration und Personalpolitik,
tendiert bereits von sich aus vor aller politischen Willensbildung und aller
Festlegung auf ausschließende Tickets zum Faschismus.
Also wir haben es hier mit einem Text über Antisemitismus zu tun. Es geht jetzt weiter.
Wer es einmal zu seiner Sache macht, Eignung zu beurteilen, sieht die Beurteilten
aus gewissermaßen technologischer Notwendigkeit als Zugehörige oder Außenseiter,
arteigene oder artfremde, Helfer, Selfer oder Opfer.
Der Diskurs, den wir jetzt von CDU und Bild sehr stark bekommen.
Der stark prüfende, bannende und gebannte Blick, der allen Führern des Entsetzens eigen ist,
hat sein Modell im Abschätzenden des Managers, der den Stellenbewerber Platz
nehmen heißt und sein Gesicht so beleuchtet, dass es ins Helle der Verwendbarkeit
und ins Dunkel Anrüchige des Unqualifizierten erbahnungslos zerfällt.
Das Ende ist die medizinische Untersuchung nach der Alternative Arbeitseinsatz oder Liquidation.
Der neutestamentliche Satz, wer nicht für mich ist, ist wieder mich,
war von jeher dem Antisemitismus aus dem Herzen gesprochen.
Also diese Dichotomie, schreibt Adorno, war dem Antisemitismus aus dem Herzen gesprochen.
Er gehört zum Grundbestand der Herrschaft, jeden, der nicht anwesend ist.
Mit ihr sich identifiziert, um der bloßen Differenz willen ins Lager der Feinde zu verweisen.
Nicht umsonst ist Katholizismus nur ein griechisches Wort für das lateinische
Totalität, das die Nationalsozialisten realisiert haben.
Sie bedeutet die Gleichsetzung des Verschiedenen, sei es der Abweichung,
sei es des Andersrassigen, mit dem Gegner. Der Nationalsozialismus hat auch
darin das historische Bewusstsein seiner selbst erreicht.
Karl Schmitt definierte das Wesen des Politischen geradezu durch die Kategorien Freund und Feind.
Der Fortschritt zu solchem Bewusstsein macht die Regression auf die Verhaltensweise
des Kindes sich zu eigen, das gern hat oder sich fürchtet.
Die a priorische Reduktion auf das Freund-Feind-Verhältnis ist eines der Urphänomene
der neuen Anthropologie.
Freiheit wäre, nicht zwischen schwarz und weiß zu wählen, sondern aus solcher
vorgeschriebenen Wahl herauszutreten.
Und diese vorgeschriebene Wahl, die präsentiert uns hier Linnemann.
Womit wir ja wieder beim Universalismus sind. Wir haben ihn ja schon ein paar
Mal besprochen und der Autor ist ja Omri Böhm.
Wie heißt sein Buch? Radikaler Universalismus. Er selber als Israeli,
glaube ich, so wie Harari ja auch und viele, die wir jetzt auch noch hören,
Issa Perel und so, war natürlich jetzt auch gefragter Gesprächsgast.
Er war zum Beispiel bei der Buchvorstellung von Susan Nyman,
genau, das ist mir auch angehört.
Also war interessant, passt nur jetzt nicht zu unserem, aber er wurde natürlich
in der Sternstunde Philosophie jetzt nochmal gefragt. Ich habe es heute morgen
erst gehört, weil das jetzt am Samstag oder so im Podcatcher auftauchte.
Und Universalismus ist ja...
Eine große Idee, von der er auch sagt, ich meine das nicht deskriptiv, sondern normativ.
Es ist immer nur eine Forderung, ein Wunsch sozusagen, könnte man auch politisch sagen.
Und trotzdem bricht er sich ja runter auf so eine Handlungsmaxime,
die wir als Perspektivwechsel jetzt einfach, so wie Sloterdijk fasst,
als Übung einfordern können.
Als direkte Antwort auch von Adorno, wenn wir nämlich diesen Widersatz von wir,
die, Freund, Feind usw., dann ist es ja umso wichtiger, diese Perspektive zu übernehmen.
Und diesen Perspektivwechsel von dem Autor, der uns den Universalismus zugetragen
hat, jetzt nochmal im Kontext der Debatte, kriegen wir denn den 7.
Oktober kontextualisiert? Hören wir jetzt diesen Clip, wie er sich da äußerte.
In der Debatte erscheint ein Perspektivenwechsel schon fast schockierend,
schockierend, verstörend oder problematisch.
Wenn wir Israels Verstöße gegen das Völkerrecht verurteilen,
sofern es diese gibt und die Feststellung davon obliegt, nicht mir,
das wird ein Richter entscheiden müssen, muss auch dies in den Kontext der grausamen
Verbrechen der Hamas gegen die israelische Bevölkerung gestellt werden.
Wenn wir das nicht tun, liegen wir wieder falsch. Die Verurteilungen.
Auf erster Beobachterebene. Wir sehen diese Kräutertaten, verurteilen sie.
Die Worte, die wir verwenden, um das zu verurteilen, haben wir überhaupt nur,
weil wir vorher eine Debatte haben, aus der wir sie geschöpft haben.
Also historische Erfahrung. Was ist denn der Holocaust? Was ist denn ein Progrom?
Und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann kann man nicht einfach nur die eine Seite der Geschichte sehen,
sondern umso weiter die Sachen zurückliegen, sieht man ja, okay, zwei Seiten.
Also umso leichter fällt das ja dann. Das kann jetzt aktuell,
insbesondere vor Ort natürlich nicht abverlangt werden.
Aber die zweite Seite ist trotzdem da. Und wer sie immer ausblendet und ausblenden
möchte, das wird nur so und so weit reichen und dann kommt man eben nicht weiter.
Du hast es gerade so schön gesagt, die ist momentan nicht vor Ort.
Die kann aber hier sein. Ich will da noch, können wir noch einmal springen zu
einem Clip von mir, um daran anzugehen, ich weiß nämlich, worauf du,
glaube ich, hinaus willst.
Ich habe ein Klipp um diese beiden Sachen, und zwar würden wir mal gerade zu
diesem Yuval Noah Harari Klip, wo er sagt, man darf sich jetzt keine intellektuelle
und auch keine emotionale Faulheit erlauben. Er war da in der Zeit im Interview.
Diesen Klipp habe ich mir auch rausgesucht für später. Das ist ein sehr guter,
genau, wir hören uns zusammen.
Dann können wir nämlich sagen, warum wir vielleicht gerade die sind,
die jetzt diese beiden Sachen brauchen.
Er spricht jetzt gerade darüber, dass er mit Israelis gesprochen hat,
mit Freunden dort, und die sind natürlich von der ganzen Trauer umgeben. ...
Person after another. There is so much pain, they just want to tell you about their pain.
If for a single moment you try to point at the pain of other people,
like Palestinian civilians in Gaza, many of them are enraged and they feel completely betrayed.
Ich kann sie nicht schulden, aber psychologisch ist es für viele von ihnen einfach
unmöglich, mit etwas außer ihrer eigenen Schmerzen zu sein.
Ich denke das selbe für die Palästinenser.
Ich erwarte auch nicht, dass sie Sympathie für die Schmerzen der Israelis haben,
denn sie sind auch vollständig immerse in ihren Schmerzen.
Aber ich erwarte von Menschen, Ausländer, wie Menschen in Deutschland,
dass sie selbst nicht aus Israel oder Palästina kommen oder dort Relative haben.
Wenn nicht, wenn du nur ein Ausländer bist, dann sei nicht intellektuell lügend,
sei nicht emotional lügend, sehe nicht nur eine Teilung dieser schrecklichen
Realität, Versuche, so viel Realität wie möglich zu sehen.
Die Menschen, die in der Schmerzzeit sind, können das nicht.
Aber wir brauchen Außerirdische, um einen Platz für die Zukunft der Frieden zu halten.
Wir können diesen Platz nicht halten.
Keine emotionale und intellektuelle Faulheit, also nicht Carsten Lindemann. Ja.
Und er ist ja im Zeitgespräch, also im Gespräch mit der Zeit,
deswegen betonte er nochmal mit Absicht Deutschland.
Aber ich habe mich dann gefragt, hätte er auch so Deutschland nochmal genannt?
Weil Deutschland als Täterland nicht nur, wie man immer sagt,
eine Verantwortung hat, sondern auch so eine Erfahrung.
Dass wir nicht immer nur, okay, der Holocaust passiert, also erklären wir uns
das anhand der Vorgeschichte.
Auch Richard Wagner war ein Antisemit, dann zählen wir sie alle aus und so.
Sondern weil wir nach dem Holocaust eine Geschichte hatten.
Und jetzt eben wieder die Frage ist, 7. Oktober, was passiert denn am 7.
November? Oder so, ne? Also nach vorne gedacht. Da ist ja Harari eigentlich der Spezialtyp davor.
Dafür, weil er ja genau diese Art von Verständnis, wie man Geschichtswissenschaft benutzt hat.
Weil er sagt, die Geschichte ist, also die Geschichtswissenschaft ist nicht
die Wissenschaft des Vergangenen, sondern des Wandels.
Der kann in der Vergangenheit liegen, dann ist es für uns besonders einfach,
weil er dann zumindest festgeschrieben ist. Da können dann noch Diskussionen
über die Dokumente und Artefakte, wie soll man das denn deuten,
aber die Geschichte selbst ist erstmal geschrieben.
Aber man kann genau diese Art von Geschichtswissenschaft des Wandels eben auch für die Zukunft.
So, und die Zukunft nach einer zivilisatorischen Katastrophe,
wie sie jetzt am 7. Oktober passiert, haben wir ja schon einmal gestaltet.
Die führte jetzt nun dazu, dass wir 80 Jahre später es ein bisschen übertreiben,
wie wir bei Lindemann gehört haben, oder gleich bei Michael Roth.
Aber irgendwo da liegt ja doch ein Erfahrungswert so insgesamt,
der jetzt brauchbar ist für die Welt.
Die Welt. Also in der Hinsicht würde ich sagen, selbst wenn er jetzt nicht deutschen
Journalisten in Deutschland gegenüber säße und für ein deutsches Publikum in
der Zeit das sagte, könnte er noch mal auf Deutschland so wie eben auch explizit zu sprechen kommen.
Würde ich nämlich sagen, ja, gerade die deutschen Politiker haben eine besondere
Verantwortung jetzt nicht,
wie er sagt, emotional und intellektuell faul zu sein oder sich einfach aus
Solidarität auf der ersten Beobachter-Ebene zu verfangen und diesen Schritt
auf die zweite Ebene nicht, also einfach nicht zu machen.
Ich frage mich auch, bei Linnemann ist das ja so, dass man das eigentlich quantitativ messen sollte.
Also er sagt, es wird dann Zivilisten, tote Zivilisten geben und dann muss man
sagen, also wie weit muss da die Solidarität mitgehen?
Also wann habe ich unter Beweis gestellt, dass ich wirklich solidarisch bin?
5000 Zivilisten muss ich akzeptieren, bei 10.000 darf ich doch leise Zweifel auch anmelden.
Wie viele Kinder dürfen betroffen sein davon, wie viele nicht?
Also das ist ja eine völlig irrsinnige Logik. Also da merkt man schon,
wenn man sich völlig aus dem Universalismus hinausbegibt und dass man nicht
erstmal völkerrechtlich sich klar macht, dass Israel das Recht hat, sich zu verteidigen.
Dass aber dann ja gleich auch die Frage kommen muss, welche Art der Verteidigung ist sinnvoll?
Und da dann so Leute zu hören, wie Michael Roth, der sagt, jetzt sei nicht die
Zeit, Israel zu belehren oder so. Ist ja, also wann ist die Zeit?
Also die Zeit ist immer jetzt.
Ja, also das ist ja völliger Unsinn.
Ist überhaupt ein Argument, das jetzt ganz häufig kam,
dass wenn immer irgendwas gesagt würde, dass man dann, also wenn,
wenn man beispielsweise auf den palästinensischen Kontext hingewiesen hat,
dann wurde gesagt, jetzt sei nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt dafür.
Wenn jetzt nach den israelischen Angriffen, Gegenangriffen auf Gaza,
wenn man da sagt, ja, aber man muss ja auch Israel dann im anderen Kontext nochmal
sehen, dann sagen die auch, ja, jetzt ist nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt, seht ihr ja dann.
Also da muss man auch nochmal bitte unterscheiden.
Es gibt einen politisch repräsentativen Diskurs, ja.
Politiker sitzen bei der Buchmesse, Slavoj Žižek hält eine Rede und dann müssen
Politiker sich politikerhaft dazu verhalten und müssen sagen.
Ja, in dem Fall ja konkret namentlich mal machen, dieses Theater, wie es abgezogen wurde.
Uwe Becker, der Antisemitismusbeauftragte des Landes Hessen und vor wenigen
Monaten hier unterlegener Bürgermeisterkandidat, der verloren hat gegen einen
Zuzügling aus Syrien, das kann ja alles gar nicht wahr sein und so weiter, ne?
Verlässt natürlich den Saal, nachdem Zizek 20 mal gesagt hat,
es wird jetzt kompliziert, ich mache hier mal ein Argument, ich spreche hier
nichts ab, ich will einfach nur mal einen Satz auch noch sagen dürfen.
So, ich habe die Rede nicht gehört, aber so wurde es mir irgendwie auch so ein bisschen...
Ja, ich stimme nicht mit der Rede zu, aber es war der Versuch,
irgendwie einen philosophischen Diskurs darüber zu bringen und eigentlich in
eine Richtung, wahrscheinlich wie Omri Böhm in etwa argumentiert.
Also steht Uwe Becker dann auf, geht theatralisch raus. Was für den aktiven
Bürgermeister heißt, jetzt muss ich auch rausgehen. Ich kann da nicht sitzen bleiben.
Das ist das Repräsentantenspiel der Politik. Das hat aber nichts mit dem Diskurs,
den Zizek aufführt, das ist einer der Wahrheit.
Und da kann man sagen, ja, aber das stimmt nicht. Also Zizek sagt zum Beispiel
in der Rede, dass das jetzt wahrscheinlich dazu führen wird,
dass es Israel eint und dass die dann eher wieder so geschlossen hinter ihrer
rechten Regierung steht.
Hier muss man sowieso nicht über Shishek diskutieren, das ist immer eure Vorliebe.
Um das nur deutlich zu sagen, das ist ja de facto nicht der Fall.
Ich habe ja aus Jerusalem Post, da war so eine Umfrage, dass vier von fünf jüdischen
Israelis sagen, dass Netanyahu ganz, ganz stark versagt hat.
Also da kann man nicht sagen, die stehen jetzt geschlossen hinter ihrer Regierung.
Aber damit sind wir, was ich damit sagen will, da sind wir auf der Diskursebene war falsch.
Also da sind wir in dem System Wissenschaft bei Cizek und du merkst,
ich geh jetzt hier zum System Theoretiker.
Und ja ja und das ist es ja, wenn wir jetzt systemtheoretisch doch drauf blicken,
können wir sagen, hier sollen Systeme vermischt werden, die nicht vermischt
werden können. Die Politik.
Systempolitik funktioniert ja mit Macht haben und Macht nicht haben und da bedeutet
es, wenn Uwe Becker rausgeht, muss der Bürgermeister sich anschließen,
sonst kriegt der vielleicht vom Ministerpräsidenten dies und das zu hören.
Also das ist dieses Macht haben, Macht nicht haben.
Der ja auch schon mal in Frankfurt den Bürgermeisterwahl verloren hat und so weiter.
Das ist alles ganz gefährdet.
Also die Frage stellt sich hier, wenn Zizek eine Rede hält und irgendwas erzählt,
dann stellt sich die wissenschaftliche Frage, war falsch?
Ich führe uns mal wieder auf methodologischen, auf unserer Basis der ersten
und zweiten Beobachtung zurück und zu Böhm und will nur sagen,
es gibt die erste und die zweite Beobachter-Ebene und dann gibt es den Zirkus.
Ja. So und Zizek überhaupt schon mal als Eröffnungsreder auf einer Buchmesse
einzuladen, wo man genau weiß, das ist dann so Party-People-mäßig sitzt man
da so rum und dann wird es aber kontrovers.
Keiner weiß in dem Moment, wie man sich richtig verhält, sondern wartet dann,
oh Gott, was steht am nächsten Morgen in der Zeitung?
Und dann liest man irgendwie so Twitter-Threads, wo es dann heißt,
warum ich gestern die Rede verließ und dann doch wieder zurückging und was dagegen
hatte, dass der Tschetschisch das sagt, aber ich trotzdem gut finde,
dass er da sprechen durfte.
Und man denkt sich so, okay Leute, schweigt einfach alle dazu.
Das interessiert jetzt niemanden. Das sind die Ereignisse, da braucht man wirklich
kein Datum oder kein Geschichtsbucheintrag.
Nein, einfach, das ist Zirkus und Theater, aber...
Trotzdem, für uns illustriert das, es gibt unglaublich viel Redebedarf auf der einen Seite und dann,
wie wir eben von Lindemann gehört haben und das gleich auch nochmal von Michael Roth hören werden,
sehr viel, fast Diskurs, Befehle, dass jetzt kein Kontext, sondern nur Vakuum
akzeptiert werden darf und so weiter.
Man versucht so krampfhaft, was nicht geht, was physikalisch nicht geht,
die erste Beobachter-Ebene auf die zweite Beobachter-Ebene zu heben.
Das geht einfach nicht. Trotzdem wird es uns immer so angeboten, verkauft.
Wir müssen es machen, aber es ist alles Quatsch.
Aber hatten wir nicht da auch tatsächlich ein Problem? Wir haben diese ganze
Debatte jetzt auch gehabt darüber, wer hat wie in den sozialen Medien reagiert oder nicht reagiert.
Und du und ich gehören nicht zu den Leuten, die, wenn irgendetwas Schlimmes
passiert, einen Solidaritätspost machen oder so etwas.
Wir haben auch noch nie Nationalflaggen im Profil gehabt. Ich glaube,
du hast wahrscheinlich auch nichts wie Charlie gepostet.
Und ja, wer mir jetzt irgendwann nachweisen kann, dass ich in zehn Jahren Twitter
auch mal irgendwas gemacht habe, okay, gut, schön, aber in der Regel ist das nicht meine Sache.
Und mein zweiter Vorname in solchen Sachen ist Reaktanz. Wenn jemand mit der
Sache kommt, als Anliegen, sage ich erstmal besonders nein und denke dann wahrscheinlich
noch weniger darüber nach.
Ja, aber wir sind auch nicht, ich komme mir dann vor, ich bin ja nicht die Außenministerin,
die jetzt sagen muss, ich verurteile die Taten der Hamas, also das muss ich
ja nicht sagen, also das ist ja wohl unsinnig, das zu tun.
Also ich gehöre nicht zu Leuten, aber es gibt ja sehr viele Leute,
die tatsächlich laufend ihre Solidarität posten, wenn irgendwas ist,
von Black Lives Matter, über verschiedene Sachen, die Schlimmes so geschehen.
Und da würde ich schon sagen, ohne jetzt Schwilden von der Welt oder Poschert
oder so zu verteidigen, aber ich würde schon sagen, dass es auffällig war, dass am 7. und 8.
Oktober, also auch noch bevor Israel Bevor Israel in irgendeiner Weise angefangen
hat, zum Gegenangriff überzugehen, dass von einigen Leuten, die sonst alles
aufnehmen und pfeifen...
Aber wer hat das?
Sagen ja viele.
Beide Herzen offen.
Ich finde das jetzt tatsächlich nicht besonders fair, die jetzt zu nennen.
Ich habe jetzt auch nicht alle durchsucht. Ich bin ja auch nicht von der Polizei.
Die Welt hat ja alle angeschrieben.
Aber nein, die Welt hat verschiedene Leute angeschrieben, da würde ich aber
auch sagen, dass sie da Böhmermann angeschrieben haben oder so,
weil Böhmermann kann man jetzt glaube ich nicht vorwerfen, dass er sich nicht
solidarisch zeigt, wenn die Israel da ein Pogrom verübt.
Was erwarten die da? In der Welt seine Solidarität?
Genau, also da würde ich erstmal unterschreiten wollen, also niemand ist verpflichtet
mit der Welt zu sprechen, das auch nicht. Aber ich würde schon sagen,
es gibt einige, die nichts gemacht haben. Und dann gibt es noch einige, die haben.
Und haben dann, als es dann zum israelischen Gegenschlag kam,
angefangen, sofort darüber zu twittern, wie schlimm das ist,
was Israel tut. Und haben das andere aber nicht gemacht.
Dazu gehört auch Greta Thunberg. Ich will das hier unterstreichen,
weil mich das auch sehr enttäuscht. Ich habe nichts dagegen,
wenn man auch auf die Straße geht für palästinensische Zivilisten.
Aber ich finde es schon beachtlich, beachtlich, dass von Greta Thunberg zu dem
Terroranschlag der Hamas nichts kam und sie dann wartet, wartet,
wartet, bis sie dann sich fotografieren lässt mit Free Palestine etc.
Und das, finde ich, ist ein Doppelstandard, der dann angelegt wird.
Und da sind wir in dem Bereich Antisemitismus auch angekommen,
weil das ist dieses, dass man jetzt nur mal abwartet Und wenn dann Israel auch
was macht, dann kann man sagen, Herr Seta, hier, da sind sie.
Und das, finde ich, schickt sich nicht, beziehungsweise das geht einfach nicht.
Und das ist etwas, was man auch nicht übergehen sollte. Ich würde generell mal
raten, nicht laufend zu allen möglichen Dingen schnell Solidaritätsbekundungen abzusetzen.
Aber es ist schon mir aufgefallen, dass es einige, die sonst bei diesen Dingen
immer dabei sind, komischerweise nichts gesagt haben.
Möglicherweise auch, weil sie nicht richtig wussten, wie sie es formulieren
sollen oder sonst was machen. Ich will hier jetzt sagen, also ja,
noch mal, man muss mit der Welt nicht reden, wenn die einen anfragt.
Aber ich fand, dass diese ganze Aktion von der Welt doch eine Sache hervorgebracht
hat. Sie hat mich ein bisschen mit Diana zu Löwen versöhnt. Ich werde dich jetzt
wirklich überraschen. Denn Diana zu Löwen wurde auch angefragt und hat dann der Welt geantwortet.
Ich lese das mal vor, es waren dann einige Tage danach, es fliegen jetzt auch
nicht nur Raketen aus Gaza, sondern es fliegen auch Raketen aus Israel auf Gaza
und Diana zu Löwen äußert sich jetzt.
Es darf nicht sein, dass Juden in Angst leben müssen. Dieser Krieg ist zwar
nicht vor unserer Haustür, aber wir spüren die Auswirkungen hier.
Auch in Berlin haben Juden Angst vor Angriffen.
Sie verlassen das Haus nicht mehr und bangen um ihre Liebsten.
Das erlebe ich in meinem Freundeskreis.
Ich will aber auch meine Solidarität mit wirklich allen Menschen bekunden,
die unter diesem Krieg leiden. Ich verurteile die Hamas und ihre Taten,
aber habe trotzdem Mitgefühl gegenüber unschuldigen palästinensischen Zivilistinnen.
Ich wünsche mir Solidarität und Mitgefühl für alle unschuldigen Menschen,
die unter diesem Krieg leiden. Das ist meinen Augen ein mustergültiges Statement.
Ich bin ganz beeindruckt und da sind wir eigentlich hier in Kurzform beim Universalismus. Genau.
Und ich würde sagen, unschuldige Menschen sind schon mal grundsätzlich per se
alle Kinder und in Gaza leben zur Hälfte Kinder. Also zählen wir die Kinder in Millionengröße.
Also Diana zu Löwen. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das ist doch wie Donald Trump heiratet Hillary Clinton.
Ja, fast. Na gut, okay. Also wir sehen, es finden sowieso viel Kontexte statt.
Müssen wir weiter deutschen Politikern glauben oder ihnen da vertrauensvoll
hinterherhächeln, wenn sie uns weismachen wollen?
Kontextfreie Solidarität, wie hat es Schröder damals genannt?
Es gibt, anders als uns in Deutschland von diesen Leuten gesagt wird,
laut Böhm, dem wir ja nun mit voller Sympathie da folgen, ein Kontextualisierungsgebot
in dieser Angelegenheit.
Ich habe meine Befürchtungen in Bezug auf diese Einwände zur Kontextualisierung
auf beiden Seiten, sowohl von Seiten einiger meiner StudentInnen in New York,
als auch einiger meiner Freunde in Berlin.
Sie sind gegen die Kontextualisierung, weil sie davon ausgehen,
dass die Antwort Gewalt sein wird.
Wer die Taten der Hamas in einen Kontext einordnet, geht davon aus,
dass Israel nicht das Recht hat, sie zu bombardieren.
Wer umgekehrt Israels Handeln kontextualisiert, geht davon aus,
dass die Hamas durchaus das Recht hatte, Israel anzugreifen.
Beides ist falsch. Das wäre ja schon ein strategischer Sieg der Terroristen
oder der Massakrierer, dass sie diese Kontextualisierung dass wir die Dualisierung
selbst unterbinden in gewisser Weise.
Und das ist ja genau unsere Diskussion. Wir versuchen dann aus einer Kontextualisierung,
weil wir immer das Schlechteste vermuten, nämlich dass jeder ein Antisemite
ist in dieser Diskussion, immer gleich eine Erklärung, eine Rechtfertigung rauszuleiern,
die aber da gar nicht da ist.
Man stellt einfach nur mal fest, das, was wir gerade besprechen,
ist nicht das einzige Ereignis, das im Geschichtsbuch steht.
Da stehen auch noch andere Sachen. Kann man dann überlegen.
Und dann kann man sich ja ... Also man kann ja ein Anhänger der Theorie sein, dass weil am 7.
Oktober vor 70 Jahren Putin geboren wurde, hat sich die Hamas heute diesen Tag ausgesucht.
Also lassen wir das durchaus mal zu. Nur damit andere Kontextualisierungen nicht
auch per se verboten werden. Nur weil mal jemand so einen Scheiß erzählt.
So, jetzt zu dieser deutschen Diskussion.
Beispielhaft Michael Roth am 8. Oktober. Jetzt haben wir eben von Harari gehört,
Die Leute vor Ort stehen zu nah dran, weshalb es insbesondere aus Deutschland,
insbesondere von Politikern, eine Pflicht gibt, jetzt nicht emotional und intellektuell faul zu sein.
Sich einfach treiben zu lassen und alles zu sagen, sondern mitdenken,
ein echtes politisches Angebot für das Publikum zu machen, das man halt vor sich hat.
Und in dem Fall, er ist ja eigentlich ein Politiker, redet aber jetzt im Fernsehen,
also sozusagen so noch doppelte Verantwortung als Politiker,
ein politisches Angebot in einem Massenmedium zu machen, wo ansonsten Unterhaltungsrichtlinien
gelten und so weiter, auch da anschlussfähig zu sein. Und dann entscheidet sich
Michael Roth für so einen Spruch.
Es bleibt den israelischen Freundinnen und Freunden keine andere Wahl.
Sie müssen jetzt die Infrastruktur der Hamas ein für allemal vernichten.
Der Gazastreifen, den Israel seit 2005 verlassen hat, ist mehr oder weniger ein Terrorlager.
Israel ist von Feinden umgeben, die dieses Land zerstören wollen,
die die Menschen vernichten wollen.
Und das muss uns auch in Deutschland klar werden, weil wir immer wieder dazu
neigen und sagen, naja, es ist ganz furchtbar, aber eigentlich sind die Israelis
ja selber dran schuld. Und das stimmt einfach nicht.
Ich finde dieses Statement auf so vielen Ebenen so krass überzogen und inhaltlich falsch.
Schon allein, wenn er sagt, der Gaza-Streifen, den Israel 2015 verlassen hat.
Also wir haben die eine Seite, die sagt, wir sind ja seit 50 Jahren besetzt
und dann sagt er, ihr seid seit fast zehn Jahren frei.
Also das passt schon mal inhaltlich nicht zusammen. Und er weiß ja auch,
dass er hier ein Angebot für die A-Leute macht und dass es diesen B-Kontext gibt.
Sonst hätte er diese Formulierung gar nicht so gemacht. Also es ist ja ein ganz
instrumentelles, bewusstes Ausblenden von dieser B-Seite, um dann Solidarität
einzufordern und zwar für jegliche militärischen Aktionen, die halt von der
israelischen Regierung geplant werden.
So und darauf lassen wir, reagieren wir mit Deborah Feldmann, die hat ja...
Sie hat lange ihre Kindheit in so einem orthodoxen Zusammenhang gebracht.
Hat sich dann daraus befreit, ist nach Amerika gegangen. Mit Kind,
glaube ich sogar. Nein, umgekehrt.
Sie hat in den USA gelebt und ist jetzt mit ihrem Kind nach Berlin gegangen.
Ich kann das Buch Unorthodox, das
auch als Serie verfilmt wurde von Maria Schrader, beides sehr empfehlen.
Da sieht man, da hat man sogar schon ein Filmangebot. Sie kann man,
glaube ich, als Sprecherin einfach, Sie hat das Millionenpublikum gefunden,
hat wahrscheinlich unendlich viele Diskussionen geführt. Sie ist sich ziemlich
sicher über das, was sie so sagt.
Im Kontext dieses ganzen Oktober sitzt sie bei der FAZ im Gespräch.
Die haben nur so anderthalb Stunden Podium.
Sie redet dort über die deutschen Politiker und deren Reaktion auf den 7. Oktober.
Die politische Diskussion, die wir in Deutschland über Israel haben, Wie beobachtest du die?
Jetzt gerade eben. Das Einzige, was ich beobachte, ist zum Beispiel die Lippenbekenntnissen.
Jeder Politiker versucht schnell, seine Karriere zu untermauern,
indem er die üblichen Floskeln liefert. Das ist auch verständlich,
kann ich nachvollziehen.
Politiker sind auch ein Spiegel der Gesellschaft. Wenn die Gesellschaft selbst
verunsichert ist, wie sich zu Israel positionieren sollen, werden die Politiker das auch sein.
Ich sehe auch, dass gleich wieder das genutzt wird, zu lenken auf Einwanderer,
auf muslimische Bevölkerung und so weiter. Also man will gleich das Thema hier
her verschieben. Man will nicht mehr über die Opfer in Israel reden.
Wir wollen über uns als Opfer reden.
Also inwiefern die bösen Einwanderer uns zu Antisemiten machen und so.
Und egal, wie man dazu steht, finde ich das falsch, den Fokus hierher zu lenken.
Ich finde das sehr narzisstisch.
Also ich finde, es soll wirklich nur über die Menschen gehen, die man retten kann.
So, sie redet also quasi über Michael Roth, der nochmal versucht,
seinen Standpunkt zu finden, total verunsichert ist und deswegen einfach all
in geht, weil er glaubt, da werde ich ja wohl nicht angegriffen.
Und dann gleichzeitig über diese CDU-Leute, die dann einfach sagen,
ja, der Antisemitismus ist ganz schlimm. Diese ganzen Muslime,
die müssen wir jetzt alle mal zähmen.
Während sie selber gerade Geschichtsschreibung mit Hubert Aiwanger und seinem
Bruder machen, der genau für zwei Dokumente bekannt ist, nämlich ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt und einen Koalitionsvertrag mit der CSU.
Ja, das passt einfach wirklich. Ja, ich, so und jetzt lassen wir uns das auch
mal von allen Seiten betrachten,
weil ich weiß, das ist ein sehr, sehr heikles Thema, aber vielleicht können
wir diesen einen, diesen letzten Clip von mir spielen, nur um das mal als Ton
wirklich zu bekommen, weil ich immer noch fassungslos bin.
Das Hamburg-Journal, das ist NDR, die sind unterwegs in der Stadt.
Es hat gerade der Anschlag stattgefunden. Wir sind am 8.
Oder 9. Oktober, ich kann es nicht genau sagen, also unmittelbar danach.
Wir machen Meinungsumfrage und jetzt kommt dort eine Frau.
Hier darf man das mal dazu sagen, die einen Kopftuch trägt und einen Migrationshintergrund
hat. Die äußert sich wie folgt.
Was denken Sie von den Anschlägen in Israel? Das ist gut.
Das ist sehr gut sogar. Das ist gut. Ich freu mich, dass die so was geschafft haben.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr gut. Wir haben gefeiert zu Hause.
So, wir haben jetzt diese krasse Äußerung. Haben wir es damit im Einzelfall
zu tun? Ich befürchte, nein.
Ich höre von einem Bekannten aus Wiesbaden, der durch eine Straße geht,
wo sehr viele Geschäfte sind von Arabischen Migranten.
Und es wurde am 8. Oktober dort gefeiert und es wurde auch ganz laut so artikuliert,
warum man da feiert. Das war nicht zufällig eine Hochzeit oder sonst etwas.
Ich hörte, wie in Frankfurt die Stimmung war. Das war nicht besonders schön.
Wir haben die Fälle in vielen, vielen Städten, dass an Häuserwände geschmiert
wird, dass hier Juden leben.
Ich bin in Augsburg an der Synagoge vorbeigefahren.
Der Taxifahrer wies mich darauf hin. Gucken Sie mal, wie viel Polizei hier jetzt
plötzlich steht. Das war vorher nicht da.
Das heißt, wir haben ja zwei oder drei Formen, eigentlich müssen wir jetzt mal
von Antisemitismus sprechen.
Wir haben einmal diesen bürgerlichen Antisemitismus, den du in der Mitte-Studie
auch vorgestellt hast, wo dann plötzlich sogar 12 Prozent der FDP-Wähler Die AfD überflügelt.
So Sätze unterschreiben wie, es gibt wohl zu viele Juden im Finanzwesen et cetera.
Diese antisemitischen Klischees, die tradiert sind, da wiederholen und aufrufen.
Das sind ja nicht Leute, die auf der Straße stehen und von der River to the Sea skandieren.
Oder die irgendwelche Sterne an Haustüren schmieren oder so etwas.
Dann haben wir diese Aktion da gehabt vor dem Auswärtigen Amt von Demonstranten.
Da waren es also nicht Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, sondern es waren vor allem Deutsche.
Weiß ich nicht, Vogue, vielleicht waren da auch ein paar Experts darunter,
die gesagt haben, Free Palestine from German Guilt.
Also die dann sagen so, jetzt machen wir mal hier unseren Schlussstrich.
Aber die haben das auch auf Plakaten gehabt oder was? Ja, ja und haben das skandiert.
Also man kann sich dieses Video, ich habe das jetzt vergessen mitzubringen,
man kann sich das bei Twitter noch anhören, Free Palestine from German Guild.
Also jetzt zu sagen, jetzt ist mal hier Schlussstrich, jetzt müssen wir nicht
immer über den Holocaust reden. Jetzt machen wir hier mal, wo die eigentlichen
Täter sind und die werden dann ganz klar natürlich als israelisch identifiziert.
Das heißt, wir haben diese Art des Hasses und des Antisemitismus und dann haben
wir hier das, was wir jetzt eben im Ausschnitt gehört haben,
dass sich da gefreut wird darüber, dass Juden ermordet wurden.
Sollte man auch von links nicht ignorieren, dass es das gibt.
Und deswegen sollte man das auch ganz klar benennen und auch als falsch benennen
und nicht auch als irgendeine kulturelle Eigenart oder so hinnehmen.
Weil das war ja schon der Diskurs bei der Documenta, dass da dann diese Argumentation
kam, da machen indonesische Künstler antisemitische Schmierereien.
Und dann sagt man, ja, das ist so ein deutsches Ding, dass ihr da irgendwie
Probleme habt, ist das so unsere Kultur. Da muss man einfach sagen,
Antisemitismus ist keine Kultur.
Antisemitismus ist auch keine deutsche Erfindung. Der Holocaust ist eine deutsche
Erfindung, wie Friedmann damals sagte, aber der Antisemitismus nicht.
Da kann man nicht sagen, die machen das halt so.
Palästina von der deutschen Schuld
befreien, hat Harry Nutt im Tagesspiel geschrieben, noch nie gehört.
Es war bereits zu lesen, plakatiert auf der Kunstausstellung Das indonesische
Kuratoren-Kollektiv, Ruan Krupa, wehrte die gegen sie vorgebrachten Antisemitismus-Vorwürfe
wiederholt als rassistisch motiviert ab.
Sie verwahrten sich gegen die Art und Weise, deutsche Schuld und Geschichte
auf den palästinensischen und andere antikoloniale Kämpfe zu projizieren und zu übertragen.
Da muss man sagen, da ist man genau in dieser Identitätspolitik-Falle,
die Omri Böhm und Susan Nyman ja schreiben. dass man dann nur noch sagt,
nee, das ist aber unsere Identität, das ist unsere Identität.
Und da wird schon nicht richtig drauf geblickt. Und ich würde sagen,
dass man da sehr ehrlich drauf blicken muss. Denn sonst gewinnen halt diese
Irrsinnsaktionen der Bild-Zeitung.
Also die Bild-Zeitung, die jetzt ein Manifest macht mit nie wieder 50 Punkte
aufführt. Und man denkt, okay, nie wieder.
Also nie wieder, sagt es so etwas wie die Shoah geben, nie wieder Antisemitismus
in Deutschland. Und das wird auch darin artikuliert in dem Manifest.
Dann heißt es aber dann z.B.
Als 33. Punkt, Deutschland ist ein Land der Griller.
Nach einem Picknick im Park nehmen wir unseren Müll wieder mit.
Also das ist jetzt auch offenbar alles nie wieder. Oder wir drücken uns die
Hände, wir sagen bitte und danke.
Es wird alles in einem Manifest, das mit nie wieder übertitelt ist.
Und das sich eigentlich gegen Antisemitismus, sondern wird jetzt alles darauf
präzisieren, um natürlich drinnen stecken soll, ja, die muslimischen Migranten,
die nehmen offenbar ihren Müll beim Picknick nicht mit, was mir hier untergejubelt werden soll.
Und um gegen diese Leute, die jetzt das ganze alles nur als Anlass nehmen,
um mal endlich Islamfeindlichkeit rauszulassen, um diesen Leuten gar keinen Boden zu lassen,
muss man auch, also keinen Argumentationsboden zu geben, muss man auch ganz
klar benennen, dass es da ein großes Problem gibt mit drei verschiedenen Formen
von Antisemitismus, die meist sehr separiert auftreten.
Also ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass bald AfD-Wähler gemeinsam von
the river to the sea auf Straßen ... Na, mal sehen.
Man weiß ja immer nicht bei der AfD, wie sie das so ...
Ja, ich halte es für ... Die AfD ist da ja auch sehr gespalten.
Aber wir müssen schon auch das benennen, dass es das gibt.
Und dass das auch gerade das ist, also hier, wo auch Tatenausschreitungen da
sind, was Juden jetzt explizit in Deutschland zu diesem Zeitpunkt besonders
Angst macht. Und zu Recht.
Die Susan Nyman verhandelt das ja in dem Gespräch, das sie da mit Böhm zu ihrem Buch führt.
Also klar, Identitätspolitik, aber sie sagt ganz explizit, ich nenne es lieber Tribalismus.
Ja, das ist Tribalismus.
Und das finde ich sehr gut, weil Tribalismus ...
Das hängt so ein bisschen aus gesellschaftlicher Thematisierung ins die Gemeinschaft,
wo wir es viel besser fühlen, emotional nachvollziehen können, was es gemeint ist.
Und das Tribalistische ist ja so etwas, als sei das so angehörig.
Also das gehört zu meinem Tribe, zu meinem Stamm.
Und genau das ist ja, was wir dann auch zugleich bei den konservativen und bei
Bild-Zeitungsleuten jetzt finden, dass sie die muslimischen Menschen hier sich
einfach als Tribe vorstellen, denen das jetzt irgendwie so zu eigen ist.
Zu eigen ist. Und da kann man ja ganz klar sagen, nein, ganz viele sind ja eben
nicht jetzt auf Straßen und Rufen von the river to the sea. Aber man muss auch
hier wiederum differenzieren.
Wir können nicht jede Demonstration jetzt, die die stattfindet,
die sich mit palästinensischen Zivilisten solidarisieren will,
als israelfeindlich deklarieren. Das kann auch nicht gehen. Also wo kommen wir
dann dahin mit der Versammlungsfreiheit?
Ja oder eben genau und dadurch dann jede Versammlung verbieten.
Das war die Luise Engelbrecht,
bevor wir zum Tribalismus zurückkommen, hat ja mal beschrieben,
wie sie mit journalistischem Interesse auf eine pro palästinensische Demo in
Deutschland gehen wollte, um sich da mal oben zu erhören und O-Töne einzusammeln.
Ich habe selber versucht, als Berichterstatterin auf pro-palästinensische Demonstrationen
zu gehen. Ich habe mir die immer rausgesucht. Es gibt ja so eine Übersichtsseite
für Berlin mit den aktuellen oder anstehenden Versammlungen.
Dann habe ich mir immer welche rausgesucht und dann kam immer die Meldung der Polizei rein.
Veranstaltungen abgesagt, Veranstaltungen abgesagt. Und das führte am Ende dazu,
dass die einzige Veranstaltung, die ich dann erstmal gefunden habe,
war angemeldet als im Austausch über die Situation in Israel-Palästina und über
den Zustand des Versammlungsrechts in Berlin.
Und das war angemeldet mit fünf bis zehn Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmern und
ohne Skandieren von Slogans.
Das war die erste Veranstaltung, die dann zugelassen wurde. Also fünf bis zehn Teilnehmer.
Und das hat erstmal dazu geführt, dass natürlich viele Menschen,
mit denen ich gesprochen habe, wirklich das Gefühl hatten, wir dürfen überhaupt
nichts mehr sagen, wir dürfen nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen.
Dann kam aber ja am Samstag in Kreuzberg die weitgehend auch friedliche Demonstration,
die am Oranienplatz gestartet hat, wo dann 5000 Menschen zusammengekommen sind.
So und das ist ja jetzt ein interessanter, wenn man so drüber nachdenkt,
also unter dem Tribalismus Ding, wie vorhin schon mal angemerkt,
wir sehen jetzt die Muslime alle als eine Gruppe, also man spricht ja dann gerade
im amerikanischen Versuch von einer Community, gerade so bei sexuellen Ausrichtungen
und Neigungen und so, und sagt dann irgendwie die Community und wir haben ja
die Erfahrung gemacht, dass wir,
Corona, große anti-asiatische Gewaltvorfälle.
Viele hatten nach dem 11. September gegen Muslime. Menschen hatten Angst,
wenn jemand mit einem Vollbart und dunklerer Haut den Bus betrat.
Da wurde das alles hergestellt.
Immer wieder reproduziert wurde und sich dann natürlich auch in so einem medialen Diskurs verfing.
Gleichzeitig machen die aber die Erfahrung, ihr verbietet mir ja,
eine Community zu bilden. Ich finde ja gar keine Gleichgesinnten,
sondern ich sitze für mich zu Hause und hab halt meine Familie.
Aber hinaus gibt es für mich gerade gar keine muslimische Realität,
schon wenn ich mit nur fünf anderen muslimisch aussehenden Menschen auf der
Straße stehe, kommt schon die Polizei und zerschlägt alles. Oder verbietet es mir direkt.
Ja, auch da gab es ja schlimme Polizeigewalt. Das kommt dann auch noch dazu, sowas.
Und jetzt im Kontext dieser Tribalisierung,
zurück zu Deborah Feldman, die jetzt nochmal auf,
also wir haben ja eben ihren Einspruch schon gehört, den ich so gemünzt habe,
das könnte an Michael Roth adressiert sein oder an die CDU, die dann einfach
allen Antisemitismus nur in dieser einen Kategorie sieht und so weiter.
Und sie kommt hier nochmal drauf zu sprechen, welchen funktionalen Charakter
solche Aussprüche wie von Michael Roth haben.
Und wir hinterfragen das gleich im Kontext dessen, dass wir jetzt gesehen haben,
ah ja, aber die Muslimen, die ja dieselbe Fernsehrealität erleben und die vielleicht
auch Telefonnummern in Gaza haben, die jetzt nicht anrufbar sind und so weiter
und so fort, den versagen wir aber komplett, da so ein Community-Gefühl jetzt zu entwickeln.
Also warum nimmst du das den Politikern, den Institutionen nicht ab?
Weil es so eine Identitätsstiftung der politischen Performance ist und es geht
viel mehr um diese Politik selbst, sondern um das Selbstbild des Landes als
um Israel oder irgendwelche Leidtragende im Nahostkonflikt.
Für mich scheint dieses ganze Thema eigentlich nur ein Instrument,
um die deutsche Identität zu konstruieren und zu stabilisieren.
Und das finde ich wirklich einen sehr plausiblen, sehr anschlussfähigen Gedanken.
Das sind, was Michael Roth da macht.
Michael Roth sagt jetzt einfach, Israelis dürfen jetzt alles in Gaza,
bis die Hamas ein für allemal vernichtet wurde.
Und deren Infrastruktur. Da fragt man sich ja, na gut, die Infrastruktur Hamas,
also damit ist ja wirklich jedes Gebäude gemeint in Gaza.
Also das potenziell gehört ja alles zur Infrastruktur, selbst wenn da gerade
die Anwesenden nicht zur Hamas gehören, sondern gar nicht wissen,
achso, ich werde gerade missbraucht, weil im Keller passiert irgendwas,
von dem ich gar nichts wisse und da kriege ich einen Anruf und ich soll mein
Haus verlassen und so weiter und so fort.
Also da ist jetzt sozusagen von Michael Roth feuerfrei für Gaza,
während er selber ja gar nicht vor Ort ist und diesen Kampf selber führt,
so wie wir immer bei der Ukraine dann auch.
Ja klar kann man jetzt einfach hier behaupten, die machen das schon unter dem
Vorwand, naja ich darf hier nicht in der Ukraine mitkämpfen, weil dann wäre ich ja...
Teilnehmer des Krieges, wir dürfen nur Waffen liefern, die sollen mal für uns
sterben. Und das erklärt ja Michael Roth quasi wieder.
Und wir sind ja da an diesem Punkt, wo wir laufend mit Doppelstandards operieren.
Und das ist ja auch mein Vorwurf an Greta Thunberg oder so, dass sie Doppelstandards
anlegen, dass sie für alle bei so vielen Sachen schweigen. Also nicht universalistisch.
Ja, und da jetzt aber sagen, seht her, Israel macht da was Schlimmes,
aber sonst reden wir über das andere nicht.
Und das ist ja ein Doppelstandard, den wir kritisieren. Genauso wie wir diesen
Doppelstandard kritisieren müssen, dass man da einen Freifahrtschein gibt.
Und das ist ja auch diese tiefe Auseinandersetzung jetzt in der EU.
Also das haben wir so auch noch nicht gehabt. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite
die Kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der Leyen und ihre Leute,
die sagen wir mal so in etwa den Linnemann Diskurs pflegen und Rot Diskurs pflegen.
Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir Michelle und Borell vom Rat, die das anders sehen.
Und dann gab es dieses Schreiben von Hunderten, die aus dem Personal sind der
EU, also die dort für die EU arbeiten.
Und die haben ja von der Leyen sehr kritisiert, dass sie gar nicht darüber sprechen
will, dass zum Beispiel Palästinenser jetzt sehr zu leiden haben.
Oder dass es da eine humanitäre Katastrophe auch geben kann,
wenn da nicht die entsprechenden Lkws usw.
Ankommen. Das hat ja Biden schon sehr früh, auch nach seiner Abreise,
direkt gesagt, ja, wir versuchen da, was möglich zu machen. Ich würde auch sagen,
das ist nicht genug, was da versucht wurde. Aber immerhin wird es von ihm angesprochen.
Und da zitieren die dann in diesem Schreiben, wo sie von der Leyen anprangern.
Eine Rede von von der Leyen und er sagt von der Leyen Russlands Angriffen gegen
die zivilen Infrastruktur, besonders die Elektrizität, sind Kriegsverbrechen.
Schneidung von Männern, Frauen, Kindern von Wasser, Elektrizität und Heizung mit Winterkrieg.
Dies sind Taten von purem Terror und wir müssen es so nennen.
Und gerade in der EU läuft ja auch so eine Art Rivalismus zwischen EU-Kommission
hier, EU-Ratspräsidentschaft da und so. Das sind ja auch diese Machtkämpfe,
die sich jetzt an solchen Themen dann plötzlich so Kontur versuchen zu finden.
Und da geht es auch dann am Ende auch nicht mehr um die Israelis und noch nicht um die Palästinenser.
Nee, gar nicht genau.
Das ist sehr gut von Feldmann.
Ich will mal einen kleinen...
Es ist ja wirklich ein heißer Brei, dass es diese erste Beobachterebene wirklich gibt.
Harari sitzt im Fernsehen und erzählt davon, dass seine Familie in diesem Kaput,
das da mit betroffen ist, lebt und er da auch nicht wusste, was ist denn.
Und die Nachbarn ihm erzählen, dass die Tochter entführt wurde und man jetzt
gemeinsam hofft, dass sie nur entführt wurde und nicht noch irgendwo liegt und nicht gefunden wurde.
Also hochgradig, dramatisch, menschlich, einfach dieses.
Ich meine, Israel ist ein kleines Land. Das war ja doch jetzt bei so vielen
Experten dazuhören, dass da immer direkte Kontakte waren.
Ja, ich kenne da auch jemanden, ich wusste gleich, das ist das Kibbutz,
da muss ich nachfragen, ist da jemand betroffen? Hab dann über WhatsApp gesagt
bekommen, es ist nicht so oder so. Also diese Erzählungen oder es war so.
Diese Erzählungen haben wir jetzt ganz oft in diesen Interviews gehört.
Da merkt man, wie klein eigentlich auch dieses Land ist.
1.400 Menschen von 10 Millionen, da bist du halt schon im 0,1-prozentigen Bereich.
Also dann ist schon jeder Tausendstel direkt betroffen.
Und dann bist du halt ganz schnell in dieser Sechseckentheorie,
dass dann einfach jeder jeden kennt oder jeder jemanden kennt.
Also Deborah Feldman macht hier noch einen Satz zur Frage, wie kann man jetzt
damit umgehen? Was Herr Harari auch aufwarf, wir kennen die Leute vor Ort und
deren Umgang und was man ihnen auch abverlangen kann.
Und dann die Forderung an Menschen weiter entfernt, insbesondere Deutschland,
wie die damit umgehen sollen. Und wir haben es schon gehört,
Michael Roth und Lindemann haben keinen guten Umgang mit diesen Problemstellungen.
Wie geht man jetzt damit um, dass man beispielsweise das im Fernsehen so sieht,
die Reportagen bekommt, aber auch niemanden vor Ort kennt, sich auch nicht jetzt
unbedingt in eine politische Diskussion einwerfen möchte und so weiter.
Und sie hat diesen kleinen Appell für, dass man auch Sprachlosigkeit mal zulässt.
Brutalität hat mir wirklich sprachlos gemacht. Und ich finde es legitim,
einfach zu sagen, diese Brutalität macht sprachlos.
Also man darf auch auf eine authentische Art reagieren und sagen,
es ist nicht auszuhalten.
Lässt sich keine Worte für so etwas finden. Und das ist mir mehr wert als ein Floskel.
Das ist mir mehr wert als ein Lippenbekenntnis.
Das würde ich sagen, können wir jetzt aus so einer, keine Ahnung,
du scheinst mir auch emotional stabil und so weiter.
Also es droht jetzt nicht, dass ich in eine Depression verfalle,
weil ich was im Fernsehen sehe.
So, aber diese Sprachlosigkeit sei trotzdem zugestanden für die, die sie brauchen.
Wir wissen aber so richtig weit kommt man damit nicht. Und wir können jetzt
so einen Clip spielen unter der Maßgabe, ja das ist nochmal ein ganz expliziter
Vorwurf an Michael Roth, keine Lippenbekenntnisse jetzt, keine Floskeln.
Ich bin dann, also gut, wir hätten auch darüber geredet, wenn der Anstieg jetzt
vor zwei Tagen gewesen wäre.
Aber jetzt bin ich sehr dankbar, dass wir, dass wir erst jetzt darüber reden
können. Ich war auch wirklich zum Teil entsetzt bei Twitter.
Also ich meine, Nils Minkma twitterte, löschte es dann wieder,
weil er irgendwie sagte, es sei wohl missverstanden worden.
Er twitterte, der Tod ist ein Meister aus Gaza. Das ist ja der Bezug zu diesem
berühmten Gedicht, der Tod ist ein Meister aus Deutschland von Paul Celan.
Ja, und dann würde ich sagen, ist das jetzt angemessen, dass man als Deutscher
sagt, ah ja, der Tod ist ja jetzt so der Meister aus Gaza.
Ist das nicht auch quasi ein Schlussstrich-Tweet, den wir hier ziehen?
Also da da wundere ich mich einfach muss man die pointe setzen ist das ist das
irgendwie da haue ich nochmal so eine so eine kleine line raus sollte man dann nicht lieber.
Aber Roland Kaiser bei Florian Silbereisen was schreiben, fände ich dann besser.
Ja, also Sprachlosigkeit sollte hier wirklich auch eine ernsthafte Alternative
sein, für die man sich entscheiden kann. Ja.
Da es Nils Minkma uns nochmal zeigen möchte, dass er literarisch bewandert ist
und wie auch immer die zivilisatorischen Freiheiten nochmal nutzt,
sich in seinem Bücherregal Gedanken dazu zu machen, zu reflektieren und dann so einen Spruch.
Und ich würde das auch sagen wollen, ich habe das aber auch in der internationalen
Presse dann genauso nachvollzogen, in vielen Interviews gehört auch bei CNN und so.
Nur so, dass jetzt immer gesagt wird, das ist der, der seit dem Holocaust wurden
noch nie auf einmal so viele Juden wieder getötet.
Und ich, also das ist faktisch korrekt. Ich würde aber bei denjenigen,
die aus Deutschland das so, so sehr vor sich her tragen, auch ein bisschen zögerlich
sein bei dieser Argumentation.
Denn das legt, will so ein bisschen auch sagen, so jetzt wohl die anderen sind jetzt die Täter, ja.
Also wir, wir, wir, wir, wir müssen schon nochmal auch die, die,
die, die, die einzigartigkeit, die Singularität sollten wir jetzt nochmal ganz klar unterstreichen.
Es geht mir jetzt nicht um irgendwelche Berechnungen quantitativ,
das schickt sich eh nicht, wenn man über Menschenleben redet,
aber ich würde schon sagen, sollte man zumindest jetzt von deutscher Seite nicht
ganz so sehr darauf rumreiten, da die Singularität von Auschwitz auch jetzt
nicht von dieser Seite so ein bisschen mal angekratzt werden kann.
Also während es genauso nicht geht zu sagen, Free Palestine from German Guild,
kann man jetzt auch nicht so sagen, naja wir hier und jetzt.
Also da diese Zugutwerdung der Deutschen, die macht mir auch mit unter jetzt Angst.
Die Deborah Feldmann.
Sie reflektiert sich ja selbst, weil sie nämlich so kritisiert wird von anderen Juden,
als Entlastungsjüdin, die also kritisch Israel und dem Judentum als Lebensform,
also in dieser orthodoxen Form, wie sie es erfahren hat, dass sie dann kritisiert
wird als, ah ja, du machst den Deutschen das Angebot, eine Entlastungsjüdin
zu sein. Also die sozusagen.
Das Angebot macht so halb antisemitisch, so reinzugehen in so einen Diskurs.
Das finde ich auch interessant, wie sie es in diesem Gespräch reflektiert,
das muss dann jeder selber hören, weil sie auch noch mal dieses Wort kurz verwendet,
also Antisemitismus mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen, der Philosemitismus,
also dass man es ein bisschen übertreibt.
Und ich musste in diesem Moment, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt illustrativ irgendwas
herbringt, aber ich musste an meine Oma denken, die grundsätzlich,
wenn sie einen Menschen mit dunkler Haut gesehen hat, Mitleid hatte.
Also grundsätzlich einfach. Der arme Mann, der kommt bestimmt aus Afrika und
der ist bestimmt ganz arm.
Und das ist auch nicht eine Anwaltschaft, die erstens irgendwohin führt oder
gar gewollt ist und so weiter.
Also in der Hinsicht ist das sowieso interessant, wie jetzt gerade so darüber diskutiert wird.
Und vielleicht kann man so eine Prognose machen,
der Umgang mit Gaza jetzt gerade führt dazu,
dass auch in drei Monaten von Menschen,
die sich das heute noch nicht eingestehen und auch nicht für sich vorstellen
können, nochmal zurückreflektiert wird auf das eigene Twitter-Verhalten im Oktober
2023 mit der Frage, sehe ich das eigentlich immer noch so?
Sehe ich immer noch so, dass wir eine bedingungslose Solidarität mit Netanyahus'
Regierung und deren Entscheidungen für, wir werden jetzt da gewalttätig,
reflektieren das gleich noch? Aber vorher, ich will drei Clips von Estaperell spielen.
Du erinnerst dich sicher an
unseren Salon, in dem wir Sophie Passmanns Fernsehsendung gesehen haben.
Wie könnte ich das vergessen?
Ich meine, diese erste Literatursendung. Ja. Da gab es ja eine mit Michel Friedmann
und Mithu Sanyal als Gäste.
Ja.
Die ja sowieso schon sehr flirty miteinander waren und dann auch irgendwann
ignoriert haben, dass sie bei Sophie Passmann in der Sendung sitzen und so ein
bisschen selbst in die Hand genommen haben.
Woraufhin die beiden sich dann offenbar privat dachten, komm lass uns nochmal
eine Veranstaltung machen.
Ich habe doch hier im jüdischen Museum in Frankfurt eh so einen Slot,
Denken ohne Geländer, so eine Veranstaltungsreihe, in der Friedmann einfach Gäste einlädt.
Komm du doch zu mir, wir reden über Liebe.
Sehr gut. So, also gab es am 23. Januar eine Veranstaltung zum Thema Liebe von
Michel Friedmann und Mithu Sanyal.
Ach das ist ja interessant, weil ich bin jetzt mit Samira eingeladen in Essen,
darüber zu reden, über Liebe zu reden.
Naja, ja, vielleicht machen wir einfach ein Re-enactment dieses Talks.
Oh, die Latte liegt hoch. Das war wirklich ein Spektakel mit den beiden,
weil die sitzen ja auch so bequem auf Sofas und so. Und es war schon sehr,
wie soll man sagen, heiter.
Und dieses Gespräch ging also los zum Thema, dass Sanyal meinte,
die Liebe ist ja das Gegenteil von Hass.
Es gibt also eine Unterscheidung mit zwei Seiten, Liebe und Hass.
Und dann haben sie so ein bisschen über Liebe und Hass geredet und natürlich
mit Vermerk auf Liebe, Liebe, die Vorzüge der Liebe, das Aufkommen der Liebe
in der Literatur und wie auch immer usw.
Und gegen Ende hat dann Sanyal so gefragt, Ja, aber brauchen wir Liebe nicht
als Grundbegriff in der Politik? Das wäre doch voll toll, wenn wir uns alle so ein bisschen lieben.
Und dann sagte Friedmann so ganz trocken, aber Liebe me too.
Du hast mir doch vorhin ganz ausführlich erzählt, dass Liebe nicht ohne Hass zu denken ist.
Also brauchen wir das nicht in der Politik. Weil es kippt von heute auf morgen
und dann haben wir alles Hass. Sehr richtig.
Und damit hat sie ihn, er sie, so ein bisschen schachmatt gesetzt.
Und es war dafür, dass die da so flirty in alle Richtungen abgetaucht sind,
auch so ein Okay, das Gespräch ist jetzt hier auch zu Ende.
Also nicht im Sinne von die verstehen sie nicht oder so, sondern ja,
wir träumten alle gerade so kurz eine Stunde lang von der Liebe,
aber es war halt nur ein Gespräch. So eine Realität ist dann doch anders.
Und jeder weiß es, wie ungerecht die Liebe sein kann, an wen sie gerät,
wer sie gerne möchte und nicht bekommt von einem und so weiter.
Also das ist nichts, wie man Politik organisieren sollte.
Ja, und ich finde auch gerade in der Liebe, wo man dann doch so eine göttliche
Fügung fast braucht und sowas, also wirklich darauf angewiesen ist.
Politik würde man vielleicht sagen, man muss höflich miteinander umgehen oder
zugewandt, vielleicht in manchen Aspekten auch liebevoll, aber Liebe kann da keinen Platz finden.
Liebe, Unterscheidung zum Hass, Liebe, Auslebung im Sex und dann da noch Zivilisations,
also es geht ja gerade darum, dass da vielleicht natürlich nur in Einvernehmlichkeit und so, aber...
Aber vielleicht hat er etwas Transgressives per se.
Ja, und wir sind ja auch auf einem Gebiet, wo wir mit Absicht bewusst und willentlich
jenseits des rationalen Erlebnisse machen wollen. Also es passt einfach gar nicht.
Und da aber trotzdem der 7. September als absoluter Tag des Hasses in die Geschichtsbücher eingeht,
und zwar irgendwie auch zurecht, wie soll man das sonst beschreiben, dachte ich mir,
ja, bei Pivot in diesem Podcast, die sonst nur über Tech-Kram reden und so,
von Kairos Fischer und Scott Calloway, die haben sich für die richtige Gesprächspartnerin
entschieden, nämlich über den 7.
Oktober zu reden mit Esther Perel. Die ja nun,
klar kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, sie ist von mir absolut hoch geschätzt,
ich vergöttere sie geradezu als Erklärerin aller Beziehungsprobleme und was
auch immer, nicht nur Liebesprobleme gemeint, Liebesbeziehungen,
sondern weil sie auch diese, also sie hat einfach auch Reichweite dafür,
also sie ist sowieso, auch wenn ich das jetzt nicht fände, wäre sie...
Die Figur, die man jetzt braucht, um sowas zu besprechen.
Sie ist nicht wie Jay Shetty, über den wir gesprochen haben.
Sie ist so gar nicht dieser Jay Shetty, sondern sie geht wirklich all in und
hat da Ahnung und sehr inspirierend und informativ und überhaupt und so.
Und sie haben sie dann im Podcast und reden mit ihr darüber,
ja wie gehen wir jetzt eigentlich damit um?
Und zwar, diesen Clip spiel ich nicht, aber wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen,
wie das ist, wenn Scott Galloway selber sehr viele Freunde in Israel hat und
dann wenige Tage später in einem Podcast darüber redet, wie er das jetzt findet,
was die Hamas da angerichtet hat.
Also wir wissen, das ist Holger im Quadrat. Weiß doch jeder, wer hier und so weiter.
Also beginnt dann dieses Gespräch mit Esther Perel und sie erklärt mal ihre
Herangehensweise an den Umgang mit diesen Erlebnissen auf erster Beobachterebene, 7. Oktober.
Die Menschen sind in Schock, die Menschen sind emotional nackt,
die Menschen sind in tiefen, tiefen Tränen,
die Menschen sind beängstigt, es gibt Terror,
es gibt Gegen-Terror und auf allen Seiten, aber wir sprechen über die Menschen,
die gerade begonnen haben, zu verstehen, dass es ein Massaker von epischen Proportionen
gab und und eine intergenerationale Trauma-Proportion, die auch in der Make ist.
Und die Antwort, wenn man angegriffen wird und man ein Tier ist,
wie wir sind, ist, dass wir versuchen, uns gegen die Angriffe zu verhindern
und stärker und höher zu gehen und uns selbst zu verteidigen und die Helplosigkeit,
die Schwäche und den Terror, die uns bevölkern, nicht zu spüren.
Und all das ist tief animalistisch.
Und es ist sehr wichtig, dass wir nicht viele, viele morale Stanzen aufnehmen,
besonders für die Menschen, die weit entfernt sind.
Es gibt so viel Angst und es ist sehr wichtig, dass die Menschen,
die um uns herum sind, diese kämpfenden Fraktionen nicht mehr Öl zum Feuer geben
und die Angst nicht noch stärker ausüben.
Verletzte Menschen verletzen Menschen.
Risiken, uns zu dehumanisieren. Wir fühlen, wir seien dehumanisiert,
wir antworten mit demselben, dass wir denken, es wird uns beschützen und manchmal
tut es das und dann geht es manchmal zu weit und zerstört uns sogar.
Wenn wir also eine Diskussion zum Thema Antisemitismus haben,
die dann ganz explizit in Deutschland von Michael Roth und Linnemann ausgelegt
wird, als jüdisches Leben ist jetzt zu verteidigen, auch wenn die Verteidigung
eines jüdischen Lebens bedeutet, dass tausend Leute in Gaza sterben müssen.
Dann haben wir es mit einer animalistischen Wende in diesem Diskurs zu tun,
der uns alle dehumanisiert.
Also der nimmt die Sprecher in diesen Diskussionen, die auf zweiter Beobachter-Ebene stattfinden,
Lippenbekenntnisse sind, Floskeln sind, weil Karsten Lindemann und Michael Roth
ziehen jetzt nicht in den Krieg, die nehmen keine Waffe in die Hand und die
bringen diese Kinder in Gaza einfach nicht selber um, sondern das erledigen
jetzt Bomben von oben und so.
Dann haben wir es hier mit einer animalistischen Wende zu tun.
Ja. Unter dem Deckmantel des Kampfes gegen Antisemitismus, von dem wir ja sagen,
aber die Lehre des Holocaust muss eine universalistische sein. Ja.
Das, was Adorno hier sagt. Dass man nicht in dieses, wer nicht für mich ist,
ist wieder mich, kommt, denn das war von jeher, schreibt Adorno,
dem Antisemitismus aus dem Herzen gesprochen.
Und wenn wir jetzt aber mal über das geopolitisch in anderer Weise sprechen,
Also Völkerrecht wurde angemahnt von Seiten der USA,
gleich bei dem Besuch muss eingehalten werden,
ist dann die Frage, inwieweit das auch Lippenbekenntnis ist oder dann auch tatsächlich
entsprechend durchgesetzt wird von Seiten der USA,
also Israel ist ja sehr stark auch davon abhängig, dass es die US amerikanische
Unterstützung gibt und zugleich
Vielleicht haben wir ja einen ganz anderen Diskurs über das Völkerrecht schon
im Zuge der Ukraine. Wir haben solche Protagonisten wie Carlo Marsala,
die eine Realpolitik einfordern und nicht mit diesen Werten kommen.
Wir müssen es auch hier wieder auftrösen. Wir haben die wertegeleitete Außenpolitik,
von der wir immer feststellen, ach so, das ist aber auch gerade nur dann, wenn es uns passt.
Wenn Katar aber uns jetzt Flüssiggas liefert, ist das okay. Orientalismus.
Selbst jetzt noch, wo ja Katar zwar möglicherweise sinnvoll sein kann,
um uns Geiseln zu befreien, aber andererseits wissen wir auch,
dass aus Katar Geld fließt an die Hamas und dass Katar zugleich super investiert
ist in deutsche DAX-Unternehmen.
Und da habe ich zumindest jetzt noch keine Sanktionsforderungen vernommen.
Mir wurde ja damals auch im Presseclub und sonst wo gesagt, als ich dann darauf
hinwies, Wir diversifizieren unser Autokratenportfolio und sind jetzt zum Beispiel
da bei Katta verwickelt.
Ja, das muss jetzt so sein, das ist Realpolitik.
Also mit anderen Worten, diese wertegeleitete Außenpolitik wird zwar genannt,
wird aber dann nur partiell gelebt.
Und dann gibt es zwei, die völlig unterschiedliche Positionen haben,
wie sie einen politischen Kontext bewerten. Aber vielleicht sind sie doch in
gewisser Weise ähnlich, dachte ich dann.
Nämlich Carlo Marsala und Michael Lüders, die ja beide auf eine Realpolitik
abheben und sagen Interessenpolitik.
Und jetzt würde Lüders andere Interessen stark machen als Carlo Marsala und umgekehrt.
Aber im Prinzip ist das ja sehr stark da. Und dann hatte die Zeit,
Marsala zitiert in so einem Interview noch mal. Und da heißt es,
Marsala sagt, eine realistische Politik für das 21.
Jahrhundert muss sich von den Fesseln des selbstverordneten völkerrechtlichen Dogmas lösen.
Und in dem Moment denke ich, wollen wir das jetzt wirklich machen?
Wenn wir das machen, dann gestehen wir natürlich, also ich will nicht leugnen,
dass Völkerrecht, dass wir immer mit Doppelstandards gelebt haben und Afghanistan
und, und, und. Viele Lügen des Westens, ja.
Aber dass das Völkerrecht auch ein Fundament war, Schlimmeres zu verhindern.
Dass das auch dann quasi die Leitlinie ist, mit der man retrospektiv dann genau
so etwas sagt wie, naja Afghanistan, das war aber auch nicht korrekt,
das war nicht der Krieg, der hätte geführt werden dürfen.
Und wenn wir uns aber davon jetzt befreien, von diesem, wie er es nennt,
völkerrechtlichen, uns selbst verordneten Dogma.
Ist ja wirklich alles offen. Also dann begeben wir uns ja nur noch in ein globales
Kräftemessen, wo wir nur noch sagen, ja der Stärkere möge gewinnen.
Und dann kann man sagen, ja mal gucken, wie lange wir jetzt Israel noch unterstützen.
Irgendwann gewinnt dann sonst ein
anderer Stärkerer. Aber dann geht es ja überhaupt um nichts mehr als das.
Also ich finde das ganz Vielleicht können wir diesen einen Clip gerade spielen,
weil er so gut passt, zum Völkerrecht von Michael Wurfsohn, der das natürlich
in sehr großer Ehrlichkeit bekannte bei Anne Will. Aber es hat mich auch beängstigt.
Das Völkerrecht ist hervorragend geeignet zur internationalen Bekämpfung der
Blattlaus und sonst nichts.
Und also, wenn es um Sein und Nichtsein geht ... Tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist ... Sie nehmen es gar nicht ernst. Bitte? Sie nehmen es nicht ernst?
Er ist ernst, aber ich bin Historiker und ich muss die Wirklichkeit,
wie sie ist, darstellen.
Und in Situationen, wo es um Leben und Tod geht, richtet sich derjenige,
der sein Leben verteidigen muss oder der glaubt, so und anders nicht vorgehen
zu können, hält er sich nicht daran. Das ist das Faktum.
Aber dann ist das doch doch ein Freifahrtschein. Also, Putin glaubt ja auch, so vorgehen zu müssen.
Ich würd noch eine Stufe früher ... Er ist Historiker, aber offenbar dumm,
weil das ist einfach, ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, ich finde sowas ganz dumm.
Das Völkerrecht ist ein Recht, deswegen steckt der Recht im Namen.
Und jetzt sagt er, es gibt so Elementare, wenn es um Leben und Tod geht und
so weiter, da hält sich ja keiner ein Recht. Ja, stimmt. Also wenn das Schiff
untergeht, sind die Regeln egal.
Frauen und Kinder zuerst? Nee, ich und so, ja, unterm Strich zähle ich.
Also klar gibt es die Situationen, in denen das Recht nicht gilt.
Gilt. Und jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass ausgerechnet im Krieg und viel Völkerrecht
möchte Krieg regeln, ausgerechnet im Krieg gilt das Völkerrecht nicht.
Das ist aber eine Feststellung, von der wir einfach sagen, okay,
Leute, wir waren alle mal sieben Jahre und in der ersten Klasse und haben festgestellt,
da, wo es drauf ankommt, gelten die Regeln nicht.
Die sind doch gerade für den Moment gemacht, wo sie dann nicht gelten,
das ist ja ein interessantes Paradox.
Nur, da würde ich sagen, ja, aber bitte, dass das so ist,
ist halt einfach so, aber das kann man dann nicht einfach eins zu eins in so
eine Anne-Will-Sendung bringen,
weil wir ja aufgeklärt sind und wissen, ah, das Recht bringt jemand Dritten
in eine Streitpartei, Also in eine Streitpartie, in der zwei Streitparteien sind.
So. Und insbesondere bei Kapitalverbrechen, und dann beginnt es ja bei der Verletzung
körperlicher Unversehrtheit und endet eben bei Folter und so, wie wir es am 7.
Oktober gesehen haben, gibt es
ja sogar eine Pflicht für den unbeteiligten Dritten jetzt aktiv zu werden.
Beim Kapitalverbrechen braucht man keinen Kläger, sondern allein die Beobachtung,
da hat jemand jemandem was angetan.
Dann sind alle in der Pflicht, jetzt die Polizei zu holen. Das muss nicht das Opfer selber machen.
Und auch wenn das Opfer sich dagegen wehrt, gibt es trotzdem eine Pflicht,
da einzugreifen, auf Basis dieses Rechts.
Wenn ich dir jetzt hier eine über die Rübe haue, dann kann ich das als Beweis
nehmen, das Recht gilt nicht.
Das Recht deiner Unversehrtheit und so weiter gilt nicht. Aber das heißt ja
nicht, dass das Recht an sich nicht gilt. Das hat doch für mich gerade hier nicht gegolten.
Ganz genau. Solange es unbeteiligte Dritte gibt, Deswegen hat man ja sowas wie
Den Haag. Ja, also wir haben Kriege zwischen der Ukraine und Russland.
Aber es ist noch kein Weltkrieg, sondern es ist ein Krieg zwischen Ukraine und
Russland. Wir haben einen Krieg zwischen Israel und Gaza.
Die Hamas im Libanon, angeführt von der iranischen Regierung,
beteiligt sich da gerade nicht.
Amerika ist nicht mit amerikanischen Soldaten gerade in Israel und beschützt
da noch irgendwas und so weiter.
Also wir haben noch unbeteiligte Dritte, für die dieses Recht jetzt gerade da ist.
Weil es nämlich denen Orientierung dazu gibt, wie verhalten wir uns jetzt als Dritte unbeteiligte.
Und selbst in den Kriegen, wir haben zwar Völkerrechtsverletzungen im hohen
Maße von russischer Seite und aber auch dann einige von ukrainischer Seite.
Und dennoch ist das ja nach wie vor das Völkerrecht der Maßstab,
nachdem wir genau dies dann auch beurteilen.
Und nicht umsonst versucht ja dann auch eine Regierung solche völkerrechtlichen
Versäumnisse oder oder Missachtungen zu vertuschen oder oder so.
Das zeigt ja, dass das ein Standard ist, an dem man es auslegt,
dass man nicht einfach sagt, ja so ist es halt, so machen wir es.
Und das ist auch der Unterschied, was Israel,
das ist ja auch vielen, die jetzt da falsch demonstrieren,
sag ich mal, nicht klar ist, dass es schon ein Unterschied ist,
ob Israel an das Völkerrecht gebunden ist und sich dann mal in Punkten nicht
dran halten würde, während die Hamas einfach sagt, das ist gar nicht existent mehr für uns.
Da ist alles egal, was man ja dann an diesen Abschlachtungen sehen kann.
Und deswegen darf auch niemals eine Solidarisierung mit der Hamas stattfinden,
weil das wirklich die Terrororganisation ist, mit der man sich nicht solidarisieren kann.
Aber lass uns mal genau bei diesem Gedanken bleiben. Wir dürfen uns nicht mit
der Hamas sympathisieren oder solidarisieren oder identifizieren oder wie auch immer,
Weil dann sind wir ja auf dieser Ebene der Hamas, wo einfach das basale,
banale Recht des Stärkeren und dann bin ich auch total dafür,
einfach abzukürzen, dass Böse gilt, so regiert.
So, wenn wir jetzt aber sagen, von außen betrachtet, naja, wenn sich die Hamas
so verhält, dann dürfen wir das auch.
Als eine andere Partei, die nicht die Hamas ist, aber die sich genauso verhalten
darf wie die Hamas, dann sind wir auf genau derselben Ebene angekommen.
Und das propagiert der Wolfssonn hier.
Ja, und das finde ich schlimm. Und das ist ein Diskurs, den wir bei der Ukraine
hatten, als es um Waffen geht, die geächtet sind, die man forderte,
wo man dann auch sagt, warum dann nicht auch Landminen, warum dann nicht auch
das? Russland macht das ja auch, genau.
Deswegen kämpfen wir ja gegen Russland, weil wir das nicht wollen,
dass jemand sich so verhält. diese Sachen eingeschrieben. Aber um das gerade
noch mal zu der Hamas-Nummer einzuschieben.
Ich will es mal so drastisch formulieren, weil mich es wirklich geärgert hat.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich kann verstehen, wenn jetzt Demonstrationen stattfinden,
die für Waffenstillstand sind, die die palästinensischen zivilen Opfer beklagen.
All das ja. Und Kontextualisierung ist wichtig.
Aber dass man mit der Hamas sich verbindet, dass man dort Hamas-Narrative übernimmt
und zum Teil deren Kanäle teilt von, ich sag's jetzt mal, Woken-Aktivisten aus.
Da muss ja auch schon einiges im Köpfchen schieflaufen. Also die tun ja gerade
so, als würde die Hamas dann bald alle Flinter-Personen dieser Erde befreien.
Nein, ihr seid die Nächsten auf der Hamels.
Ja, genau. Macht euch das mal bitte klar. Da gilt diese Logik,
die Friedmann ja immer wieder betont.
Es beginnt ja nur da bei offensichtlichen Merkmalen, schwarze Haut,
spricht nicht meine Sprache, Banause und so weiter, alle weg.
Es droppt sich ja dann ran, bis nur noch einer übrig bleibt.
Das ist ja genau die Gefahr. Und es gibt bei Wolfsson noch so einen zweiten
Punkt, wenn er so sagt, das Völkerrecht gilt ja in dem Moment,
wo es eigentlich gebraucht würde.
Also neben diesem Argumentation, ja, aber es ist für den unbeteiligten Dritten,
der sich dann darüber verständigen muss, wie er denn da eingreift.
Oder auch, wie der unbeteiligte Dritte das Containment organisiert.
Also die Amerikaner könnten jetzt auch sagen, wir glauben nicht,
dass die Diplomatie erfolgreich wird. Wir bombardieren jetzt lieber mal den
Iran. Ja. So, wäre auch eine Möglichkeit. Ja. Und dann würde man sagen,
nee, das ist keine Möglichkeit. Und zwar wegen Völkerrecht.
Ausdrücklich wegen diesen historischen Erfahrungen, die dazu führten,
dass wir eine Errungenschaft wie das Völkerrecht haben.
Das Völkerrecht ist ja in der Hinsicht wirklich einfach nur kondensierte Geschichte.
Man könnte auch ein ewig langes Seminar wieder über den Holocaust und so weiter
führen und deswegen machen wir das nicht. Oder man sagt einfach das Völkerrecht.
Aber man darf eben die Abkürzung, das Völkerrecht, nicht zu kurz machen.
Also ein bisschen Geschichte muss immer mitgeliefert werden.
Deswegen ist es besonders blöd, wenn der Wolfson dann einfach völlig geschichtsvergessen
plötzlich irgendwelche Insekten nennt oder so. Also das Völkerrecht regelt nicht
das Leben von Insekten, sondern das Leben von Menschen und schon diese Unterscheidung
macht, also ist sehr wichtig.
Aber ich habe den Verdacht, dass sich dieser Diskurs, weil das wurde jetzt da
mal vorgetragen, Massana hatte eigentlich einen ähnlichen Ansatz, ich will jetzt...
Dass das etwas ist, was wahrscheinlich uns immer mehr begegnen wird.
Du hast eben über eigentlich so ein langsames verblassen des Occidentalismus gesprochen.
Und diese Selbstverständlichkeit, die natürlich oft mit so einer paternalistischen
oder kolonialistischen Geste daherkam,
diese implizierte aber auch dann vielleicht doch eine Selbstverständlichkeit,
dass man also das Völkerrecht schon als wichtig ansah, auch wenn man es nicht immer beachtet hat.
Und ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass diese Selbstverständlichkeit auch verblasst
und dann finden wir uns und wir gehen ja schon in diese Richtung und wir sehen
das auch an dieser rhetorischen Aufrüstung dahin,
dass wir uns nur noch in einem Kräftemessen global gegenüberstehen und dann
sind wir in so einem Social Darwinism aber im geopolitischen Spektrum.
Und wenn ich und den der also der Massala hat ganz glücklich getwittert,
dass Pistorius, was in dem Interview gesagt und Man hat dann auch noch so angemerkt,
mit allerdings, ich glaube, ZwinkerSmiley hat Pistorius wohl mein Buch gelesen,
aber wenn Pistorius in einem Interview sagt,
und das heißt, wir müssen kriegstüchtig werden,
wir müssen wehrhaft sein und die Bundeswehr und die Gesellschaft dafür aufstellen,
dann hat das noch nichts gegen das Völkerrecht gesagt, aber dass man überhaupt
jetzt sagt, wir stehen jetzt Krieg, wir müssen kriegstüchtig werden,
wehrhaft und Bundeswehr und Gesellschaft dafür aufstellen, also auch wir sollen
quasi schon als Gesellschaft militarisiert werden.
Wenn das jetzt die Welt ist, auf die das hinausläuft.
Also wir haben es im Ukraine Krieg ausführlich diskutiert. Drei Tage Regen führen
hier zu 70 Milliarden Euro Schaden, dem zweitgrößten Finanzfolgen durch Klima.
Stefan, ich glaube, worin wir uns am meisten eigentlich sind,
ich glaube, das ist… Lass mal Salah einen Knaller. Nein, nein, nein.
Aber was für uns wirklich so eine Grundlage ist… Dass unser Bizeps es nicht ist.
Wir sehnen uns eigentlich beide von systemtheoretischer wie marxistischer Seite danach,
dass man wenigstens ökonomisch denkt,
dass man wenigstens ökonomisch rational denkt und ich befürchte aber,
ich befürchte, dass sehr viele mächtige Menschen, in Klammern Politiker,
leider nicht ökonomisch denken, denn dann würden wir ja, wie wir wissen,
über Migration, Grundsicherung, alles anders reden.
Das heißt, unsere Sehnsucht, dann denkt doch wenigstens mal ökonomisch pragmatisch.
Die ist eine, die immer seltener befriedigt wird und das macht mir Angst.
Ich habe ja kritisiert, dass selbst Michel Friedmann in den Literatures auf
der Bühne sitzt und ein ökonomisches Argument macht, statt nochmal die Idee
Mensch, die er sonst, muss ich betonen. Ich bin jetzt wieder auch davon abgerückt,
das allzu sehr zu kritisieren, denn ich halte das auch für den richtigen Weg.
Weil zum Beispiel Kriege ökonomisch nix bringen. Also das ist ja auch so eine
Mär, dass man gesagt hat, Kriege bringen was. Ja, das bringt ein paar Leuten etwas.
Also das ökonomische Denken führt uns zu einer einheitlichen Rationalität,
bei der jeder seinen Platz einfach reflektieren kann, die approximationshoffnungsmäßig
sehr weit zum Universalismus führt.
Weiter als viele andere politische Ideen und so weiter. In der Hinsicht,
da sind wir uns wirklich sehr einig, auch wenn wir daraus ganz unterschiedlich in die Richtung kommen.
Ich wollte noch anmerken, dass bei dem Wolfssohn...
Und ich will immer explizit jetzt dazu sagen, es ist schon eingepreist,
das Völkerrecht ist für den Dritten.
Solange es noch einen Dritten gibt, brauchen wir das Völkerrecht.
Wenn irgendwann mal der Tribalismus obsiegt hat und wir noch zwei Lager auf
der Welt haben und es gibt keinen Dritten mehr, dann Recht des Stärkeren.
Also dann hilft uns das Völkerrecht wirklich nicht mehr so, aber bis dahin ist
es glaube ich noch ein bisschen Weg.
Und da sollten wir auch daran festhalten, dass es möglichst lange bleibt.
Und das zweite Wichtige, auch für jemanden, der von sich sagt,
ich bin Historiker, da würde ich sagen, schön, aber greife trotzdem auch mal
zu einem soziologischen Buch, die Unterscheidung, Struktur und Semantik.
Wenn man feststellt, dass es für das Völkerrecht in dem Moment,
wo man es braucht, also kriegerische Auseinandersetzung, kein Korrelat gibt
auf struktureller Ebene, also man stellt einfach materiell fest,
hier hält sich keiner dran.
Oder die Hamas geht sogar bewusst gegen die Regeln des Völkerrechts vor und
sagt, nee, wir foltern hier, wir foltern vor allem Frauen und Kinder und wir
stellen das noch ins Internet.
Dann hat es trotzdem einen gewissen Gehalt, auf einer semantischen Ebene zumindest
mal über völkerrechtliche Regeln
zu reden, weil wir kennen das Bedingungsverhältnis nicht so ganz genau.
Historiker helfen uns auch überhaupt nicht dabei, darüber aufzuklären,
aber es gibt ein Bedingungsverhältnis zwischen Semantik und Struktur.
Und irgendwie wird die Struktur immer mitgeschleicht, wenn semantisch vorbereitet wird.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir aufhören, über das Völkerrecht zu reden oder es in Argumentationen
mal anzuführen, dann müssen wir uns erst recht nicht wundern,
dass es strukturell keine Entsprechung mehr hat.
Nur zu fordern, ja dann können wir mal gleich darüber auf...
Weil wir sehen, also strukturell hat es schon keine Entsprechung,
ja dann können wir diese Mantik, nee, das ist ja genau umgedreht.
Wir bräuchten jetzt einen Appell für mehr Gespräche über Völkerrecht.
Es in so einer Anne-Will-Sendung einfach mal ernst zu nehmen und dann inhaltliche
Argumentationen daraus zu entwickeln, um dann zu hoffen, dass es sozusagen Folgen
auf struktureller Ebene gibt.
Und sei es bei der nächsten politischen Entscheidung zwischen Pistorius und
Olaf Scholz, wie wir jetzt unseren Beitrag da gestalten und für wen auch.
Also unterstützen wir wirklich nur Israel oder gibt es dann auch doch noch mal
eine Diskussion darüber, wie sieht das jetzt aus mit den LKWs,
die vor Gaza stehen, wo wir sehen, da sind wirklich nur Decken drin,
aus denen kann man auch keine Raketen bauen. Also irgendwie so.
Gut, aber wir waren ja gerade bei Israel und dieser allerersten Ebene,
also da, wo man einfach feststellt, ja, also hier Völkerrecht ist mir gerade
egal, weil hier wurde gerade meiner Schwester Kopf abgeschlagen oder was auch immer.
Wie geht man jetzt damit um? Und es ist,
finde ich wirklich erstaunlich, wie explizit hier sagt, wir müssen von moralischen
Bekenntnissen absehen, eigenen oder sie hinterfragen und insbesondere auch davon,
sie von anderen einzufordern.
Und das mal so als These, dass das ein Weg ist, der uns wohin führt,
wird von ihr noch mit der Argumentation unterfüttert, die ich wirklich erstaunlich
finde, dass ansonsten die Menschlichkeit selbst uns in Bedrängnis gerät. Drängnisgerät.
Let me ask you, how are you doing?
Ich bin hier nur zwei Stunden auf dem Fahrrad gefahren und habe eine dieser
zwei Stunden mit meinen Freunden und meiner Familie auf dem Telefon verbracht, um nachzusehen.
Man hört auf, versucht nicht zu verurteilen.
Wir können in politische Diskussionen einsteigen.
Wir wissen, was die Geschichte ist. Wir sind ein paar informierte Menschen,
aber dies ist nicht der Moment.
Es ist so, als ob die Menschen nicht viel Rationalität haben.
Man hält sie, man beinhaltet sie, man macht sie fühlen, als ob sie hören wollen,
man kann sie tolerieren, man kümmert sich um sie, und man kreiert ein Envelope,
Arme, das einfach sagt, ich halte dich in deinem Schmerz, in deiner Wut.
Bitte sei vorsichtig, bitte geh nicht irrationale Dinge machen.
Aber niemand entscheidet viel von diesen Dingen alleine. Was viel hilft,
im Allgemeinen, ist, dass die Leute aktiv werden, etwas tun,
damit sie nicht fühlen, als ob sie dort helpless sitzen und es einfach alles mitnehmen.
Volontäre, schicken Dinge, schreiben zu den Leuten, informieren,
lesen vorsichtig und lesen Dinge, die nicht nur Ihren Seiten beschreiben, wo du stehst.
Versuche einfach, so gut du kannst, offen zu bleiben, um ein wenig zu verstehen,
wie der andere Seite, welcher Seite du bist, weil es so viel gibt und Social Media hilft dem nicht.
Es ist so, als ob du ein Wort in dieser Fähigkeit gesagt hättest,
oder zu sagen, dass du über diese Person denkst, dann bekommst du einen Schlag.
Schande an dich, dass du nicht über diese Seite denkst. Schande an dich,
Schande an dich. Und jede Seite, die du nicht halten kannst, eine morale ...
Dies ist nicht der Zeitpunkt, um eine morale Balance zu halten.
Du musst Seiten nehmen. Und diese Seite verweigert alles von der anderen Seite.
Es gibt sehr wenig Nuance und sehr wenig Komplexität.
So every time you see a place where people are able to not bite at each other,
but just hold each other, we are a little closer to our humanity.
Wir hören das ja alle sehr aufgeregt, ich höre sowas natürlich auch.
Schöner kann man das ja nicht sagen.
Ja, vor allem das ist eben aus dieser Ebene, mich interessiert nur die elementare
soziale Beziehung zwischen Menschen, egal welcher Form, aber sie muss elementar
sein. Also nicht Medien vermittelt, parasozial, sonstiges, massenmedial und so weiter.
Was jetzt also ich höre hier wenn ich so ein Clip höre, dann höre ich einfach nur,
Das, was ich von allen Politikern höre derzeit in Deutschland, ist kontraproduktiv.
Also wenn Michael Roth da sitzt und sagt, wir müssen jetzt gegen den Antisemitismus
kämpfen, fördert er ihn eigentlich. Er produziert ihn regelrecht.
Als hätte er so eine Antisemitismus-Fabrik angeschaltet in der ARD.
Und am Ende kommt mehr Antisemitismus raus.
Obwohl er doch innerlich so… Ja, aber es ist, glaube ich, die Hilflosigkeit
der Politik. Also ich würde jetzt so weit in den Kurven nicht gehen,
aber es ist diese Hilflosigkeit, wie… Sie meinen ja nicht intentional.
Ja, ja, nicht intentional.
Aber es passiert ja trotzdem. Ja, ja. Ich glaube, was hier für mich in diesem Clip drin steckt,
ist, dass sie ja versucht aufzuzeigen, dass wir uns eigentlich,
wenn wir mal von all den politischen Einstellungen, Ideologien absehen,
als Menschen gegenüber treten und als Menschen sowohl als auch Wesen sind in gewisser Weise.
Und als Menschen würden wir eigentlich eine Ambiguitäts-Toleranz doch annehmen,
die wir aber sobald so ein politischer Diskurs kommt, der ganz stark mit Schlagworten
arbeitet, dass wir dies nicht mehr zulassen.
Und es war so, dass ich vor wenigen Wochen in Trier war,
bei den Wochen gegen Antisemitismus und sollte da einen Film auswählen,
wo ich dann einen Vortrag halte und es war Leg dich nicht mit Zohan an.
Kennst du den? Mit Adam Sandler.
Ein an sich sehr vulgärer Film.
Ich hab nochmal Augenlider umgeturnt. Und ich war ein bisschen verblüfft,
warum ich jetzt einen Adam Sandler Film nehme und nicht irgendwas Wichtiges
von Claude Lanzmann oder so.
Nee, nee, der Film ist schon sehr gut und ich musste jetzt sehr viel an diesen Filmen denken,
denn tatsächlich ist es das ja, also er handelt ja von Antisemitismus und auch Islamfeindlichkeit,
also er spielt ja im Zuge von 9-11, also die Jahre danach, wo jeder,
wie du eben sagtest, der einen langen Bart hat.
Er ist der super Mossad Agent, der...
Der dort immer gegen die Terroristen kämpft, aber eigentlich etwas anderes sein
möchte, nämlich Friseur.
Er möchte eigentlich nicht mehr kämpfen. Die Eltern können es gar nicht verstehen.
Ja, das Gegenteil. Wir haben ja immer zu Geschichten gehört von Leuten,
die Friseur sind und dann sagen, aber ich gehe jetzt in den Krieg.
Und das ist genau der umgekehrte Weg. Er sagt, ich möchte jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, ich war ja erfolgreich und so. Und ich gehe jetzt nach New York.
Und dort trifft er aber dann auf eine Frau, die Palästinenserin ist,
also einen palästinensischen Migrationshintergrund hat. Und sie weiß nicht,
dass er Israelis und auch noch Mossad-Agent war.
Und dann gibt es einmal so ganz kurz schon mal, dass sie so sagt,
ja, das Problem ist ja da mit Israel.
Naja, aber ihr ja auch. Und so geht das direkt los. Und dann wird das aber Und
dann gibt's also palästinensische Terroristen, die eigentlich einen Anschlag auf ihn verüben wollen.
Und er, na ja, ich will diese Geschichte jetzt nicht weiterzuhören.
Jedenfalls schafft dieser Film, der mit ganz viel Blödelhumor und Vulgärkomik
arbeitet, am Ende klarzumachen, vergesst diesen ganzen Hass,
steht euch als Menschen mal gegenüber.
Und das ist wirklich eine ganz große Utopie, die da ausgerollt wird von Adam Sandler.
Wo auch diese ganzen antisemitischen, antiisraelischen und auch antiislamischen
Klischees wunderbar auf die Schippe genommen werden und dann dadurch entkräftet werden.
Dann stehen sich plötzlich Menschen gegenüber und davon will der eine gern Friseur
werden und der andere will irgendeinen Handyladen betreiben und mehr nicht.
Und die sind auch eigentlich ökonomisch vernünftig, weil die sagen,
wir wollen doch eigentlich nur hier auch ein bisschen Geld verdienen,
das ist doch gut, reicht doch.
Und deswegen kann ich diesen Film ausdrücklich empfehlen. Das ist,
ich würde sagen, zum Nahost-Konflikt einer der besten Filme.
Sehr gut. Also, die Issa Perel hat ja auch sehr viel über Artificial Intimacy gesprochen.
Heute kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zu diesen Clips. Wir werden die aber
noch ausführlich besprechen, weil das eben genau dieses Gegenprogramm ist.
Elementares Zusammensein, sich wahrnehmen, fühlen und so weiter im Vergleich zu ...
Naja, aber ich mache doch jetzt einen Tweet für 30.000 Leute.
Ja. So. Und dann kriegt man ein paar Reaktionen und irgendwas,
aber man kennt so ziemlich genau diesen Unterschied.
Und Adam Curry, den ich ja mittlerweile wirklich verabscheue für seinen Podcast,
aber der hat bei sich kurz so ein Bild aufgemacht von der Meme-Ship.
Ich kenn den gar nicht. Adam Curry war früher mal so ein MTV-Moderator,
errang darüber so eine gewisse Prominenz und ist dann ins Podcast-Business als
der Podcast-Brother eingestiegen, macht aber mit NOAH GENDER SHOW so einen völlig abgedrehten...
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen Trumpistigen Podcast, aber wir wissen ja,
wie es ist, wenn die Leute sagen, wir haben ja keine Agenda.
Nee, nee. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber so hörerfinanziert, dass sie dann so
quasi auf Publikumsfang sind.
Und dann sagen, ach vielleicht doch nochmal.
Es ist im Grunde ein richtiger tribalistischer Podcast. Ja. Alterweise Männer
machen nochmal was, so in Amerika, Free Speech und so weiter.
Und auch ruhig nochmal ein Q&A an Aktivisten.
Aber manchmal hat er so Alltagsbeobachtungen und er meinte so,
also er hat diesen Begriff jetzt geprägt, der Meme-Ship.
Es gibt Friendships und alles, was online stattfindet, ist eine Meme-Ship.
Also man schickt sich so kleine Stupser, guck mal hier, dieses Meme.
Also man schickt gar keine Textbotschaften mehr, sondern man fischt einfach
nur noch aus den Newsfeeds und schickt dann mal kotzweiß rüber und hofft,
dass es in 2D zurückkommt und sowas. Also völlig sinnentleertes.
Ja, wir nehmen uns noch als lebendig wahr, aber darüber gibt es keine weitere Tiefe.
Und das finde ich jetzt wahnsinnig interessant. Grundsätzlich jetzt diesen Zusammenhang
zwischen, okay, wir haben einen Nahostkonflikt, von dem uns gesagt wird,
das sind Jahrhunderte, die das überspannt.
Und wenn wir verstehen wollen, was da passiert, muss erst mal Herr Schneider
in irgendeinem Podcast gehen und uns eine Stunde lang erzählen was und so.
Und man denkt sich so, nö, am Ende ist es doch wie bei Sohan.
Wir begegnen uns direkt auf der Straße und die Geschichte ist einfach egal.
Also es ist nur entscheidend, was als nächstes passiert. Überhaupt nicht,
was früher passierte. Wurden natürlich auch alle von Freud in die Irre geführt.
Ich bin ja immer noch großer Alfred Adler Fan, auch wenn ich es nicht mal so ganz nehme und so.
Aber Adler sagt ja auch, es ist egal was war, entscheidend ist ja,
was kommt. Also wo man Handlungshoheit hat und dann steckt man halt das Feld
der Alternativen ab und so weiter und so fort.
Und da ist es ja auch, finde ich nicht unbedeutend, mal festzustellen,
okay, der eine oder andere Hamas in Anführungszeichen Kämpfer,
der da auch unausgerüstet, also nur mit Waffe, aber gar nicht,
also wo die auch ihn losgeschickt haben mit, du wirst eh gleich erschossen.
Ja, das ist ja Selbstmord. Genau, wir rüsten dich erst gar nicht aus,
weil das wird ja irgendwie 100 Euro kosten, dir jetzt eine Schussweste zu geben.
Also die Hamas hat so einen Hass gegen alle, dann ihre eigenen Leute da so losgeschickt,
dass die zum Teil das erste Mal mit 20 Jahren überhaupt außerhalb von Gaza waren
und dann auf Juden trafen und die einfach abgeschlachtet haben.
Also um das prinzipiell zu verstehen, was da passiert, braucht man keine 500.000
Jahre Antisemitismusgeschichte.
Also es ist einfach völlig egal, was vor 800 Jahren passierte oder so.
Und diese, wie soll man sagen, runterbrechen auf die Erklärungsfolie ist das Elementare und so.
Deswegen ja die Isra Perel hier so entscheidend ist, weil sie einfach,
da begegnen sich halt Menschen und die begegnen sich halt. So und jetzt ist
es aber trotzdem interessant, dass wir ja immer es für wichtig finden, wer spricht.
Ja.
Und wir sagen dann, na es ist schon nicht schlecht, wenn der Böhm und der Harari,
weil die einen israelischen Hintergrund haben, die kennen das Land,
die kennen die Religion und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, aber da würden wir, Moment, also wir...
Also für den Diskurs ist es sehr entscheidend.
Ja, wer spricht im Sinne von Expertise. Aber wir nehmen ja jetzt nicht den Harari,
weil der Israeli ist, sondern weil der sich mit Israel auch auskennt.
Oder den Böhm, weil der sich mit Israel, dem Universalismus,
dem Judentum usw. auskennt.
Böhm, Harari und Feldman, Feldman haben wir jetzt gehört und Friedman.
Aber weil sie Experten sind. Genau. Nicht weil sie, die Identität allein,
will ich damit sagen, reicht nicht aus.
Aber du weißt was ich meine, es spielt so eine gewisse Rolle.
Wir als Deutsche würden denen jetzt die Argumente nicht so aus der Hand schlagen,
nur weil sie uns nicht gefallen. Doch.
Böhm wäre absolut dafür. Ja Böhm wäre auch dafür. Böhm wäre absolut dafür zu sagen.
Ich meine jetzt so im Twitter-Diskurs. Ach so im Twitter-Diskurs, da ist das natürlich so.
Wenn dann so ein Tweet von Michael Feldmann auch da ist.
Aber das ist ja genau dieses Problem, das ist ja dieses Problem,
dass das, wie war dieser Begriff von Feldmann, dieser Entlastungsjude.
Also das darf man natürlich nicht anfangen, dass man sagt, so ich habe hier
mal als Schutzschilde folgende mitgebracht, um das mal nach vorne zu stellen.
Und deswegen würde ich immer sagen, die kommen zu Wort, weil sie eine Expertise
da haben und ja, die haben auch noch die jüdische Identität,
wenn man so möchte, wenngleich die ja schon bei allen drei vermutlich sehr anders ausgeprägt sein wird.
Genau. Und im Rahmen dieser Sache, die wir jetzt so ein bisschen angesprochen haben,
ist es wahnsinnig interessant, diesen nächsten Clip zu hören,
eine Minute lang, wie Issa Perel gefragt wird, selber Israelin und so weiter,
wie sie denn so zu ihren Sachen kommt, zu ihrem Interesse allgemein für soziale Beziehungen.
Dann auch über Bande gefragt, fragt ein Kehrswischer, im Grunde also höre ich
es auch aus, ist eigentlich irre, so eine hochgradig politische Problemlage
und wir haben jetzt trotzdem Sie angefragt.
Können Sie uns das mal erklären, was uns dazu geführt hat, so ungefähr,
warum wir jetzt Sie als Beziehungsexpertin einladen, um über diesen 7.
Oktober und so weiter zu reden.
Und jetzt wollte ich eben auch sagen, es ist ganz entscheidend,
hier auch sich zu fragen, könnte man das, was sie jetzt sagt,
annehmen, sozusagen, als Grundlage für, ah ja, deswegen ist es so interessant.
Sie redet auch kurz über den Holocaust, also sie führt es kurz an, als Begriff fällt das.
Und trotzdem denkt man so, ja genau, was macht darüber hinaus Sinn?
Also man könnte jetzt auch den Holocaust ansprechen und dass sie Israelin ist
und da so Erfahrungen macht, wenn es ein anderer Konflikt wäre,
aber nur durch Zufall ist es halt jetzt der 7. Oktober in Israel und Gaza und so.
So wie wir vorhin schon hatten, dass Harari sagt, ja und so,
wenn Leute von weiter weg das beobachten, haben die eine andere Verantwortung
und sollten eben nicht emotional und intellektuell faul sein,
insbesondere in Deutschland.
Ist auch so eine allgemeine, also ja, das macht Sinn, da Deutschland zu sagen.
Und zwar nicht nur, weil es deutsches Publikum ist, so ungefähr,
ne? Also dieser Clip hier, wie kommt Issa Perel überhaupt zu ihrer ganzen, was sie halt so macht?
Und dann im Kontext, also da kommt so viel zusammen und es ist,
es fallen die Signalworte und es ist trotzdem so unpolitisch einfach.
Also im Bogen vom Holocaust bis zum Elementaren, wie gehen wir jetzt mit uns
und unseren Gefühlen um, wenn wir sowas im Fernsehen sehen, ohne alles was dazwischen,
sonst immer typischerweise reingepackt wird.
Hier das Völkerrecht, da die deutsche Verantwortung und so weiter und so fort.
Es war einfach nur, nee, Holocaust und jetzt.
Ich denke, mein Vater war ein illiterater Mann, der drei Jahre lang zur Schule
gegangen ist, aber er war ein wahrer Menschenrechtlicher.
Meine Mutter auch, aber mein Vater, er hatte einfach nur einen Weg,
sich mit jemandem zu verabschieden, den er auf der Straße, an der Gasstation,
was auch immer, treffen würde und anfangen zu sprechen.
Ich denke, er hat das schon lange vorher verstanden und er hat mir das immer
gesagt. Nicht über Geld verletzt werden, nicht über Bildung verletzt werden.
Der einzige Kriterium ist Gerechtigkeit.
Wer respektiert und behandelt dich mit Gerechtigkeit und Gerechtigkeit?
Und er hat in der Konzentration gelernt, zwischen denen, die noch einen Hinblick
auf die Menschheit hatten, und denen, die pur sadistisch und psychopathisch waren.
Und in diesem Sinne hat er gesagt, schau auf die Person, gib ihnen eine Chance und verurteile nicht.
Es ist so einfach, zu verurteilen. Denk nicht, dass sie von deiner Tribe besser
sind oder von der anderen Tribe. Sie sind definitiv böse.
Es ist viel subtiler und viel vorsichtiger und justizierter.
Ihr Vater war nur drei Jahre in der Schule. Wir würden dann heute sagen, es ist ein Analphabet.
So, ein völlig unliterat, unliterarischer, hat wahrscheinlich nie ein Buch gelesen oder so.
Und kommt dann aus der Konzentrationslagergefangenschaft ins Familienleben rein.
Und seine Tochter lernt von ihm, ich hab damals im Konzentrationslager unterschieden
zwischen Menschen, die noch grundlegende Achtung füreinander aufbringen oder
nicht. Und es war nicht deckungsgleich mit, das sind die Juden und das sind die Nazis.
Und da muss man sagen, das ist wirklich eine krasse Grundlage,
um so eine Lehre zu ziehen, die dann wirklich truly universalistisch ist,
also überall anwendbar.
Es ist unglaublich, dass man überhaupt mal so eine weitreichende Argumentation dafür hat.
Und die einzige Textgrundlage, die mir jetzt dazu einfällt, ist eigentlich von
Niklas Luhmann. Das gibt es jetzt gar nicht als Monografie.
Alle anderen Bücher gibt es ja als Monografie. also der Gesellschaft,
aber es gibt eben diesen Sammelband, die Moral der Gesellschaft mit einem sehr
großen, wahrscheinlich das halbe Buch, umspannenden Text zum Thema Achtung.
So, und jetzt hast du die ganze Systemtheorie, ne? Der Anspruch,
die universelle Theorie, die die Gesellschaft erklärt, einzelne Systeme,
Organisationen, Interaktionen, Funktionssysteme, die Wirtschaft, die Politik und so.
Und dann neben all dem die Achtung. Menschen begegnen sich und klären miteinander,
wie sie diesen kleinen sozialen ich weiß nicht, was du als nächstes machst,
du weißt nicht, was ich als nächstes mache, wir wissen es einfach nicht,
es entstehen halt so Sachen, wie man das miteinander aushandelt.
Und da lernt man, wie wenig Gesellschaft dabei eine Rolle spielt.
Geschichte, Gesellschaft, Regeln, Satzung, was auch immer. Sondern einfach nur
dieses, ja, die begegnen sich eben und dann werden Achtungsbedingungen ausverhandelt.
Nicht Ehre, nicht Ansehen, nicht Reputation, nicht Prominenz,
nichts was von irgendwo vererbt wird, sondern Menschen begegnen sich einfach
und dann wird geklärt, gehe ich jetzt nach rechts oder gehst du nach rechts
oder gehe ich links an dir vorbei oder wie auch immer so, ne?
So und dann wird alles ausgeblendet und ich glaube hier sind wir wieder da angekommen.
Also wenn man sich jetzt zum Thema 7. Oktober irgendwie verständigen möchte
auf dieser elementaren Ebene,
dann greift man am liebsten erstmal zu diesen Inhaltlich ganz neutralen,
aber strukturell allessagenden Soziologiebüchern,
in dem einfach Achtungsaushandlungsprozesse erklärt werden.
So und dann hört man bei Isda Perel nach, wie Menschen miteinander umgehen sollten.
Dann hat sie da ihren Podcast, Where Should We Begin, wo sie von Leuten...
Dort Botschaften auf ihren Anrufbeantworter bekommen, die ihr Beziehungsproblem
schildern. Dann sucht sie aus, wen sie zurückruft.
Dann reden die 20 Minuten drüber. Man lernt über Bande sozusagen das etwas abseitige,
nicht funktionierende, manchmal auch boshafte Kennen und so.
Und gewinnt darüber ein Verständnis dafür, wie es eigentlich funktioniert.
Und so einen Podcast zu hören, einen guten Beziehungspodcast zu hören,
ist wirklich sehr viel besser als irgendein Podcastgespräch politisch unsicheren
Leuten über Antisemitismus.
Das bringt einen jetzt wirklich gar nicht weiter.
Ich glaube aber wir müssen dennoch jetzt nochmal auf diese geopolitische Ebene
gehen, denn wir müssen ja darüber reden, was wird gemacht, was ist da eigentlich geplant.
Und ich will erstmal ein Clip da spielen zum Ukraine-Krieg,
nämlich gab es eine Konferenz, die Yalta European Strategy und dort hat von
der Bundeswehr Christian Freudig gesprochen,
das ist jetzt vier Wochen her, fünf Wochen her etwa, und der ist dort im Gespräch
mit Anne Applebaum, die ja auch da einen sehr harten Kurs fährt, also mehr Waffen etc.
Und wir hören uns jetzt mal da an, was dort für ein Szenario mal so ganz nebenbei ausgerollt wird.
Wird das, so lange es dauert, einen langen Krieg bedeuten?
Was, wenn es nicht eine 6-Monate-Krieg ist, sondern eine 2-Jahre-Krieg, eine 3-Jahre-Krieg?
Ich glaube nicht, dass jeder in diesem Saal erwartet, dass diese Krieg in den
nächsten 6 Monaten beendet wird. Natürlich wünscht jeder, dass es in den nächsten
6 Monaten beendet wird. Aber ich denke, ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel.
Wir bekommen die Unterstützung von unserem Parlament, die finanzielle Unterstützung
von unserem Parlament, die militärische Unterstützung von unseren ukrainischen
Freunden, bis zum Jahr 2032.
Ich denke, wir sind bereit und vorbereitet, eine langfristige Unterstützung
zu geben, eine langfristige Unterstützung zu geben, und wir sind bereit,
Zeit für unsere Parteien zu machen und nicht Zeit für die Parteien von Putin.
Jetzt haben wir das hier gehört, Unterstützung bis 2032.
Wir können jetzt noch acht Jahre weitermachen. Ich, weil du eben so sagst,
da werden vielleicht dann einige in drei Monaten auf ihre Tweets vom Oktober
noch mal skeptisch zurückblicken.
Ich befürchte, dass das so zu viel Selbstreflexion abverlangt.
Denn man könnte ja jetzt nach über 600 Tagen Krieg und einem nicht weiterkommen,
genauso wie es ausbuchstabiert wurde in dem besten nichts Neues in dem Netflix-Film,
könnte man ja vielleicht jetzt mal so langsam einen Diskurs haben,
bei dem man sagt, ja, also die da immer mal wieder Verhandlungen stark gemacht
haben als eine Möglichkeit, hatten möglicherweise nicht ganz Unrecht.
Also man könnte es ja alles sehr vorsichtig formulieren. Aber genau das findet
ja nicht statt. Und wir hören hier mal weiter, was die Vision ist.
Wir werden unsere Unterstützung fortsetzen. Wir werden unsere Unterstützung beschleunigen.
Wir werden unsere Unterstützung besser koordinieren, weil ich denke,
das ist einer der wichtigsten Dinge, nicht nur,
um zu überzeugen, was wir haben und was unsere Industrie produziert,
sondern wird es uns ermöglichen,
Kapazitätspakete, Training, Equipment, Sustenabilität der ukrainischen Armeen
zu geben, um die ukrainischen Armeen für die Siegertätigkeit zu vorbereiten.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass wir euch, mein Freund,
eure Vision der Siegertätigkeit teilen.
Vielen Dank. Deine Vision der Siegertätigkeit bedeutet, alle in der Ukraine
beteiligte Territorien zurückzunehmen.
Um die Territorialintegrität der Ukraine zu erneuern. Von den Grenzen von 1991.
Genau. Vielen Dank. Ich denke, damit beenden wir das.
Die uns auch 2014 FF so wichtig waren.
Ja, die sind uns jetzt so wichtig, dass wir jetzt 8 Jahre weiter Krieg führen
wollen. Also das ist so die Situation, in der wir uns befinden.
Ja, vor allem dieser Ukraine-Krieg.
Die UKW haben Tim Bridlaff und Pawel Maja auch nochmal ein Update gegeben.
Die reden ja dann immer drei Stunden darüber, was sie so im Internet finden.
Und es gibt dort jetzt Regionen, in denen man einfach so Bataillonsweise,
also wo einfach hunderte Fahrzeuge zerstört werden.
Und irgendwann meinte Pawel dann so, ja, in den letzten zehn Tagen sind fünf
Prozent aller Russen, die bislang im Krieg gestorben sind, gestorben.
Also während wir medial monothematisch natürlich dann nur mit Hamas und so beschäftigt
waren, fanden einfach unfassbare Massaker statt. Ohne jeden Grenzverlauf.
Also die Grenzen haben sich ja seit einem Jahr nicht mehr verschoben.
Das ist ja alles gleich, es ist nur noch Gemetzel.
Und da sind einfach 3000 russische Soldaten und eben die Ukrainer gehen wohl
ein bisschen effektiver in Anführungszeichen zu sein.
Da wird immer gesagt, ich befürchte die ukrainischen Opfer sind extrem hoch.
Ich meine an die Zahlen wäre ja ranzukommen, wenn man Interesse daran hätte.
Also das finde ich ja immer sehr merkwürdig, dass so gesagt wird,
ja die geben keine Zahlen bekannt, aber ich sage mal, da werden ja westliche
Geheimdienste schon Mittel und Wege kennen.
Ja, und das journalistische Interesse ist auch so negativ gerade,
dass es ja teilweise tagesschau.de Übersichten gibt, in denen die Ukraine nur
noch mit einem Text und dann auch nur noch im unteren Siebtachtel stattfindet.
Also muss man so weit scrollen, wie man nie scrollt.
Ja, und man kann sich ja vorstellen, wenn das bis 2032 geht,
da gibt es ja keine dauerhafte mediale Berichterstattung mehr.
Also klar, da wird immer ein Korrespondent was berichten und irgendwo wird man
was finden dazu, aber das ist dann nicht mehr ein großes Thema.
Und jetzt hören wir uns mal stattdessen an, was Yuval Noah Hari sagt jetzt zu
dem aktuellen Naus-Konflikt zum Thema Frieden.
Viele Menschen sprechen heute und in den letzten Jahren über die Leidenschaften
von Hunderten von Tausenden Palästinensern, die ihre Heimat in 1948 verloren haben.
Wenige Leute wissen, dass auch als Ergebnis der 1948er-Krieg Hunderttausende
Jüdinnen und Jüden ihre Heimat verloren haben, in der Rückkehr für die Krieg.
Jüdische Gemeinschaften überall im Mittelmeer, in arabischen Ländern,
in Ägypten, in Irak, in Yemen, in Syrien, die dort lebten, für hunderte,
manchmal tausende Jahre, und nichts
damit zu tun hatten, dass sie in der Kriegsschwelle geflüchtet wurden.
Hunderttausende Jüdinnen und Jüden, das größte Gruppe von Menschen,
die jetzt in Israel leben, sind Jüdinnen und Jüden, die als Flüchtlinge ausgewiesen
wurden, als Resultat der 1948-Kriegsschwelle.
Now, does this justify what happened to the Palestinians? No.
Does this justify the Israeli occupation and the mistreatment of Palestinians?
They're absolutely not. And we shouldn't use historical injuries to justify
more injuries. If you have to choose between justice and peace, choose peace.
Every peace treaty in the history of the world was based on compromise.
No, we need some level of justice, of course, Aber es gibt nie die Möglichkeit
der absoluten Gerechtigkeit.
Wenn man die absolute Gerechtigkeit folgt, wird man nur unbeendet Krieg verursachen.
Erstaunlich, ne?
Schwere Gröte, wenn dann auf der Bühne nochmal abverlangt wird zu sagen, also die Grenzen von 91.
Ja, da die Grenzen von 91 und hier sagt jemand ja der Kompromiss muss her und
nicht ohne Gerechtigkeit, aber Gerechtigkeit muss sein.
Da kann man ja nochmal Olaf Scholz loben dafür, dass er immer,
also die ganze Kriegsdefinition, warum ist das schlimm, was Putin macht?
Wegen der Grenzläufe, wegen der Grenzziehung. Wir verschieben keine Grenzen mehr.
Und das geht sehr, sozusagen die praktische Intelligenzseite von dieser HMG-Anmerkung.
Geht in diese Richtung. Und ich will aber auch zugeben, dass das ja jetzt in
dem Nauskonflikt deutlich schwieriger ist.
Und der Schneider schreibt hier in den Blättern, ich empfehle diesen Aufsatz wirklich sehr.
Welche Option hat Israel in dieser fatalen Situation? Es ist klar,
dass Israel den üblichen Krieg mit der Hamas nicht mehr führen kann.
Seit 2008 sahen alle Operationen mehr oder weniger gleich aus.
Sie begannen damit, dass die Islamisten Raketen auf Israel regnen ließen,
Israel bombardierte daraufhin Gaza.
Auf palästinensischer Seite gab es viele Tote, auf israelischer Seite nur sehr
wenige. Und irgendwann signalisierten beide Seiten, vor allem die Hamas, dass es nun genug sei.
Dann wurde verhandelt, die Kämpfe hörten auf und danach war alles wie zuvor.
Hunderte Menschen waren gestorben, für nichts. Und Gaza war noch ein bisschen
mehr zerstört als vorher schon.
Weder politisch noch militärisch, hatte eine Partei wirklich etwas erreicht.
Es waren, wenn man es salopp sagen will, bloße Punktsiege.
Gleichzeitig wussten beide Seiten, dass am letzten Tag des Krieges bereits der
nächste vorbereitet wird. Ein zynisches Ping-Pong-Spiel ohne Aussicht auf ein
Ende. Und das, also mir ist ja auch...
Mir ist überhaupt nicht klar, ich habe so viel, weil du sagtest ja eben auch
zurecht, wir können jetzt nicht hier sitzen und in dem aktuellen Konflikt auch
noch sagen, wir wollen mal noch generell den Nahostkonflikt lösen.
Aber ist es wirklich so schlimm, wie groß dieses Dilemma ist?
Und Schneider sagt dann auch noch, dass man auch gar nicht sagen kann,
was ist denn überhaupt das Kriegsziel Israels?
Also auch da ist er sich unsicher. Er sagt ganz gewiss, die massive Schwächung
der Hamas, neben dem Ausschalten ihrer Führung auch die Zerstörung ihrer Waffendepots
und ihrer Infrastruktur, doch was wäre mit einem so massiven Krieg gewonnen?
Gaza würde ins Chaos abgleiten, andere, vielleicht noch radikalere Gruppen,
wie der islamische Dschihad, würden die Macht übernehmen.
Nach einiger Zeit wäre alles wieder aufgebaut, zumindest der Kampf gegen Israel
könnte wieder aufgenommen werden.
Im israelischen Fernsehen erklärten Jüngst Militärs, dass sie auch eine Wiederbesetzung
Gazas nicht ausschließen.
Das sind starke Worte, doch sie besagen nicht viel, denn eine Besetzung Gazas
inklusive der Verantwortung für die Palästinenser würde Israel sehr viel kosten.
Also es ist völlig verfahren. Also eigentlich muss man sagen,
ja wir gucken da rauf, aber ja.
Aber es findet halt trotzdem statt. Und das hören wir uns auch mal ein paar
Clips an. Ich fand das ja doch sehr interessant.
Zum einen, also Friedensbemühungen gerade ruhen auf allen Seiten.
Wie hier im Politik-Podcast von Deutschlandfunk von Jan-Christian Kitzel auch reportiert wird.
Es gibt Leute, die Friedensinitiativen machen, auch auf palästinensischer Seite,
die haben natürlich jetzt ganz schlechte Karten und das ist eigentlich das Tragische,
dass das, was man da eigentlich gedacht hat, man könnte das stärken und man
könnte das ausbauen und das auch auf israelischer Seite.
Dass man sich aufeinander zubewegt und dass man sich Gedanken macht,
wie können eigentlich Israelis und Palästinenser zusammenleben?
Dass die jetzt natürlich echt keine guten Argumente haben in dieser Situation.
Und wir haben natürlich jetzt auch politische Verhältnisse in Israel,
wo Nationalreligiöse an der Regierung sind, die ganz offen sagen,
natürlich haben Palästinenser weniger Rechte als Juden.
Die das machen, was Menschenrechtsorganisationen jetzt Apartheid nennen.
Ich weiß, ich mache mir den Begriff nicht zu eigen, das ist etwas, was diskutiert wird.
Aber wenn man natürlich im Westjordanland ist und sieht, wie Palästinenser dort
auch unter der Besatzungssituation leiden und wenn dann ein Minister wie Ben
Gwir sagt, natürlich habe ich hier mehr Rechte unterwegs zu sein,
als die Palästinenser, die hier wohnen.
Das ist ja die Lebenswirklichkeit dieser Extremisten,
auch auf israelischer Seite und die haben natürlich jetzt wirklich durch das,
was passiert ist, alle Karten für sich und das ist wirklich tragisch für alles,
was man sich vielleicht an Perspektiven hätte überlegen können.
Das ist jetzt erst mal in ganz weiter Ferne gerückt und das finde ich,
das ist keine journalistische, analytische Kategorie, aber ich finde das sehr tragisch.
So, okay, es ist tragisch. Ich fand das wirklich erstaunlich,
wenn man dann so diese Podcasts hört. Man ist ja nun wirklich,
man kommt ja von diesem Harald-Schmidt-Niveau, im Grunde keine Ahnung,
würde es auch auf einer Karte nicht finden.
Katapult hat jetzt mal gezeigt, Israel, wie groß wäre es, wenn man es in Deutschland
platziert und dann der Gaza-Streifen, Also man hat so den kleinen Staat und
dann halt so Israel, keine Ahnung, so von der Länge wie Nordrhein-Westfalen oder so.
Also es ist jetzt nichts, wo man so denkt, das muss man aber unbedingt finden
auf so einer Weltkarte und so.
Und wie es dort zur Sache geht, also einen sowieso schon.
Weil jeder muss Männer wie Frauen einmal dort dienen.
Tim Brittloff hat das mal wie folgt hier in UKW 115 beschrieben.
Wir sollten erstmal noch beschreiben was schon passiert ist.
Was ja auch noch passiert ist, ist die Mobilisierung der Reservisten.
Israel hat so eine Standing Army von ungefähr 160.000 Soldaten,
die permanent im Einsatz sind.
Und man muss wissen, jeder Israeli war bei der Armee.
Also sicherlich gibt es ein paar Ausnahmen, aber im Kern jeder Mann,
jede Frau in Israel war bei der IDF und das Reservistenheer ist dementsprechend sehr, sehr, sehr groß.
Es wurden jetzt ungefähr 300.000 Israelis aus der Reserve mobilisiert.
So, also jeder junge Israeli war mal beim Militär und jetzt kriegen wir das
kurz kontextualisiert von Richard Schneider, der in diesem Spiegel-Podcast 8 Milliarden zu Gast war.
Ah ja. Warum sind sie nämlich nicht vorlöst?
Also wir haben sozusagen die Orthodoxen und so weiter, die ja da so befreit
werden teilweise oder keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Also das ist schon mal eine Einschränkung zu dem jeder. Und dann gibt es auch
noch andere Gründe, warum man nicht Vollzeit oder wie auch immer beim Militär ist.
Wenn man sich die Politik und das Militär Israels in den vielen,
vielen Jahren anschaut und sehr genau beobachtet, so sind die Militärs meistens
sehr viel vernünftiger als die Politiker.
Das ist der große Vorteil. Die sind nicht fürs Draufhauen unmittelbar,
sondern sind auch besorgt um die eigene Truppe.
Das ist ja wie hier, das war doch auch immer unsere Erkenntnis aus dem Ukraine
Krieg, die Militärs viel ruhiger, besonnener als die Politiker.
Ja, es gibt ja auch diesen Film mit Bruce Willis, Siege oder so,
wo er als General umrennt und den Politikern immer warnt. Ja.
Aktiviert nicht mich als Militär. Versucht das mal noch politisch zu machen.
Aktiviert mich nicht, aktiviert mich nicht. Dann sagen sie, nee,
wir brauchen diese militärische Lösung und dann kann er halt nicht anders.
Und dann muss er da quasi in den Stadien Konstellationslager einrichten für
die Muslime und so, um dann irgendwie den 11. September zu verhindern.
Aber auch immer diese Warnung. Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Vorsicht und so.
Naja, also wir haben sehr viel vernünftigere Militärs als Politiker.
Was ist denn mit dieser Politikerie da in Israel?
Um die frage was ist wirklich machbar und wie macht man
es das ist auf alle fälle besser als
wenn rechtsextremisten oder die
ultra orthodoxen minister die alle nie in der armee waren
übrigens die beiden rechtsextremisten das ist ja auch noch der witz etama benguere
der nationaler sicherheitsminister ist der war schon als 18 jähriger so rechtsextremistisch
dass die armee gesagt hat den wollen wir nicht der hat nicht einen tag das doch
wirklich gedient und bezahlt Als Smotrych,
der Finanzminister, ebenfalls ein radikaler Siedler, der war gerade mal ein
paar Monate in der Armee und das war's.
Also unabhängig von ihrer politischen Haltung haben sie auch keinerlei militärische
Erfahrung, die Ultraorthodoxen auch nicht und so ist das jetzt erst einmal für diesen Krieg.
Auch insofern so zynisch das
klingen mag, das ist selbst für die palästinensische Bevölkerung in Gaza,
die natürlich jetzt ohne Ende
leiden wird, ist das ein gewisser weil die Militärs werden sich überlegen,
was ist sinnvoll mit Rechtsextremen und anderen, die wollen ja nur draufhauen und alles platt machen.
Die Aussage von Smodric zu, dass er einfach alles niederwalzen wollte,
richtig? Genau, ganz genau. Also das ist unabhängig, dass das ein politisches
Unding ist, aber das ist auch keine Strategie.
Das geht gar nicht. Das wäre ja völlig wahnsinnig.
So und ich will es mal spekulativ ausspuchtabieren.
Die Militärs in Israel unterscheiden, also gucken sich genau an,
wen sie da mustern, um zu sehen und einfach zu unterscheiden,
Mit diesen Menschen können wir Israel verteidigen.
Wenn wir diesen Menschen zu uns in die Truppe holen, schlägt er so krass auf
die Palästinenser ein, bei jeder Gelegenheit, die sich findet,
dass das nur zu mehr Unsicherheit führt.
Und unter diesen Gesichtspunkten wurden die damals aussortiert.
Also das ist ein Ausmaß an Trumpesker Politik,
wo dann Journalisten nochmal beim Dings anrufen und fragen,
Wie verhindern sie jetzt, wenn der Atomwaffenbefehl kommt und der dann erklärt,
ja dann trete ich zurück und dann kommt der nächste und der dritte dann auch
zurück und dann verschaffen wir uns erstmal einen Tag, in dem wir alle zurücktreten
und sowas. Wie das ja damals beschrieben wurde.
Ja, das Militär will ja versuchen die Bevölkerung zu schützen vor etwas,
die haben ja keine anderen Ansinnen, während die Politik Macht haben will,
also eine andere Ebene und da ist jedes Mittel recht und Netanjau ist nun wirklich
jemand, der da mit allen Wassern gewaschen ist und das ist ja das Schlimme,
also was ja auch jetzt so deutlich wird, dass Juden.
Schutzraum Israel haben. Also Antisemitismus ist ein globales Phänomen,
wie wir überall sehen und erleben.
Und dann ist ja die Idee von Israel, dass man einen jüdischen Raum,
ein Land hat, das für Juden ein Schutzraum ist.
Und wenn jetzt aber eine Regierung derart stümperhaft vorgeht und da so viele
sind, die überhaupt gar keine Ahnung vom Militär haben und das Militär ja auch
gewarnt hat vor dieser Gesetzesreform.
Also da man sagte, Da wird auch Tür und Tor geöffnet für dies und das.
Da werden möglich Sicherheitslücken entstehen.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht da ist, wenn das Land plötzlich nicht mehr dieser Schutzraum
ist, für das dieses Land ja gegründet wurde, dann ist das wirklich eine extrem bedrohliche Lage.
Und ja, ganz schlimm, weil zugleich ja auch diese ganzen anderen Räume plötzlich prekär werden.
Also siehe dann, dass hier auch die Polizei erhöht erhöht vor Synagogen stehen
muss oder dass man jetzt auch Berichte im Fernsehen sah darüber,
dass Eltern die Kinder nicht in eine jüdische Schule oder in den Kindergarten
gerade bringen, weil sie Angst haben.
Also das ist echt eine ganz ganz schlimme Situation und zugleich sieht man ja
auch dann anhand dieser Proteste der letzten Monate in Israel,
wie plural die Gesellschaft ja eigentlich auch ist, weshalb man ja auch immer
da dann diese Unterscheidung machen kann Und muss, die wir hier sowieso immer
stark machen, der Bürger ist nicht die Regierung.
Und diese Trennung muss man auch wieder hier ganz stark machen,
genauso wie auch Palästinenser nicht die Hamas sind.
Aber führt dann doch zu einer erheblichen Mobilisierung in den Köpfen.
Sag ich mal, Frank Capellan hier mit einer Beobachtung, die er als Teil einer...
Diese Delegation, ich weiß gar nicht wen sie da begleitet haben,
Baerbock, Scholz, die waren ja jetzt alle kürzlich da. Wie sind die jungen Leute
jetzt in Israel aufgestellt?
Sebastian, vielleicht darf ich das abschließend noch erzählen, was du gesagt hast.
Wie sehr die Israelis jetzt auch eine starke Bodenoffensive wollen,
ja, das habe ich auch erlebt.
Das war auch beeindruckend, als wir im israelischen Verteidigungsministerium
waren Und wie viele sehr,
sehr junge Leute wir da gesehen, die sich freiwillig als Reservisten gemeldet haben,
die auch durchaus fröhlich, sage ich jetzt einfach so,
da durch die Lande gezogen sind und die eine gewisse Euphorie mitgebracht haben,
jetzt in den Krieg gegen die Hamas zu gehen, ist für uns alles befremdlich,
für Deutsche, denke ich mal, das so zu erleben. Aber diese Stimmung ist da.
A. Interessant, weil ich einen Artikel las, weiß aber jetzt gerade nicht welche
Zeitung, dass offenbar Reservisten aus dem Ausland ein bisschen Skepsis zeigen,
weil sie eigentlich nicht für diese Netanjau-Regierung was machen wollen. B.
Ist natürlich so ein punktueller Einblick, man sieht dann so ein Musterungszentrum
oder so und dann sind da 80 Leute und dann… A.
Schon vorstellbar, ja. B.
…dann so eine Vorstellung, dass es in die Richtung geht. In Deutschland ist
natürlich dann so, Sendungseröffnung Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag beispielhaft am 16.10.
Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag. Mit Philipp May, schönen guten Abend.
Wann beginnt die Bodenoffensive der israelischen Armee im Gaza-Streifen nach
dem Terrorangriff der Hamas? Es ist ein banges Warten. Morgen kommt Kanzler
Olaf Scholz zum Solidaritätsbesuch nach Israel.
Gleich mehr zur Lage im Nahost.
So, jetzt habe ich ja vorhin Anmerkungen gemacht zum Thema Semantik und Struktur.
Also wenn die jetzt zehn Tage lang hintereinander einfach zur Länderselbstverwaltung
fragen, Wann kommt die Bodenoffensive der Hamas in Gaza, der Israelis in Gaza, gegen die Hamas?
Ja, dann ist klar, dass wir irgendwann darauf geprimed sind und dann alle nur
noch darauf warten. Und wenn es dann ist, ja, uns dann.
Korridor, der uns vorher aufgemacht wurde, kognitiv Gedanken dazu machen.
Dankenswerterweise gibt es ja dann Podcasts wie UKW, die da so ein bisschen,
wie soll man sagen, reinreflektieren.
Was bedeutet es eigentlich jetzt? Die Bodenoffensive gegen die Hamas und so.
In dieser UKW 115 Ausgabe, in der die beiden da mal drüber sprachen,
wurden die Kalküle auch noch mal genannt.
Keine Ahnung wie, aber irgendwie Daten sickern trotzdem dort raus.
Starlink-Antennen und so. Also ich meine Satellitennetz gibt es natürlich auch.
Ja und selbst wenn sie dann was weiß ich USB-Sticks oder Handys durch die Tunnel
nach draußen schicken, also die Bilder werden von Grausamkeiten, werden da rauskommen.
So hier geht es um die Frage, wenn die Israelis in Gaza das Internet ausschalten,
heißt das dann, dass das Anliegen der Hamas, nämlich so viele Bilder wie möglich,
wie jüdisch, israelisch und so weiter, Soldaten, wie das dann da geframed wird,
Palästinenser abschlachten, töten und so, also diese Bilder zu produzieren.
Da meinten die schon mal, ja das sind ja nun die Leute, die sich damit auskennen,
ne, nur weil es da kein Internet gibt, heißt das noch nicht,
dass da niemand mit technischem Gerät und vollem Akku sozusagen parat steht,
um dieses Dokument dann anzufertigen.
Sich heutzutage einfach nicht unterbinden und damit rechnet eben auch Hamas,
sodass sie die Zivilbevölkerung nicht wirklich schützen wollen,
sondern eigentlich so viele tote Zivilisten wie möglich in kurzer Zeit sehen wollen.
Und dieses Anliegen der Hamas, das wir ja schon sehen, also von 30.000 Menschen,
die einen Post bei Telegram sehen, plötzlich 500.000 oder möglichst 5 Millionen,
also dafür werden die die Palästinenser einfach opfern, die da leben. Ja.
Und umso mehr die Israelis da mitmachen, wir kommen jetzt gleich auf Heusgen
zu sprechen, ich will es schon mal ankündigen, es ist ja sehr kontrovers gewesen,
die letzten Tage in Deutschland, ob man jetzt Heusgen auch noch zuhören darf.
Sieht man auch schon wie irre alles geworden ist, dass der Chef der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz,
die so als die Veranstaltung für NATO und transatlantische Freunde in der Regel angesehen wird,
ja und weshalb dort ja dann immer Friedensdemonstranten und alles sind,
dass also jetzt dieser Heusken von Volker Beck als eingefleischter Israelhasser
bezeichnet wird bei Twitter,
dass man da jetzt eine Diskussion hat, so als sei, wir haben ja auch das Buch
von Heusken gelesen, als sei er irgendwie da ja schon bekannt, wo man irgendwie da, ne.
Ich meine, Angela Merkels Diktum von der deutschen Staatsräson.
Der Zeit, als Häuschen ihr Referat selbst aus Politik geleitet hat.
Also er ist der Autor, der Urheber dieses ganzen Bildes.
Es ist völlig irre, wie man als Volker Beck, der sich eigentlich auskennt,
der müsste ja wissen als ehemaliger Parlamentarier, wieso die Zusammenhänge
sind, wer wo gearbeitet hat und wer verantwortlich ist.
Ist doch vorstellbar, das ist ein eingefleischter Israel-Feind.
Also das ist ja so, was ja nicht heißt, dass man nicht einzelne Aussagen wegen
mir kritisieren Aber das ist einfach, da zeigt man, man will nicht argumentieren.
Man will nicht über wahre und falsche Argumente diskutieren.
Sondern man möchte einfach nur den Meinungskorridor möglichst eng machen.
Sodass man nur noch für den Tribalismus orientiert ist und sonst gar nichts.
Dein Tribalismus, mein Tribalismus und dann lassen wir es auf der Straße krachen, wenn sie uns begegnen.
Und jetzt hier, Pavel, Sie spekulieren einfach, wie wir es uns auch nicht trauen.
Aber die beiden haben jetzt so viele Podcasts auch über die Ukraine und so gemacht.
Was würde es nun einfach mal bedeuten, wenn Israel in Gaza so richtig einmarschiert?
Also nicht so peu a peu und dann ist da mal eine Aktion und da.
Sondern wenn man so richtig sagt, wir wollen jetzt Häuser straßenweise besetzen.
Bei einer Aktion dieser Art rechnet man mit 6% Verwundeten oder Getöteten pro Tag.
Also sechs Prozent Casualties, Verluste, wie es so schön heißt.
Und davon vielleicht so ein, zwei Prozent ungefähr tatsächlich Getötete.
Das heißt, jeder Tag wird auch für Israel, also dieser Vormarsch,
dann tatsächlich schmerzhaft sein.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie gesagt, dann kommen die Bilder. Und dann ist die
Frage, wie lange wird die Welt zuschauen?
Und da zu Schätzungen, naja, so 14 Tage.
Wenn dieser Vormarsch läuft, dann dass dann der öffentliche Druck auf Israel
zu stark werden wird, weil die Bilder einfach zu unerträglich werden.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Erwartungshaltung von Profis, sag ich mal,
dass das irgendwie so läuft, oder?
Ja, Schneider hatte ja im Piraten-Sender Powerplay auch gesagt,
dass er sich vorstellen können, dass man zunächst einmal vielleicht von israelischer
Seite ein paar Opfer israelische Soldaten mehr in Kauf nimmt.
Aber dass das auch für ihn eigentlich so eine interessante Sache sein wie viele
tote israelische Soldaten sind eigentlich der Gesellschaft der Israelischen zuzumuten.
Also das war jetzt so auf die globale Ebene wie lange kann man das akzeptieren.
Aber auch noch mal so wie die israelische Gesellschaft auf ihre eigenen toten
Soldaten blickt und Und das ist, glaube ich, schon etwas, was jetzt gerade im
Kopf der Netanjahu-Regierung ist.
Möglicherweise verlieren wir dann ganz den Rückhalt.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur eine Frage, wie sieht es medial aus,
sondern auch, was bedeutet das materiell. Und es ist ja, ich fand es auch schon
so ein bisschen, es ist Pavel selbst nicht aufgefallen, aber man kann ja die
Mathematik, die jetzt da drin steckt, mal durchgehen.
Also man stellt sich vor, da ist jetzt so eine Hundertschaft,
in dem Fall wirklich mal 100 israelische Soldaten, die in den Gaza-Streifen gehen.
Die Blutdrahte von sechs pro Tag, hat er ja gemacht. Sechs Prozent pro Tag verwundet oder verletzt.
So, und 14 Tage hält man das durch. 14 mal sechs sind 84.
Also von den 100 blieben nach den 14 Tagen, wo es auch medial für die Welt nicht
mehr erträglich ist, bleiben 16 Soldaten übrig von 100.
Das ist so die Kalkulation, die, würde ich jetzt auch vermuten,
auf die ein oder andere Weise schon da durchkalkuliert wird.
Auch mit den Amerikanern und so weiter. Und wir haben jetzt gehört,
wie radikal die israelische Regierung ist und wie gerne die da einfach und dass
sie zum Glück da gebremst wird, wie Richard Schneider sagt.
Das muss man ja dann auch erstmal für den Fall, dass man jetzt hier wieder,
ist das jetzt Antisemitismus und so?
Nee, der Richard Schneider, der sich da wirklich auskennt und den wir gerade
alle sehr schätzen als Kommentator, hat uns gesagt, die sind so radikal,
die würden da sofort einmarschieren.
Und dann sitzen wahrscheinlich die Militärs daneben und sagen,
wir haben eine Verlustrate von 6 Prozent pro Tag. Was heißt bei 100 Leuten und
nach 14 Tagen müssten wir uns dann, müssten Sie sich auch, also nach 14 Tagen
spätestens fällt das auf Sie politisch zurück.
Ja und dann sage ich Ihnen auch, da kommen unsere Reservisten aus dem Ausland
auf keinen Fall mehr, wenn wir mal diese Zahlen haben.
Genau und die kommen dann nicht und wir haben 84 volle Serke für 100 Soldaten,
die Sie heute da reinschicken. Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Und das ist auch die Antwort auf die Frage im Deutschlandfunk,
die einfach salopp zur Sendungseröffnung, wo so floskelhaft schon,
alle Welt wartet auf den Einmarsch in Gaza und denkt, kann schon durchaus sein,
aber man kann gleich mal ein bisschen ernsthafter damit reinsteigen.
Also diese Gewalt, noch steht sie auf dem Papier.
Ja schon sehr viel Gewalt da auch ist. Also sehr viel Opfer in Gaza.
Wir sind jetzt hier an einem Montag. Man weiß nicht genau die Zahlen.
Man spricht von etwa 7000 toten Palästinensern in Gaza.
Es ist die Rede von etwa 1400, 1500 Kindern.
Die genauen Zahlen haben wir nicht schwer nachvollziehbar, aber wir können uns
sagen so roundabout wird es sein.
Wir koppeln mal so ein paar Clips zusammen, der eine ist sehr lang, 2 Minuten 43,
die New York Times hat im The Daily Podcast einfach in Gaza angerufen,
bei Menschen, die man da kennt, die ja auch für die New York Times,
die ja nun sehr darauf achtet, wer kriegt denn hier die Plattform New York Times zur Verfügung und so,
also die reden hier mit jemanden, den sie wirklich für ernst zu nehmen,
zurechnungsfähig und aussagekräftig halten und reportieren es dann aber eins
zu eins, also sie spielen einfach das Telefon Hallo.
Hi, ist das Abdallah? Ja. Hi Abdallah, mein,
Name ist Sabrina Tavernissi, ich spreche mit einem Abdallah und...
Also sie rufen da an?
Ja, die rufen direkt in Gaza an und verwickeln die dann so in Gespräche und
hier haben sie so ein Gespräch.
Was denkst du über Hamas, Abdallah? Was es ist, was es tut? was es ist, was es tut.
Ich bin nicht Hamas und ich war nie ein großer Fan von Hamas.
Wir beide sind anders in der Ideologie.
Aber was hier passiert, ist überhaupt nicht um Hamas. Worum geht es?
Es geht um die ethnische Entschädigung der palästinensischen Menschen.
Es geht um 2,3 Millionen palästinensische Menschen.
Das ist der Grund, warum Israel das erste, was es tat, Wasser und Elektrizität und Essen zu schneiden.
Es geht also nicht nur um Hamas, sondern auch um unsere Gesellschaft.
Ich möchte, dass ihr euch morgen wieder anrufen könnt. Ich möchte euch in Kontakt
halten und sicher sein, dass ihr okay seid.
Und wenn ihr könnt, schickt mir eine Stimme-Memo, okay? Wenn ihr etwas hört
am Abend, schickt mir eine Stimme-Memo. Okay.
Wir beginnen mit breitenden Nachrichten über die Israel-Gaza-Welt.
Wir beginnen mit breiten Nachrichten über den Israel-Gaza-Krieg.
Letzte Nacht hat Israel mehr als ein Million Palästinenser in Norden Gaza erzählt,
um nach Süden zu fliehen, das zeigt, dass ein Grundversuch wahrscheinlich kommt.
Und selbst wenn diese Leute nach Süden fliehen können, gibt es aktuell keinen
Weg aus Gaza, weil die Grenzübergang in Ägypten blockiert ist.
Die Befehle, den Norden und den Süden von Gaza zu evakuieren,
sind einfach verrückt und es muss ein Witz sein, weil Israel mehr Palästinenser
aus ihren Häusern in 24 Stunden aus dem ganzen Nakba von 1948 auswählen will.
Du redest über mehr als 1,1 Mio.
Palästinensische Menschen, die wieder in einem Tag, in 24 Stunden,
ausgeliefert werden müssen?
Das hat mich auch aufgeregt, dass jemand wie Norbert Röttgen dann einfach sagte,
ja, warum macht denn Ägypten nicht die Grenze auf? Die können die doch alle aufnehmen.
Wo wir zugleich von seiner Partei und von der Ampelkoalition eine Antiflüchtlingspolitik
hat, die seinesgleichen sucht.
Die wollen auch keine Hamas-Camper auf ihrem Boden haben. Ja,
es ist ja nicht so, dass dann nur, gut, man könnte sagen, wir lassen jetzt nur
die Kinder rein oder was soll das sein.
Und wir, die uns jetzt nur noch abschotten und nur noch sagen,
jetzt muss aber mehr abgeschoben werden und so. Also wir sind ja jetzt schon
fast an dem Punkt, Wir hatten das bei Krah gehört, der der sagt,
ja, wir dürfen auch nicht mehr vor dem Begriff Remigration zurückschrecken.
Ja, wenn ich glaube, wenn wir noch zwei, drei Monate warten,
kommt das auch noch aus den bürgerlichen Wagern dann auch bald,
dass wir das thematisieren.
Und dann will man aber von Ägypten das fordern. Also das ist ja völlig klar,
das muss man auch hier unterstreichen.
Für die umliegenden Länder ist die palästinensische Bevölkerung auch nur Spielball.
Die interessieren sich ja leider auch nicht für die. Also das ist jetzt ja nicht
so, dass man sagen kann, ja Israel, aber die anderen Länder sind auch leider
nicht daran interessiert.
Und es ist ein ganz, ganz großes, auch humanitäres Versagen,
das da stattfindet. Und das ist gut, dass das eingefangen wird hier. Genau.
Also während wir vermuten, dass die israelische Regierung zögert,
weil die Militärs einfach sagen, zu viele tote Israelis, sehen wir ja,
dass die Bombardierung Gazas stattfindet und zwar mit diesen Folgen.
Was eben auch bedeutet mit diesen Folgen, das war jetzt ein 2 Minuten 43 Sekunden
langer Clip aus einem halbstundelangen Podcast, der millionenfach in die Welt
ausgeliefert wurde, von dem wir jetzt sagen,
Aber unter der Maxime, wie Omri Böhm das sagte, so ein Perspektivwechsel mal
versucht, dass es noch ein anderes Lager gibt, nicht nur Lager A.
So, und wir können uns ja jetzt ungefähr vorstellen, wie die Berichterstattung
über dieses Thema dort stattfindet,
wo man nicht die ganze Zeit Team A noch mit Kritik reinhämmern sieht,
sondern die bewusst Version B hören wollen von diesem Bericht.
Und hier wird schon von ethnischer Säuberung gesprochen, Von das einzige,
was ich mir vorwerfen ist, als Palästinenser geboren worden zu sein.
Dafür kann ich ja gar nichts.
Und so. Und es hat nichts mit Hamas zu tun. Also.
Ja, da ist der Diskurs schon völlig anderer. Da muss man fragen,
wie man das auch nochmal auf eine gemeinsame Grundlage bekommt. Ja.
Und auch in Deutschland. Deswegen vorhin meine Bemerkung.
Weil ich würde, also wir würden jetzt nicht von der ethnischen Säuberung sprechen.
Aber hier aus dieser Perspektive, Ihnen scheint das völlig klar zu sein,
dass es so ist. Weil es auch dann fühlbar ist natürlich in einer Weise,
dass er sagt, ja wie soll das auch, wie sollen wir hier überleben.
Genau, wenn wir jetzt in Deutschland darüber reden, ist das Beobachter Ebene
2. Was wir jetzt hier bekommen haben, ist Beobachter Ebene 1.
Da lohnt es sich gar nicht, dem zu widersprechen oder sonstiges,
sondern er hat das so gesagt. Er fühlt das so, er ist dort nicht der Einzige.
Wie wir das kommentieren, ist egal. Ja, das sind ja auch diese ganzen Begrifflichkeiten.
Also jetzt wird da jeden Tag bei Twitter gerungen, welcher Begriff und so weiter.
Dann denkt euch schnell einen anderen aus.
Aber lasst uns doch mal über Fakten und Grundlagen sprechen. Genau.
Und Fakten sind ja dann besonders hart, wenn sie, wie wir wissen,
in Zahlen ermessen werden.
Und das ist wirklich interessant, denn hier am 16.10. in Micky Beisenherz Podcast
mit seiner Frau zusammen, also
wir kriegen jetzt ein Angebot aus dem neuen inneren Mainstream sozusagen.
Es ist ja interessant, dass deutsche Journalisten, die Zeitungen herstellen,
heute die junge Garde bei sich im Haus haben und die dann fragen,
wie konsumiert ihr so die Nachrichten? Dann sagen die, wir hören Podcasts.
Also wir sind hier auf Heute-Journal-Niveau, der Samstagabend-Unterhaltung und wie auch immer.
Das ist, Micky Beisner, das ist der neue Thomas Gottschalk, er macht sich immer
lustig darüber, aber genau so ist das ja zu verstehen. Und selbst da?
Jetzt schon nicht darum hin, diese Zahlen einfach mal zu nennen,
weil sie so erschütternd sind. Und ich will noch mal anmerken,
ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt, so in drei Monaten denkt jeder noch mal anders.
Auch wenn man heute so und so über die Luftangriffe auf Gaza redet,
man denkt, glaube ich, in drei Monaten noch mal anders, wenn das so ins Land geht.
Zumindest im Stillen dann, ja.
Wahrscheinlich, genau. Im Stillen auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen.
Man kommt nicht darum hin, weil immer heute schon der Ton so ist.
Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, dass diese moralische Hoheit,
die geht verloren und man sieht, 500 Kinder im Gazastreifen sind jetzt tot und
die Bilder, ich sehe dann wirklich keine Chance mehr auf Frieden,
ich sehe sie jetzt schon dahinschwinden.
Aber auch noch einmal, Nebel des Kriegs. Du weißt nicht, in welches Territorium du da eintrittst.
Die Tunnel, die Verstecke, die Fallen.
Ich sehe da wirklich nur Verlierer auf beiden Seiten.
Und zwar in Zahlenermessen. Also 500 tote Kinder.
Sollen wir mal zum Heuskind springen?
Wollen wir diesen einen Muriel Asseburg-Clip noch spielen? Ja,
was war das? Moritz Asseburg war als Gesprächspartnerin Deutschlandfunk,
das war der Tag, wo so ein Interview noch mal eingeflochten wird.
Da war sie zu Gast. Wir wissen ja jetzt aus diesem ARD-Manual,
was sie sich intern haben schreiben lassen, weil sie ihren eigenen Subredaktionen
nicht vertrauen, dass sie als nicht sehr ausbalancierte Gesprächspartnerin gilt.
Ich würde aber trotzdem sagen, das klingt mir hier schon nach einer relevanten
Anmerkung, die sie macht.
Die sie macht, denn angenommen die Israelis, also die israelische Regierung
und die Militär und die politische Elite sitzt jetzt da und entscheidet sich
gegen den flächendeckenden Einmarsch in Gaza wegen der hohen Verlustzahl und so weiter.
Geht denn damit das Ziel dann verloren oder aus den Augen die Hamas vernichten
zu schlagen? Und dazu macht sie folgende Anmerkung.
Lass mich gerade das mal ganz kurz einhacken, weil es dieses Paper da gab,
wo so an irgendwelche Experten so dran geschrieben wird, Achtung ist vielleicht
nicht ausgeglichen oder so und so und irgendwelche Framings,
die da vorgeschlagen werden.
Wir hatten hier unseren Altbundespräsidenten Gauck und haben nur mal als Frage
den Raum gestellt, ist das nicht gerade der größte Populist und haben diese
Frage zur Beantwortung unserem Publikum gegeben.
Dieser Altbundespräsident wird
jetzt wieder befragt hier zum Thema Völkerrecht, Israel und so weiter.
Ich würde da auch mal empfehlen, auf diese ganzen Adressbücher,
die man so hat, bei Gauck mal so hinter zu schreiben.
Achtung, wurde die Frage gestellt, ob er populistisch argumentiere.
Also wirklich nur mal hier.
Also wer alles jetzt im Verahnsinn aufgetreten ist in den letzten Wochen.
Ich könnte ja eigentlich für einen Fernsehpodcast mal ein Gegenmanual schreiben.
Für die Zuschauerschaft.
Also nichts internen Gebrauch, sondern explizit extern gewünschter Gebrauch.
Und dann gehen wir die ganzen Moderatoren mal durch und schreiben mal so einen Wikipedia-Absatz.
Also hier, Moghul Asseburg, sie durfte zumindest im Radio, das ist ja interessant,
in der SWR Forum wird sie natürlich eingeladen, das war der Tag im Deutschlandfunk.
Wir stellen das ja hier seit Beginn dieses Podcast fest, im Radio ist eine Pluralität,
die nicht mal ansatzweise im Fernsehen zu finden ist.
Ganz genau.
Ich möchte vielleicht noch mal was klarstellen, weil das, vielleicht habe ich
mich nicht ganz klar ausgedrückt. Also ich bin in der Tat sehr pessimistisch,
was eine konkrete Deeskalation in Gaza angeht und was ein Abblasen der israelischen
Militäroffensive angeht.
Ich bin mittlerweile mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, ob es tatsächlich zu einer
umfassenden Bodenoffensive kommen wird.
Bislang hätte ich immer gesagt, Israel braucht diese Bodenoffensive,
wenn es die Strukturen der Hamas endgültig zerschlagen will.
Aber eigentlich, wenn man sich das genauer anschaut, dann kann man natürlich
auch durch Luftschläge diese Strukturen völlig zerschlagen,
wenn man überhaupt keine Rücksicht nimmt auf zivile Infrastruktur,
auf Wohnhäuser und wenn man auch auf die Geiseln keine Rücksicht nimmt.
Das heißt, wenn man Wenn man alles platt macht, kann man das auch aus der Luft machen. So!
Alles platt machen!
Im Kontext, ja, das ist die materielle Wahrheit wahrscheinlich,
die sie sagt. Wir wissen, okay, sie ist so kritisch eingestellt,
dass sie das bewusst noch mal so deutlich sagt, hat sie auch so angekündigt.
In der Hinsicht ist das eingepreist. Aber die Frage ist jetzt,
ob für diesen Plan, der ja materiell so richtig ist, also man hat seine eigenen
Soldaten in Sicherheit, wenn man sie aus Entfernung schießen lässt und dann
mit größerer Munition einfach ganze Häuser platt macht, statt da einzelne Türen
zu erkämpfen oder so was.
So, wie verträgt sich das dann mit der semantischen Solidaritätsbekundungsorgie,
die wir da gesehen haben?
Also ist das jetzt mit eingeklammert?
Meint Michael Roth jetzt, ist ein Plan, den ich auch gut finde? Keine Ahnung.
Ganz Gas ab, einfach dem Erdboden.
Ja, es ist, deswegen ist ja dieser Satz Israel Staatsräson richtig.
Von von von Merkel also damit kann man was anfangen mit einem Satz wie unbedingte
Solidarität, die ja diese Formulierung ist ja im Zuge des 11.
September schon gefallen, damit kann man halt nichts. Und galt auch nicht lange.
Ja galt erstmal nicht lange wie wir wissen. Herr Schröder hat sich sehr sehr
verscherzt beim Irak Krieg ganz lange her.
Und da kann man doch jetzt auch noch mal auf die persönliche Ebene gehen,
mit wem wäre man unbedingt solidarisch?
Unbedingt. Also ich kann ganz viele Leute nennen, mit denen ich solidarisch
bin, denen ich loyal gegenüber bin und wo ich auch mal ein Auge zudrücke.
Aber unbedingt solidarisch ist man mit keinem Menschen auf dieser Welt.
Und nicht mal mit sich selber würde man es einfach so, man würde selbst da sagen.
Deswegen werfen wir die andere Frage auf, mit wem wäre denn jetzt unbedingt
darüber zu reden, wie diese Floskeln zu verstehen sind? Also welche Person kennt
denn wirklich den Unterschied zwischen Semantik, Klammer auf, Diplomatie?
Krieg und dann dem Wechselspiel dazwischen, dass nämlich die Semantik,
also das Gespräch über einen Krieg, bevor er stattfindet, Einfluss haben kann
auf den Krieg, auf die materielle Struktur, die sich wirklich entfaltet und so weiter und so fort.
Und man kommt nicht umhin. Es geht nur Christoph Heusgen, der weiß,
wie im Kanzleramt Außenpolitik gemacht wird und nicht nur darüber gesprochen,
sondern gemacht und nicht nur kommentiert.
Der in der UN gesehen hat, wie auch durch Deutschland marginalisiert mittlerweile
das Gespräch über Krieg und Frieden ist auf globaler Ebene.
Und der jetzt die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz leitet, wo man also jenseits
dieser staatlichen Strukturen auf Dinner-Club-Ebene dann doch noch politische Sachen hinbekommt.
Gerade weil die anderen so marginalisiert wurden, die man auch so kennengelernt hat.
Also man kann überhaupt nur mit Christoph Heusgen darüber reden.
Es gibt da keinen vergleichbaren Gesprächspartner für diese relevanten Fragen.
Und man musste geradezu dankbar sein, dass er sich nicht aus der Öffentlichkeit
zurückzieht, trotz Renteneintrittsalter und uns vor Publikum Sachen erklärt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da grundsätzlich, also die Meinung hat mir nicht
gefallen, ja. Was ist denn das? Also das verstehe ich einfach überhaupt gar
nicht. Dass man da dann sagt, nee, nee, das ist aber nicht meine Meinung.
Ich muss ihn jetzt verteufeln.
Jetzt verteufeln.
Also dieser Teil vom Oktober jetzt der Stadtpfand in Deutschland war besonders schräg.
Obama zum Antisemiten zu erklären. Es bei beiden so zu vermuten.
Schirrits, Mark Schirrits hat da so einen witzigen Tweet gemacht.
Oterisch und Obama sind Antisemiten und bei beiden ist man sich noch nicht so
sicher. Das ist der deutsche Diskurs.
Und unsere Galleonsfigur der SPD, Esken, schreibt öffentlich bei Twitter,
ich gehe nicht zu dem Treffen mit Bernie Sanders, wo ich auch bin.
Bernie Sanders sagt, keine Ahnung, wir haben eine Buchpremiere,
da sind viele eingeladen. Weiß nicht, ob die da hingeht.
Es ist ganz, ganz, ganz schräg und deswegen sagen wir jetzt,
Christoph Häusgen, dankenswerterweise, hat er am 14.10.
Sich schon geäußert und ich finde, dass es war am 14.10., also eine Woche nach dem 7.
Oktober und ist bis heute und wird auch immer ein relevanter Punkt sein,
denn dieser Konflikt wird noch lange gehen, Häusgen dann zum Einmarsch Israels in Gaza.
Was erwarten Sie für die kommenden Tage? Ist das eine ausgemachte Sache,
dass es zu einer solchen massiven, großen Bodenoffensive kommen wird?
Es gibt Warnungen davor und viele Leute sagen, dass eine Invasion in den Gaza-Streifen
insgesamt die Sache noch viel schlimmer machen wird, humanitär, aber auch politisch.
Nur mein Eindruck nach Gesprächen mit israelischen Freunden ist,
dass das jetzt ausgemachte Sache ist und dass Israel tatsächlich in den Gaza-Streifen
einmarschieren wird und zwar in einer Art und Weise, wie sie es bisher noch nicht gemacht haben.
Insofern als sie das Ziel haben dann die Hamas völlig auszulöschen.
Und ist das ein realistisches Ziel die Hamas militärisch auszulöschen und was wäre mit welchem Preis?
In diesem Ausmaß ist es noch nie versucht worden. In der Vergangenheit haben
diese Besetzungen von Gaza nicht das erwünschte Ergebnis gebracht.
Der ehemalige Premierminister Olmert hat vor einer Besetzung gewarnt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so funktionieren wird,
wie Israel sich das vorstellt.
Ich glaube, dass das sogar eine Falle ist, die in die Israel geht, dass Hamas das möchte.
Dass Hamas möchte, dass es schreckliche Bilder geben wird von auch getöteten
Zivilisten und dass dadurch insgesamt die Situation auch in den Nachbarstaaten
in der Welt weiter eskaliert.
Das ist, glaube ich, etwas befürchte ich, was die Hamas in ihr Kalkül mit einbezieht.
Also die Hamas hasst Palästinenser unter diesen narzisstischen,
wir als Organisation wollen bestehen, wir wollen hier in gewissem Luxus leben
und so weiter und so fort.
Was bedeutet, die haben sich damals demokratisch wählen lassen,
dann haben sie die Macht übernommen,
haben gezeigt, wir sind hier die Könige der Stadt und haben als Zeichen dessen
für alle symbolisch und dann als Beispiel einfach die Menschen da vorm Haus
geworfen und auf der Straße liegen lassen und einen Zettel daneben gelegt,
legt euch nicht mit der Hamas an, das ist euer Schicksal.
Und hier, wenn er jetzt sagt, das könnte eine Falle sein, denke ich mir so,
wie könnte, das ist eine Falle.
Die Hamas wird den israelischen Soldaten, die Zivilisten nur sofort die Füße
werfen und sagen, das sind Hamaskämpfer, schießt die sofort tot.
Logisch ist, das zu tun. Und wenn jetzt jeder kommt mit diesem,
ja, die Hamas ist das ultimative Böse. Ja, genau. Deswegen wird das so einfach für die.
Diesen, wir haben ja gehört, wie die israelische Regierung drauf ist,
genau diese Kräfte, die da warten, so auszunutzen.
Wir sind hier nicht im Krieg, in dem Sinne, wo sich Soldaten gegenüberstehen.
Wir sind einer terroristischen Gruppe gegenüber, deren Mittel,
Es ist einfach alles zu tun, was ihr hilft und auf nichts Rücksicht zu nehmen.
Und da sehen wir ja daran an diesen Gräueltaten, die verübt wurden.
Es ging nicht allein darum, Menschen zu töten, sondern es ging auch wirklich
darum, es auf möglichst bestialische Weise zu tun. Und Ähnliches kann man jetzt auch da erwarten.
Und Häusgen ist jemand, der ja eine Erfahrung mit den sogenannten Kriegen gegen
den Terror hat und der ja genau weiß, wie diese waren und welche Bilder sie
produziert haben und wie sie wieder mehr Hass geschürt haben und all das.
Und aus dieser Erfahrung heraus sagt er das jetzt und ich weiß nicht,
was daran falsch sein soll, das so mal in den Raum zu stellen und zu begründen.
Ich will es auch nicht zu frech sagen oder so, aber die Logik,
die Heusken aufmacht, nicht zu verstehen, ist für mich nicht erklärlich.
Außer kennt man ja, man ist halt nicht in der Lage, es zu verstehen.
Also Klammer auf Dummheit irgendwie.
Ja, man ist halt dem Augenblick der jetzt nicht gewachsen.
Ja und deswegen, ich habe das ja eben mal so gesagt, also inwieweit man wirklich
Sorge haben muss um die Existenz von Israel.
Denn wie lang bleiben Allianzen noch bestehen?
Ist alles sehr fraglich. Wir sehen, wie wackelig das in den USA ist und dass
selbst die beiden Regierungen ja da vielleicht doch etwas zögerlicher agiert
in Bezug auf Israels Saisonstat.
Sicherlich würden jetzt die Aktivisten auf den Straßen, die...
Auf die Opfer in Gaza hinweisen, sagen ja, aber die Amerikaner unterstützen
das doch viel zu sehr und so.
Aber ich würde sagen, da sind schon einige Haarrisse zu spüren.
Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, dass dieser globale Diskurs ein ziemlich anderer wird,
wenn diese großen Demonstrationen weltweit zu beobachten und so weiter,
dann ist wirklich die Frage, Inwieweit die Hamas nicht auch gewinnt dadurch tatsächlich,
in dem Israel von der Hamas diese Falle gestellt bekommt, sich zu disqualifizieren auf globaler Ebene.
Und dieser Gefahr muss man sich im Klaren sein. Und das Heusgen,
die ihr ausdrückt, scheint mir eher, wenn ich das jetzt richtig interpretiere,
ein Solidaritätsakt gegenüber Israel zu sein, den Heusgen hier verbalisiert.
Ja, und das ist bei dem zweiten Clip jetzt noch wichtiger und triftiger und
ich finde auch noch mal besser verständlich,
also finde ich, ich weiß nicht warum das Leute anders sehen,
aber meine Vermutung ist,
die Hamas wollte möglichst grausam in Israel Massaker verüben,
in der Hoffnung, dass die Antwort so grausam ist, dass danach die Hezbollah getriggert wird.
Der Iran damit automatisch verwickelt wird und wir einfach einen Flächenbrand
haben, der am Ende Israel zerstört.
Also, wo dann wirklich heißt, okay, jetzt sind nicht 0,1 Prozent der israelischen
Bevölkerung getötet worden, sondern 20 Prozent. Also wie in diesem Long-Term-Mission-Szenario,
dass man einfach mal wirklich relevante substanzielle Teile von ganzen Populationen so verliert.
Und alles, was das sozusagen containt, ist die Diplomatie nach völkerrechtlichen Maßstäben.
Und wir hören gleich, wie Heusken dazu appelliert, dass es dazu kommt.
Denn Heusken gehört ja zu der Riege, die genau wissen, ja,
wir hören dann immer so Kriege und dann sitzt man so als Fernsehzuschauer da
und hat immer so eine Idee von, der Putin hat dann gesagt, jetzt greifen wir
an und so weiter, obwohl das alles total im Fluss ist. Also da sind alle diesen Kräften ausgeliefert.
Irgendwer macht den ersten Schuss und hofft dann, dass es irgendwie so in seine
Richtung geht, was er sich als Outcome favorisiert und nicht irgendwie noch
jemand auftaucht und so weiter.
Und in sehrer Sicht, meine Vermutung ist, die Hamas hat das wirklich ganz für
sich geregelt, so Schläfergruppenartig.
Also in dem Moment, wo sie durch so ein Geburtsranden, dass es gerade noch woanders auch stattfindet.
Also dass manche einfach dachten, ach okay, nur wir haben jetzt so einen Auftrag
da, irgendwie jemanden zu entführen oder so. Dass das gerade 100 verschiedene
Gruppen da gemacht haben, war denen dann selbst nicht klar. Und so war auch
sonst niemand eingeweiht.
Und wir wissen nicht, aber wir vermuten so ein bisschen, wenn wir es von außen
sehen, wie diese Hisbollah-Gruppen organisiert sind. Nämlich so ein bisschen wie diese bei Wagner.
Also man schmiedet die so zusammen und dann greifen einfach diese Kameradschaftsbeziehungen,
da ist dann egal, wer irgendwann eine Ansage macht, man rächt dann seinen Kameraden,
mit dem man die letzten fünf Jahre verbracht hat.
So und wenn die Hezbollah, die Hamas sehen, wie die abgeschlachtet werden von
Israel Seite aus auf Befehl der israelischen Regierung,
dann triggert das irgendwie die Hezbollah so, dass der einzelne Truppen plötzlich
auf eigene Faust, so wie Hamas auch auf eigene Faust, dann einfach,
sie haben ja Raketen und so weiter, gar nicht auf den Befehl warten,
sondern einfach völlig emotional da rein springen und so.
Und das alles zu containen, dafür braucht man Völkerrecht und zwar explizit mit diesem,
wie vorhin schon beschrieben, wir als in Anführungszeichen materiell unbeteiligte Dritte,
die wir Lippenbekenntnis und so weiter machen können, weil uns zieht ja keiner
ein, Klammer auf Michael Roth, fordern jetzt von Israel die Einhaltung völkerrechtlicher
Maßstäbe, damit die Hisbollah nicht getriggert wird.
Das so als gewünschter Outcome davon.
Und so verstehe ich Heusgen, mir ist unklar, wie man es anders verstehen kann.
Er hörte sich am 14. so an.
Ist die Bundesregierung da möglicherweise zu unkritisch, zu wenig aufmerksam,
auch für die Opfer jetzt im Gaza-Streifen?
Oder sind die Vereinten Nationen zu wenig solidarisch mit Israel?
Ich will jetzt die Bemerkungen von Seiten der Bundesregierung,
da gibt es unterschiedliche Bemerkungen, nicht kommentieren.
Lassen Sie mich sagen, als ehemaliger Botschafter bei den Vereinten Nationen,
auch als jemand, der in Deutschland ja auch groß geworden ist,
in der Bundesregierung mit der Stärke des Rechts.
Deutschland hat immer ausgezeichnet, dass wir in Deutschland,
dass wir in Europa, in den Vereinten Nationen immer auf die Stärke des Rechts
gesetzt haben, auf Europarecht, auf internationales Recht, auf Völkerrecht.
Der Bundeskanzler war gerade in New York und hat noch mal ein deutsches Bekenntnis
zu den Vereinten Nationen auch abgelegt. Wir müssen beim internationalen Recht
bleiben. Das ist das Recht der Selbstverteidigung.
Aber wir können nicht das internationale Recht als so eine Art Menü a la carte
nehmen und sagen, nein, das humanitäre Völkerrecht gilt nicht.
Das Prinzip der Verhältnismäßigkeit gilt nicht.
Damit setzen wir uns den Vorwurf von Double Standards aus und das dürfen wir nicht tun.
So und wir haben den klugen Harari vorhin gehört, der nochmal ein Zeitgespräch
Deutschland hervorhob als jetzt vielleicht verantwortliche Adresse.
In der Kommunikation mal entsprechend verantwortungsvoll und nicht faul im Konzert
da mitspielen, das hat er dann Tage vorher schon ganz explizit gemacht.
Kann man eine uneingeschränkte Unterstützung Israel garantieren,
völlig unabhängig von dem, was jetzt im Gazastreffen passieren wird?
Aus meiner Sicht ist eine uneingeschränkte Unterstützung Israels immer eine
Unterstützung, die im Rahmen des Rechtes ist, des deutschen Rechtes,
des europäischen, des internationalen Rechts.
Wir können nicht weltweit verlangen, dass sich von der Ukraine bis China die Menschen,
die die Regierungen bei der Bekämpfung des Terrorismus an internationales Recht
halten, an die Menschenrechte halten, an die universelle Erklärung der Menschenrechte,
die Basis der Vereinten Nationen und dann sagen wir, aber es gilt nicht für alle.
Ja, wir hatten doch bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, die ja Heusgen jetzt ausrichtet,
diese interessante Sache, dass Heusgen dort ein Panel machte mit dem globalen
Süden und sagte, das sei der wichtigste, das sei eigentlich das wichtigste für ihn hier.
Neben der ukraine und man war so verblüfft globaler süden ist jetzt für ihn
das wichtigste das macht er auch noch mal so ganz deutlich sind auch weniger
leute im publikum da aber er sitzt selbst auf der bühne und moderiert es selbst
und das ist schon glaube ich eine perspektivverschiebung die da stattfindet
und die mag wohl einigen nicht ganz behagen,
Weil man das immer als ein sehr transatlantisches Festival empfunden hat,
dass jetzt hier schon jemand sagt, der globale Süden ist so stark,
ist so relevant, hat so viele Menschen.
Also deswegen muss ich auch jetzt mal bereit sein, über Doppelstandards zu reden
und verhindern, dass solche entstehen, von westlichen Akteuren aus dann forciert.
Und das ist glaube ich schon ein neuer Ton, der durch Heusgen in die Sache reinkommt.
Ja, vor allem, weil man die, keine Ahnung, ich finde das so eindeutig irgendwie
alles, dass ich diese Diskussion um Heusken besonders schräg fand.
Sollen wir noch drei Clips zum Abschluss spielen? Zum Thema Israel und Palästina und so weiter.
Ich hätte noch zwei im Angebot. Okay, und dann noch drei.
Weil wir haben ja diese Problemlage, wie von mir eben beschrieben,
irgendwer provoziert mit Gewalt in der Hoffnung, dass der andere sich rächen
wolle mit gegen Gewalt reagiert.
Das ist sozusagen, wir brauchen eine Atombombe, um eine Wasserstoffbombe zu zünden.
Bild von Nolan angeboten. Mal bringen, okay, wir hatten einen Film über die
Atombombe und das war am Ende nur der Zünder für die Wasserstoffbombe.
Und wir haben ja hier diese unfassbare Gewalt, die einfach stattfand und zugerechnet werden muss.
Und das waren, wie heißt sie, Muriel? Asseburg. Asseburg, auch Matthias Schmale,
der lange das UN-Hilfswerk irgendwie in Palästina geleitet hat,
heute in Afrika arbeitet.
Die waren dazu geschaltet, was natürlich sehr mutig war von so einem Sender,
während die Programmempfehlungen andere sind.
Und Schmale beschreibt jetzt mal, dass die Palästinenser von der Gewalt der
Hamas überrascht waren und was das aber mit der Zeit bedeutet im Verlauf.
Also wenn auf den 7. Oktober dann die Tage folgen, wie sie gefolgt sind.
Mein Eindruck ist von dem, was ich von ehemaligen Kollegen oder noch UNO-Kollegen
und anderen Zivilisten höre aus dem Gazastreifen,
es gab am Anfang Verwunderung, vielleicht hier und da eine gewisse Sympathie,
weil eben gezeigt wurde, dass Israel verwundbar ist,
aber je mehr das Ausmaß Terrortat bekannt wurde, desto mehr glaube ich zweifeln
auch Palästinenser Und die erleben natürlich jetzt im Gazastreifen massive Vergeltung.
Es sind über 2500 Zivilisten tot im Gazastreifen, darunter 750 Kinder.
Und es ist einfach klar, dass eine Zivilbevölkerung das nicht zur Tagesordnung
übergehen wird. Und es ist ja auch noch nicht vorbei.
Ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig und perfide, aber wir haben ja vorhin schon
gehört, Menschen von außen, sagte Harari, sollen ein bisschen anders darüber
reden als die Menschen, die direkt betroffen vor Ort sind. Und genau diesen
Freiraum nehmen wir uns gerade.
Was wäre gewesen, wenn die israelische Regierung gesagt hätte,
das schockiert uns so sehr, wir machen jetzt erstmal 10 Tage Staatstrauer.
Uns rächend Gaza bombardieren, ob wir das heute machen oder in zehn Tagen,
das macht dann wirklich kaum einen Unterschied.
So, wir können erst mal, sag ich jetzt, fehlen jetzt andere Worte,
aber wirken lassen, was passierte, auch auf die Palästinenser.
Dann sieht man einfach, was in Israel passierte und dann kann sich jeder Palästinenser
überlegen in Gaza, ja klar, ich werde jetzt hier regiert von der Hamas,
ich kann nichts dafür und mein Schicksal ist nunmal, hier geboren worden zu
sein. Aber wie gehe ich jetzt eigentlich damit um?
Und dann mal gucken, wen man was abverlangen kann oder was sich so ergibt.
A. Also ich glaube da auch, dass das ein Ansatz, der auch meinem Pazifismus
nahekommt ist, den ich interessant finde.
Nur was ja wirklich ein ganz akutes Problem ist und das ich jetzt auch noch
wirklich von keinem gehört habe, wie es lösbar ist.
Wie wird man denn die Hamas los? Also wie befreit man Palästina von der Hamas?
Wie will man die Palästinensern davon befreien, dass das, also das ist ja eine
Organisation, die so verflochten ist und die ja zum Teil dort auch zivil agiert
in vielen anderen Bereichen.
Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass die nur auftauchen, um Terror zu machen,
sondern die sind ja auch ganz existenziell dann da in Infrastruktur und so weiter verwoben.
Wie das zu machen wäre, also wir werden da keine Antwort jetzt drauf haben,
nur das ist ja echt ein Dilemma, vor dem Israel steht.
Klar ist, man wird das jetzt mit einer Bodenoffensive nicht für immer regeln
können, also davon geht man nicht aus.
Oder wie jetzt Schneider sagt, da kann dann auch eine viel radikalere Gruppe
noch kommen und dann weiß man nicht. Aber das ist ja wirklich so vertrackt,
also man kann da gar nichts zu sagen eigentlich.
Wie kann man das einnehmen? Man könnte Finanzflüsse nochmal in anderer Weise
wahrscheinlich versuchen, aber wie will man das herstellen?
Also wir können, wie vorhin ganz am Anfang schon eingemerkt,
wenn wir Probleme besprechen, heißt das nicht, dass man eine Lösung hat.
Und wir können trotzdem kritisieren, dass viele gerade keine Lösung haben.
Ich will nur eine etwas freche Diagnose des Diskurses machen.
Gerade auch, weil der Leon Windscheid das vorhin so anfing mit plötzlich das,
plötzlich das, plötzlich das.
Ja und auf plötzlich das, plötzlich das, plötzlich das haben wir mit Zero-Covid,
Zero-Putin und jetzt Zero-Hamas reagiert.
Darüber hinaus sind wir nicht gegangen. Und wir haben kein Zero-Covid,
sondern Corona ist immer noch da. Wir haben mit dem Virus zu leben gelernt.
Putin ist auch immer noch da und wird wahrscheinlich sogar ein Gesprächspartner
sein, denn das muss man sich am Kopf mal vorstellen.
Donald Trump gewinnt die nächste Präsidentenwahl in Amerika.
Mit diesem ganzen amerikanischen Impetus mein Angebot an Putin ist,
Waffenstillstand jetzt, Einfrieren des Zustands jetzt, anstatt weitere Tote jeden Tag.
Das war's. Und dann sagt Putin, ja, bevor wir überhaupt mitbekommen haben,
also es gibt eine Einigung zwischen den beiden, bevor das überhaupt eine Spiegel-Headline
ist, dass das Putin schon sowas gemacht hat.
So und dann ist das einfach neue geschriebene Geschichte und keiner kann sich dagegen wehren.
Wie gesagt, bei diesem Konflikt kann ich mir tatsächlich so ein Szenario vorstellen,
bei einer terroristischen Gruppe wie der Hamas oder den dann noch die Hezbollah
auf Ideen kommt, eben nicht.
Also die die Lage bleibt auf Dauer echt extrem angespannt beziehungsweise prekär
und kann und und die israelische Bevölkerung kann sich nie sicher sein.
Also das ist, das ist dann Fakt. Also da, weil, weil das war ja auch das,
dass man sich ja auch auf von, von palästinensischer Seite, also von Abbas Seite
jetzt ja auch immer dann vor den größeren Friedensschlüssen,
die vielleicht möglich waren, gedrückt hat, weil der dann auch immer nochmal
seine, sich auch nicht mit der Hamas verscherzen wollte oder sonst was.
Also das ist ja auch eine Perspektive, die mal eingenommen werden muss,
dass wir es eigentlich da mit einem positiver ausgedrückt oder neutral ausgedrückt
heterogene Gesellschaft zu tun haben bei den Palästinensern.
Und da ist ja auch keine, also das ist mit, ich will hier noch mal ganz deutlich,
also das ist mit Russland und der Ukraine so etwas zu machen, ja, ist denkbar.
Und auch dann vielleicht denkbar, dass man sich daran hält, wenn gleich Putin
auch immer wieder solche Zugeständnisse gemacht hat und dann hat man sich doch
nicht daran gehalten, siehe Minsker Abkommen und so weiter.
Ja, so meinte ich das auch gar nicht.
Aber hier ist ja nochmal einfach...
Keiner Willens, also dass die, die oder sagen wir es andersrum,
der unique selling point und die einzige Existenzberechtigung der Hamas ist,
dass sie sich wie die Hamase aufführt und Terror verübt.
Genau, aber so meinte ich es gar nicht. Ich meinte nur, wir haben jetzt zwei
Jahre lang fast so eine Zero-Putin-Diskussion und faktisch wird es so wahrscheinlich
sein, also ich nehme das wahrscheinlichste Szenario derzeit für Trump, die Umfragen,
soweit er das Trump gewählt wird, es von heute auf morgen...
Bist du da echt... Ja, die Umfragewerte sind wirklich dramatisch.
Ich erinnere mich hier an andere Gespräche, Stefan.
Ja, aber es ist halt wie es ist. Also Donald Trump führt in allen relevanten Umfragen.
Ich wollte das hier nur mal so für mich, weißt du, weil ich will auch so ein bisschen Recht haben.
Ach so, ja. Ja, das ist wie mit Putins Atombombe, weißt du, wenn sie fällt,
haben wir halt Recht gehabt, aber... Ja, das muss ja nicht sein.
So, Donald Trump ist eine Atombombe.
Also du siehst da sehr schwarz für Amerika gerade.
Wir werden diesen Ukraine Krieg noch ein Jahr lang so weiter haben.
Es wird zu keinen weiteren Grenzverschiebungen kommen, aber sehr viel mehr Toten.
Es wird so eine richtige Auszehrung demografischer Art sein.
Und Donald Trump wird diese Gelegenheit nutzen, ins Amt zu kommen mit dem Frieden
in der Ukraine, der aber bedeutet, es wird vertraglich geregelt,
dass Russland diese Gebiete jetzt annektiert hat.
Schon vor zwei Jahren wird es dann heißen und so weiter, dass das ja sozusagen
eh Realität auf dem Boden ist. Und dieses Dokument wird Putin selber unterschreiben.
Also wenn wir noch diskutieren, kann Putin wirklich ein Verhandlungspartner sein?
Wird Donald Trump einfach sagen, also wir haben eine Verhandlung,
wir werden keine Verhandlungen führen. Ich sage einfach, das ist die Sachlage,
weil ich genau weiß, Putin sagt dazu ja und dann ist es halt geregelt.
Also diese Zero-Putin, Zero-Covid-Fantasien sind alle nicht aufgegangen,
richtig schief gegangen geradezu.
So und ich will nochmal auf dieses Journalismus-Paradox kurz zu sprechen kommen.
In dem Moment, wo wir gerade hoffen, dass wir jetzt gerade, weil wir so intensiv
darüber reden in allen Podcasts und in allen, in allen Bildungssendungen,
jetzt einen Auskonflikt befrieden, werden wir in 100 Jahren feststellen,
nee, das war der eigentliche Startpunkt.
Also wir haben es jetzt mit einer großen Katastrophe, die noch passiert, zu tun.
Dieser siebte Oktober war so der Beginn davon und da darf man nicht immer nur,
weil man immer so anderes hofft und es ist ja auch noch immer gut gegangen und
so solchen Ideen irgendwie, dass man da anders denkt.
Und elementar wird es erklärt von Luise Engelbrecht, die so diese deute Stimmung
unter Palästinensern beschreibt.
Minuten langen clip das ist auch wieder ich kann das sehr
empfehlen der politik podcast 340 vom deutschlandfunk wo
louise engelbrecht die ich vorher auch nicht kannte einfach rigoros
und auch so ein bisschen rücksichtslos gegenüber der dummheit ihrer gesprächspartner
einfach mal sagt was sache ist statt den nächsten appell zum antisemitismus
noch mal abzufeiern und sich wie feldmann sagt einfach nur tribalistisch in
sicherheit zu bringen sondern einfach mal mal uns informiert darüber,
die wir eben nicht Kontakt zu Palästinensern haben, wie man so denkt in Deutschland.
Ich habe im persönlichen Umfeld aber auch diese Diskussionen erlebt,
dass dann Leute gesagt haben, ja, ich will mich nicht instrumentalisieren lassen
gewissermaßen von der israelischen Seite, so kam das an.
Und wie kann es denn sein, dass es jetzt keine pro palästinensischen Demonstrationen
geben darf in Berlin? Das war so der Eindruck.
Und dann kam direkt auch wieder der Hinweis darauf, was alles schiefgelaufen
ist in der israelischen Politik, Siedlungspolitik beispielsweise.
Oder dieser rechte Minister, hilf mir, Ben-Gvir, der auf den Tempelberg gegangen
ist, wo dann gesagt wurde, das sind Provokationen.
Und das spürt ja auch ein Botschafter Israels in Deutschland.
Sebastian, du hast ein langes Interview mit ihm gemacht, Ron Prosor,
der auch gestern da war und der dann folgendes gesagt hat.
Wir müssen jetzt im Gaza-Streifen die gesamte Infrastruktur des Terrors beseitigen.
Und wenn wir das tun, möchte ich wirklich kein Ja, aber wiederhören.
Aber da ist eben die Frage, gibt es nicht hunderttausendfach schon dieses Ja, aber in Deutschland?
Das nehme ich auch ganz stark wahr. Und es wird immer mehr, das finde ich auffällig.
Ich kann sagen, dass ich in den ersten Tagen nach dem Terrorangriff der Hamas
deutlich mehr arabisch-palästinensisch-stämmige Menschen auf der Sonderlee zum
Beispiel gesprochen und gehört hab, die das ganz klar verurteilt haben.
Und je mehr dann in den Folgetagen passiert ist, desto mehr merke ich,
dass da die Stimmung kippt. Dass immer mehr jetzt diese Menschen ...
Die werden jetzt nicht zu Hamas-Anhängern automatisch.
Aber dieses Ja, aber kommt immer schneller. Bevor man das Mikrofon angemacht
hat, kommt schon das Ja, aber.
Das sagen einem auch mehr Menschen als am Anfang, finde ich,
dass es um eine Selbstverteidigung geht.
Da verschwimmt dann diese Grenze, die ich am Anfang mehr gespürt hab.
Was die Hamaster getan hat, ist Terror. Jetzt hört man immer mehr,
aber wir können ja nicht anders.
Da passiert was. Das ist ganz wichtig, das wahrzunehmen und zu gucken,
wie gehen wir damit um. Weil es ist da.
Ich will daran anknüpfen und dann diese Frage versuchen mal zu beantworten.
Ja, wie geht man denn damit um?
Also zunächst einmal muss man schon klar machen, dass Antisemitismus nicht geht.
Also da gibt es auch keine Diskussion und auch keine Entschuldigung mit.
Ja, aber du musst ja auch sehen, dass.
Und es ist ganz klar auch als solcher dann zu benennen, wenn er in Erscheinung tritt, Wo gegen ich...
Bin ist eine unendliche Ausweitung, dass man alles in Frage stellt,
was an Demonstrationen stattfindet und das alles nur als Hass-Demonstrationen framet.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist es sinnvoll, hier mal jemanden zu Wort kommen
zu lassen, der auch schon das Demonstrationsrecht einschränken wollte.
Nämlich, wir hören jetzt hier Herbert Reul, Innenminister von NRW,
der angesprochen wird bei MoMA darauf, wie man jetzt damit umgeht,
wenn es dort palästinensisch organisierte Demonstrationen gibt.
Was kann man da tun, was sollte man dagegen tun und was nicht?
Und wir sprechen mit dem Innenminister von NRW. Schönen guten Morgen,
Herbert Reul. Guten Morgen, Herr Nassif.
Ja, es ist vieles in Deutschland von der Meinungsfreiheit und von der Versammlungsfreiheit
gedeckt. Wo ist aber die Grenze?
Die Grenze ist da, wo man gegen die Regeln verstößt, die in dem Versammlungsgesetz
niedergeschrieben sind. Heißt?
Gewalttätigkeit, Aufruf zur Gewalt, sich nicht an die Absprachen halten.
Es wird vorher verabredet mit der Polizei, welche Regeln eingehalten werden.
Das war gestern Abend eine wichtige Leistung der örtlichen Polizei,
dass die präzise beschrieben haben, was erlaubt ist und was nicht.
Wann die Beleidigungen, die Beschimpfungen des israelischen Staates oder judenfeindliche
Sprüche da sind. Am Ende entscheiden das immer Gerichte.
Wenn Menschen durch die Straßen ziehen, den Hamas-Terror feiern,
Süßigkeiten verteilen, ist das noch erlaubt oder muss da der Rechtsstaat vorgehen? Ja, ich ...
Ich würde sehen, wie ein Gericht entscheiden würde. Das weiß man nämlich nie
genau. Ich befürchte, es würde erlaubt, weil die Meinungsfreiheit bei uns,
die Versammlungsfreiheit, ein ganz, ganz hohes Gut ist.
Ich habe das ja selbst erlebt, als ich das Versammlungsgesetz ein bisschen schärfer
machen wollte, dass dann sofort alle Menschen dagegen sind und sagen,
das ist ein hohes Gut, zu Recht.
Aber für mich politisch war das, was in Berlin passiert ist, einfach eins zu viel.
Rechtlich ist die Handhabe also gar nicht so groß. Ich warne immer vor solchen
Forderungen, das jetzt mal noch mal auszuweiten beziehungsweise zu verengen,
dieses Demonstrationsrecht.
Denn was einem heute recht ist, was eingeschränkt wird, kann dann morgen auch
schon ganz andere Dinge betreffen. Weil da kommen auch andere wieder auf die
Idee und sagen, dann müssen wir das aber auch mal in diese Richtung einschränken.
Deswegen, glaube ich, kommt man damit gar nicht so weit. Er hat ja einige Punkte
benannt, was also nicht sein darf.
Und dagegen muss dann punktuell vorgegangen werden, weil man ja nicht alle,
die auf einer Straße demonstrieren, gleich als Israel-Hassa oder so ruprizieren kann.
Das heißt, das muss dann im Einzelnen geklärt werden.
Das ist ja irgendwie auch eine kleinteilige Arbeit, aber so ist es nun einmal.
Damit muss man leben. Was anderes ist aber, und darauf würde ich jetzt abheben,
über dieses Rechtliche hinaus, inwieweit eine Gesellschaft damit umgeht.
Und da muss schon ganz klar sein, dass dieser Antisemitismus,
der hier vorgetragen wird auf Demonstrationen oder der ja vor allem im Internet
dann auch stattfindet, dass der geächtet gehört in ganz klarer Weise.
Und da kann man auch nicht mehr mit irgendwelchen tribalistischen Argumenten oder so,
das darf alles da keine Rolle spielen, weil dann verlässt man sofort die Grundlage,
auf der wir ja heute hoffentlich für alle ersichtlich argumentiert haben,
nämlich die Grundlage des Universalismus.
Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass man gewisse Dinge wird zulassen müssen an Kritik,
auch wenn sie dem einen oder anderen nicht gefällt.
Aber wenn wir den Meinungskorridor so eng machen, dass am Ende Christoph Heusken
schon unter Verdacht steht, Israel zu hassen, dann kommen wir halt nicht mehr
weiter mit irgendetwas.
Und das bringt dann auch dazu, dass immer mehr Gerüchte entstehen.
Wir haben das ja schon in den ganzen rechten Diskursen gehabt.
Ja, man darf ja gar nichts mehr sagen. Und dann werden wir jetzt mal bei Triggerpunkte
nachlesen, ob das wirklich so ist, was können wir dann noch sagen.
Und dieser Eindruck darf jetzt gar nicht entstehen. Warum darf der nicht entstehen?
Wir hatten eben diese lange Passage aus den Minimal Moralia von Adorno.
Und es findet sich gar nicht so viel darin zum Antisemtismus,
in dem Sinne, dass ja dieser Begriff vorkommt.
Aber es gibt noch eine andere Stelle in den minima moralia und es ist einfach
nur ein Sentenz, einfach nur ein Aphorismus, wenn man so möchte. Da sagt Adorno.
Der Antisemitismus ist das Gerücht über die Juden.
Und wenn man sich das mal klarmacht, der Antisemitismus ist das Gerücht über die Juden,
dann muss man auf jeden Fall als Gesellschaft, die Antisemitismus bekämpft,
verhindern, dass solche Gerüchte überhaupt entstehen, einen Nährboden bekommen.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt den Eindruck vermittelt,
ihr dürft gar nicht mehr euch irgendwie äußern, Ihr müsst unbedingte Solidarität
ist nur, wenn ihr genau der Linie von Volker Beck und Michael Roth folgt und
alles andere darüber hinaus geht nicht, dann lässt man ganz viele Gerüchte entstehen.
Und die können sich noch besser dann mit einem Antisemitismus,
der ohnehin schon in dieser Gesellschaft da ist und der zu wachsen scheint,
vermischen und verbinden.
Und deswegen würde ich hier noch mal ganz klar dafür plädieren,
den rechtlichen Rahmen, den man hat, sinnvoll auszuschöpfen.
Aber der Rest muss eigentlich von der Gesellschaft selbst geleistet werden und
da nicht mit irgendwelchen falschen Verständnissen oder so aufkommen.
Und da ganz klar diesem Antisemitismus, der sich da äußert, dass man sich dem
entgegenstellt und nicht fünfe Grade sein lässt, auch nicht,
wenn jemand eine Migrationsgeschichte oder sonst etwas hat,
Das kann alles, die Identität, keine Rolle spielen, keine Entschuldigung für Antisemitismus sein.
Yes, so ist es. In der Hinsicht, es wird wirklich wahnsinnig kompliziert.
Ja. Die guten normativen Schranken, die man sich wünscht. Ja.
Durchzuhalten, weil ich sehe ja gar keine Lösung. Nee, eine Lösung sowieso nicht.
Wir sind jetzt ja schon so über der Zeit, also ich hatte natürlich ein ganz
großes Thema noch vorbereitet, das bringe ich jetzt zum letzten,
damit darfst du dich ja nicht verraten.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nächsten Monat ganz gewiss noch aktuell.
Ich will noch ein kleines Thema mit zwei Clips spielen.
Ich habe ein Thema noch, das ich nur mit einem Clip spielen kann.
Und zwar nochmal hören wir Harald Schmidt.
Er wurde auch dazu befragt, wie er das denn sieht jetzt mit BSW Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht. Darüber können wir heute gar nicht ausführlich sprechen.
Ich hatte mir die Pressekonferenz angesehen, überlegte kurz Clips davon zu machen,
fand es aber dann nicht so interessant. Und jetzt hören wir uns erst mal diesen
Clip von Harald Schmidt als Inspiration
an und dann will ich noch ein paar Sätze von dir mal dazu hören.
Sarah Wagenknecht ist ein Star, Ja, und ich weiß, wovon ich rede,
als Star hat man keinen Bock auf die mühende Ebene.
Das heißt, wenn sie jetzt so eine Partei gründet, klingt das toll.
Aber da muss ja wahnsinnig viel organisiert werden.
Da muss ja der Kartoffeldruck organisiert werden für die Flugblätter.
Da brauche ich ein Faxgerät, da brauche ich Ortsverbände.
Ich brauche übrigens auch diese lästigen Kandidaten, mit denen man ja auch nichts
zu tun haben will in der eigenen Partei.
Stimmt.
Also wie ist deine Prognose? Du hast ja wahrscheinlich die Pressekonferenz auch angesehen.
Nein, ich habe es mir nicht angesehen. Ich habe es nur in Ausschnitten verfolgt.
Ich fand es unsäglich, wie der Journalismus damit umgeht.
Also ich finde, man kann das total kritisieren. Wir haben ihr Buch gelesen,
haben uns gefragt, was ist das und so.
Und trotzdem finde ich es irre, wenn in einem Deutschlandfunk-Politik-Podcast,
war es glaube ich, es war in diesem Dunstkreis Deutschlandfunk,
Öffis und so weiter. Wenn ein Platz plötzlich so,
Und gleichzeitig Sprüche fallen
wie, wir kriegen jetzt so eine Richard-David-Precht-Lautsprecher-Partei.
So im Sinne von, jemand äußert sich immer zu allen möglichen Kram und so weiter,
wie Sarah Wagenknecht, weil sie ja immer eingeladen wird. Und dann geht das so in zwei Richtungen.
Entweder man kritisiert sich selbst, auch im Deutschlandfunk,
dass man sich selber fragt die ganze Zeit. oder auch Lanz und Precht selbst
in diesem Gespräch, die haben auch darüber gesprochen.
Waren wir da nicht selber mit schuld, weil wir Sarah Wagenknecht immer wahnsinnig
attraktiv fanden als mediale Figur, wir haben sie so gerne eingeladen,
sie war ja auch häufiger an meiner Sendung und so, der ganze Kram.
Also man hat sozusagen einen Lautsprecher, ein Megafon, ein menschliches Megafon
einfach so geschaffen in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren.
Und dann diesen Bogen zu spannen, eigentlich finden wir das blöd.
Also wir laden es die ganze Zeit ein,
aber wenn die dann plötzlich so Parteien gründen und so, nee,
machen wir doch auch nicht, so was maßt die sich an, so irgendwie,
ne, als Frau jetzt plötzlich da was zu organisieren.
In der Hinsicht sind die Einflugsteisen in die Kritik so wild.
Irgendwie denke ich, das ist so heikel, sie auch noch mal zu kritisieren.
Ja, ich finde es auch ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass wir jetzt eine Ampelkoalition haben,
die ständig für Abschiebungen plädiert, die viel krassere Formulierungen wählt,
als die, die Sarah Wagenknecht in der Vergangenheit getätigt hat und dafür ja
sehr, sehr harsch kritisiert wurde.
Und das winkt man jetzt bei der Ampel alles so durch und hat nichts anderes zu tun.
Da kann man das auch Wagenknecht auch ganz ähnlich. Bei Wagenknecht jetzt zu
fragen, ist das die neue AfD oder ist das die, die weibliche AfD oder was weiß
ich. Also, dass man nichts anderes weiß, als jetzt AfD und Wagenknecht nochmal zusammenzubringen.
Ja, mich hat es auch geärgert, dass sie von, ich glaube, sie sagte,
unregulierter Migration sprach und dass sie da nicht einen vernünftigen Ansatz haben.
Wir haben ja hier, liebe Sarah Wagenknecht, im Salon immer wieder die Möglichkeit,
über tolle Bücher zu reden. Und wir wissen ja, Frau Wagenknecht,
Sie lesen auch. Lesen Sie mal das Buch von Perel Kenner zum Thema Und dann kann
man nochmal anders darüber nachdenken.
Also ist das jetzt der sinnvolle ökonomische Kurs? Ist das die vernünftige Politik,
die sie jetzt einfordern?
Das würde ich alles in Frage stellen. Aber sie jetzt einfach so auf die AfD-Seite
und irgendwie ein bisschen querdenke.
Und weil jetzt allen gerade aus dem Mainstream Richard David Precht nicht mehr
genehm ist, wird der auch noch, der muss auch noch mit Drucker leiden oder so. Genau, genau.
Also das wird dann einfach so benutzt als Munition.
Wo man sagen muss, was hat der denn jetzt mit seiner Wagenknechterhut?
Also das ist, das ist so absurd, wie das geschrieben wird.
Und ich habe mir angeguckt, was bislang an Statements veröffentlicht wurde.
Es gibt noch kein Programm. Natürlich, sie haben erst einen Verein gegründet.
Insofern hatte ich gedacht, es ist jetzt sinnlos über ungelegte Eier groß zu diskutieren.
Na was heißt ungelegte Eier? Also bei Parteien, die ein Programm haben,
ist uns doch auch egal, was da drin steht. Ja.
Dann wüsste ich ja wenigstens mal grundsätzlich, will sie die Einkommenssteuer erhöhen?
Ja, das stimmt. Also so Sachen kann man ja schon mal wissen.
Also einfach nur zu sagen, also momentan haben wir von ihr erfahren,
dass sie ganz große Konzerne nicht so gut findet.
Dass sie für eine vernünftige Politik ist, wo ich auch sagen muss,
ja was ist vernünftig, ökonomisch vernünftig, machtpolitisch vernünftig.
Dass sie sagt, wir brauchen gar nicht mehr Migration, sondern wir müssen die
Leute besser ausbilden oder überhaupt mal ausbilden.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, man muss die Leute besser ausbilden oder überhaupt mal
ausbilden, aber trotzdem wird man um Migration nicht herumkommen.
Außerdem gibt es noch eine andere Verantwortung, die da mit reinspielt beim
Thema Migration, nämlich Flucht und Asyl und all das.
Aber ich würde sagen, es ist noch nicht eine Grundlage da, auf der man sich
jetzt entweder das Maul zerreißen kann oder auf der man sagen kann, es ist alles ganz toll.
Was ich feststelle, ist, dass es aber schon bei sehr vielen Journalisten so
eine Erleichterung gibt,
dass man sagt, na ja, wenn Wagenknecht im Osten es tatsächlich schafft,
schon anzutreten, dann wird sie die AfD erhebliche Stimmen kosten.
Und da sehe ich auch jetzt erst einmal so strategisch, wenn man jetzt sagt,
AfD verhindern, einen Vorteil drin. Denn es ist ja so, dass momentan, Auf Wiedersehen.
Wir wissen, die AfD hat diese Rechtsextremen, hat Leute, die als Faschisten
bezeichnet werden. Trotzdem wählt ihr die und sagt, ihr wollt nur einen Denkzettel erteilen.
Diese Denkzettel-Argumentation, die wir sowieso hier immer sehr in Frage gestellt
haben, die gilt nun gar nicht mehr.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, ich will mal den Etablierten einen Denkzettel verteilen,
einen Denkzettel geben, dann kann ich ja jetzt die Wagenknecht-Partei wählen.
Nicht die Höcke-AfD wählen. Dieses Angebot ist gemacht und alles weitere wird man sehen.
Ob Harald Schmidt auch vielleicht recht hat, sagt, naja, sie ist ein Star und
als Star will sie hofiert werden.
Und ob da sich genügend finden, die das Spiel mitspielen, also ob sie eine Entourage
bekommt, die ja ein Star normalerweise hat, aber auch dann gut bezahlen muss. Das wird man schauen.
Also man muss das schon gut organisieren, vielleicht so ein bisschen wie so
ein Taylor Swift Tournee.
Ja, also was Harald Schmid sagt ist richtig und ich finde es,
wenn er ein bisschen früher dran gewesen wäre,
also wenn er selber im Kopf ein bisschen munter gewesen wäre,
wahrscheinlich die Megapointe landen können,
dass man ja sagt, warum gründet Sarah Wagenknecht eine eigene Partei,
weil sie es nicht mal geschafft hat in einer bestehenden Organisation,
wo sie nichts aufbauen muss, sondern nur in den Strukturen, die es gibt und
sie war die Fraktionsvorsitzende dieser Partei, konnte sie sich nicht durchsetzen.
Und jetzt gründet sie eine eigene Partei und glaubt, naja, dann gründe ich einfach
meine eigenen Strukturen und kann mich dann in denen durchsetzen,
wo wir genau sehen, was mit der Piratenpartei passiert ist, wie sich die AfD
immer weiter radikalisierte, obwohl die Spitze das immer nicht so wollte,
wie es von unten drückte.
Also aus diesen Erfahrungen zu schätzen, würde ich sagen, ist das… Gegenbeispiel wäre ja Macron.
Nicht deutsch. Macron hat dafür zwei Volksparteien abgebaut,
um eine eigene aufzubauen.
Da könnte man auch sagen, gegen das Modell ist Sebastian Kurz,
der das nämlich auch geschafft hat.
Ja, aber das ist ja, wir reden ja hier über das deutsche Fraktionsparteien und Gefüge,
wo wir nicht auf einen Speaker warten und dann werden Regeln erfunden,
sondern es gibt ganz knallharte Regeln, wie Fraktionen organisiert werden und
so weiter und so fort, wie die Willensbildung in Parteien stattfindet.
Aus Gründen gibt es die und dann kann man nicht einfach von oben in so eine
Partei hineinregieren und sagen, das ist jetzt die Liste, also dieses Prinzip,
Macron gründet eine Partei, Sebastian Kurz verwandelt einfach eine ganze Volkspartei
in eine Liste Kurz, gibt es ja in Deutschland ausdrücklich nicht.
Das deutsche Parteienrecht sieht nicht vor, dass der Parteichef darüber befindet,
wer auf welchem Listenplatz setzt, sondern das muss demokratisch geregelt werden.
Also muss man organisieren, wie die Mitglieder einen Willen formulieren.
Also diese Gefahr mit Macron und Sebastian Kurz droht ja in Deutschland gerade
nicht, weil wir so ein Parteienrecht haben, dass uns bisher immer diese Lage
versetzt sozusagen, ne, es sind ja nur fünf verschiedene Parteien und nicht
14 wie in den Niederlanden.
Und dann kommt da noch so ein Gerd Wilders, der als ich, die Partei bin ich,
die Partei hat ja einen Mitglied, Gerd Wilders.
Das läuft auch alles unter Demokratie, aber nicht in Deutschland.
In Deutschland ist es wahnsinnig schwer,
eine Partei zu gründen, weshalb sie halt auch jetzt erst mal nur einen Verein
gegründet hat, weil ansonsten müsste sie nämlich alles auf einmal machen und
das noch den Medien erzählen, erklären und noch um Mitglieder anwerben und dann
noch die Mitglieder so organisieren, dass es am Ende in ihrem politischen Wille geht.
Also ich halte das für, was er so salopp sagt, für extrem kompliziert, was sie da zuvor hat.
Im Prinzip dann nur Getreue, die das mitmachen und ob man da genügend findet,
also die diese Strukturen dann wirklich aufbauen, also dass da Leute bereit
sind, auch mit in der ersten oder zweiten Reihe zu stehen, da habe ich keinen Zweifel dran.
Aber diese Strukturen aufzubauen und sich dann quasi diesem Top-Down regieren zu unterstützen.
Das ist eine große Frage.
Wir haben in Deutschland aus Gründen
Föderalismus und organisieren die Bundestagswahl über Landeslisten.
Sarah Wagenknecht ist aber nur eine Person. Wenn die bei einer Bundestagswahl antreten will.
Ja, deswegen heißt es ja schon Sarah Wagenknecht, damit das überhaupt noch an sie gekoppelt ist.
Wir müssen dann den Sachsen erklären, dass sie Sarah Wagenknecht bekommen,
obwohl der Landesverband nach
deutschem Parteienrecht sehr selbstständig und ohne sie regieren wird.
Da würde ich allerdings sagen, da ist sie eigentlich nah an dem,
also das ist ja alles völlig richtig, was du sagst, aber ich glaube,
dass sie damit wirklich sehr nah ist an dem, wie Leute über Politik denken.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, die Anekdote mal erzählt, als mal eine Nachbarin in Rheinland-Pfalz
zu mir sagte, das nächste Mal wähle ich den Stoiber. Und ich sagte,
das könnte von Koblenz auch schwierig werden.
Und wenn Sarah Wagenknecht Erfolg hat mit ihren Landeslisten,
weil die Bundesthemen trotz Landeslisten, dann ist es aber mediales Versagen.
Dann nutzt sie ein mediales Versagen. Das hatten wir ja beim Landrat,
dass ein Landrat gewählt wird, weil der hat irgendwas mit der Heizung.
Diesel, Migration und so weiter, sind dann die für den Landratsposten,
für den der dann spontan verbeamtet wird, weil er gerade nicht eine politische Figur ist.
Das ist völlig irre, dass die Wähler das nicht verstehen.
Aber wir haben doch nur die Kommunikation darüber. Wir haben doch bei jeder
Landtagswahl wird hier gerade die Bundesregierung abgestarrt.
Ich finde es sehr gut, dass Journalisten darüber diskutieren,
ob Sahra Wagenknecht erfolgreich sein kann, wenn Sahra Wagenknecht dumme Journalisten
braucht, um erfolgreich sein zu können und genau diese dummen Journalisten gerade bekommt.
Nämlich den Leuten nicht erklären, wie es funktioniert.
Nur ist das ja nicht allein Sahra Wagenknechts Problem. Die ganze Politik zielt
ja darauf ab. Die ganze Oppositionsarbeit in jedem Landtag beißt laufend auf
irgendwelche Sachen hin, die den Bund betreffen.
Ich will trotzdem noch eine Sache zu Sahra Wagenknecht sagen,
weil jetzt diese Hoffnung ist, sie nimmt dann der AfD-Stimm weg.
Also, wir haben ja zwei AfDs. Die AfD, von der wir immer hören,
also, die dann irgendwie sagt, keine Erbschaftssteuer, lasst mal das Vermögen
unangetastet, jedem das Seine und so weiter.
Das ist dieser westdeutsche, baden- württembergische Flügel und so weiter und so fort.
Der ja aus Gründen bei einem AfD-Parteitag jedes Mal das Thema Rente und so
weiter von der Tagesordnung streicht, damit nicht klar wird, was die Ost-AfD will.
Nämlich diese Sozialpolitik, wie sie Sarah Wagenknecht jetzt auch macht.
Wenn jetzt Sarah Wagenknecht,
und das finde ich sehr interessant, dass die deutschen Journalisten und Richard
David Brecht sich jetzt so fragen, gibt es das Rechts-Links-Schema noch,
weil in der Migrationsfrage ist das ja super rechte Politik,
in der Sozialpolitik ist es super linke Politik.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, das Rechts-Links-Thema hat uns so und so weit gebracht,
aber wenn wir es mit einer nationalsozialistischen Partei zu tun haben,
können wir sie auch wieder so nennen.
Wir machen eine Sozialpolitik, aber nur für Deutsche.
Aber das machen wir ja jetzt gerade auch.
Machen wir jetzt gerade auch, weshalb ich umso mehr dafür bin,
das dann auch wieder so zu nennen. Also wir lügen uns ja in die Tasche.
Ich würde es halt nicht nationalsozialistisch nennen.
Aber die Thüringer AfD ist, wenn wir jetzt einfach nur funktional,
inhaltlich durchgehen, eine nationalsozialistische Partei. Die macht Sozialpolitik,
aber im nationalen Kontext.
Ja, aber macht sie wirklich Sozialpolitik?
Also das wird immer so gesagt, aber wenn man sich das dann mal näher anguckt,
Ich weiß ja auch, dass da aus dem Kubitschek-Lager Leute sind,
die jetzt Höcke beraten oder zu beraten scheinen.
Und ja, da geht es dann irgendwie auch um etwas mehr soziale Frage.
Aber wir hatten ja gerade auch im Live-Salon diese KRA-Ausschnitte,
wo er sagt, ja, es gibt so viele arme Rentner und, und, und.
Ja, KRA ist auch dieser Westdeutsche, ne? Nee, KRA ist ja Kubitschek-Lager.
Aber Kubitschek ist ja auch so ein Wessi. Nee, aber Kubitschek gehört zu diesen
Dingen. Also ich, das ist ja schon Höcke umfüllt.
Ja, aber es gibt jetzt wirklich wieder so Mutterkreuz-Nazis und sowas.
Und was hat er dann gesagt? Dann hat er gesagt, ja, wir müssen immer wieder
den armen Deutschen, sollen wir mal wieder unsere Märchen vorlesen und die alten
Lieder singen. Also stimmt alles. Was ich sagen will, ich sehe,
also in Polen stimmte das. In Polen hatte man... Polen ist ja ein großes Vorbild für die.
Genau, in Polen hat man das aber auch tatsächlich dann gesehen,
dass diese Art, ich würde mal sagen, nationalsoziale Politik da ein bisschen Einzug halten hat.
Aber das hat sehr, sehr harte Grenzen und da würde ich auch einen Unterschied
machen wollen zur Wagenknecht-Partei, was immer da jetzt sowieso rauskommt.
Aber bei denen mag es zwar sein, dass die eine gewisse soziale Abfederung für
die, die mit deutschem Pass haben wollen, dann zu Ungunsten jener,
die keinen deutschen Pass haben.
Aber du musst ja, um eine soziale Politik zu machen, auch eine Umverteilungspolitik machen.
Und die schaffst du aber nicht darüber, indem du Flüchtlingshilfen kürzt,
weil das einfach ganz wenig Geld ist, was du da nochmal denen,
die eh nix haben, wegnimmst. Sondern du musst an Vermögen ran von Leuten, die Geld haben.
Und genau diesen Schritt geht auch in der Ost-AfD.
Keiner, niemand. Ob Wagenknecht hingewischt, weiß ich nicht.
Das blieb alles sehr nebulös. Aber dieser an sich soziale Schritt hin,
der hat nicht stattgefunden.
Und im Übrigen hat der ja auch im Nazi-Deutschland nicht stattgefunden.
Da wird, also das darf jetzt auch nicht in diese Erika Steinbach-Richtung gehen,
dass man da sagt, ja, da war auch Sozialpolitik.
Nee, nee, das war schon auch eine extrem unsoziale Politik.
Deswegen bin ich, wird das rhetorisch natürlich von denen jetzt gerne in Anschlag
gebracht. Wir schützen hier unsere Deutschen und da soll keiner im alter Arm
sein. Aber de facto geht diese Politik nicht in die Richtung. Richtig.
Ja auch, nur weil man sagt, es heißt nationalsozialistisch, heißt das ja nicht,
dass es eine tolle Sozialpolitik war.
Die Frage ist nur nach diesem polnischen Vorbild.
Du kommst ins Amt, in dem Falle, also Höcke zählt ja nur auf 33 Prozent ab,
sodass er eine Sperrminorität für verfassungsgebende Änderungen hat und so weiter.
Erstmal. In Polen kamen die ins Amt, mussten jetzt gar nicht so ein großes sozialpolitisches
Lagerfeuer anzünden, sondern die haben einfach nur das Kindergeld.
Mal so eine substanzielle Sache. So einfach. So jetzt kann man sich überlegen,
in Bayern gibt es auch ein bayerisches Familiengeld.
Also die haben ja auch sowas. Die Frage ist ja nur, wie man es semantisch labelt.
Und ich denke, es droht so ein bisschen,
dass Sarah Wagenknecht die nächsten, sagen wir mal, vier Jahre so ein inhaltliches
Strohfeuer entfacht mit sozialpolitischen Maßnahmen, die nicht teuer sein müssen.
Wir sagen ja immer wieder. Es ist ja auch nicht teuer.
Es sind ja kleinste Zugeständnisse Kindern, also dem dritten Kind in einem Haushalt,
einfach 200 Euro mehr im Monat zu geben. Was sie ja wirklich existenziell merken.
So, dass das einen Unterschied macht. Aber in der Summe bedeutet das fast nichts
für den Staatshaushalt. Fällt gar nicht groß auf.
So, dass Sarah Wagenknecht jetzt vier Jahre lang so ein inhaltliches sozialpolitisches
Strohfeuer entfacht, von dem man dann wieder sagt, aber ich Vielleicht kann
auch das Original wählen, die AfD will das doch auch.
Wenn ich das bei Sarah Wagenknecht so vernünftig fand und die ganzen Journalisten
auch nicht, sie in so eine Björn Höcke-Richtung drängen, wieso sollte ich dann
bei Björn Höcke, der ja im Grunde dasselbe fordert, der das einfach abgucken kann?
Unter so einem Impetus wären wir ja zuerst da.
Das wird der große Kampf. Wer von beiden ist das Original? Sarah Wagenknecht?
Die seit 20 Jahren, die Aussicht ist begeistert. Ich habe das damals selber
als Kind mitbekommen, wie meine Elterngeneration fasziniert war von Sarah Wagenknecht.
Oder ob die AfD sagen kann, wir haben schon die Parlamentarstaaten.
Aber dann ist das das Original Sarah Wagenknecht und im Zweifel,
also das muss man jetzt, also bei aller Kritik an Sarah Wagenknecht,
dass sie was sozialeres will für Deutschland und auch für alle,
die nicht einen deutschen Pass haben.
Und dass da nie eine Remigrationsdebatte oder so kommen wird,
das muss man jetzt einfach mal klar machen.
Also man muss auch mal die Kirche im Dorf lassen, dass das ja schon eine sozialere Sache wäre.
Mich, als ich das so sah, vernünftige Politik, als ich das so hörte,
wer da sprach, man hat ja auch so einen Unternehmer, der von Tax Me Now ist,
der sagte, wir müssen mal die wirklich Vermögenden stärker besteuern.
Ich habe dann auch unter diesem Aspekt des Linkskonservatismus,
also das ist ja eine Partei, die sich einmal gegen die Linke,
die sogenannte Lifestyle-Linke wendet und vor vor allem die Grünen als Feind auserkonnern.
Er habe darüber nachgedacht, ob jetzt gerade auf der Landesebene,
die, wie sie dann heißen wird, BSW, möglicher Koalitionspartner werden kann für eine CDU.
Die beiden könnten sagen, wir sind beide gegen irgendwie die Lifestyle-Linken
und wir technologieoffen wollen wir beide sein, deswegen nicht wie die Grünen,
die wollen was verbieten.
Also ich würde sagen, da ist ein gewisser Spielraum, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
und wenn man weiß, in welchem Lager auch Wagenknecht sehr beliebt ist,
das ist nämlich jetzt gar nicht so sehr das, Ich glaube, das war ein strategischer
Fehler, auch mit diesem Querdenker-Kram, so sehr an so eine Lage anzudocken,
mit diesem ganzen Impf-Gedämsen.
Ich glaube, es ist doch meistens so, und Harald Schmidt sagte dann auch,
wenn sie bei mir in der Show zu Gast war, immer gut funktioniert und so.
Es ist das bürgerliche CDU-Lager, das eigentlich sagt, ja, irgendwie hat die Warnknecht schon was.
Und da würde ich sagen, sehe ich jetzt, wenn ich nur machtstrategisch darüber nachdenke,
eine mögliche koalition die natürlich auf
keinen fall von der wagenknecht partei jetzt gesagt
werden dürfte weil dann sagt man ja wie also man muss jetzt gerade
ja dieses ob wir sind die wahre opposition stark spielen die cdu hat einen ganz
großen vorteil mit wagenknecht die linke hat immer noch bei den cdu leuten diesen
sd vibe mit drin ja das holen die immer noch mal raus Das müssen,
obwohl jetzt Wagenknecht ja da ganz kommunistisch unterwegs war,
das ist aber jetzt bei so einem neuen Bündnis nicht mehr der Fall.
Also man kommt jetzt da nicht nochmal mit der SED-Vergangenheit oder sowas an.
Deswegen kann das für die CDU recht einfach sein, mit denen zu koalieren.
Nächstes Jahr müssen eh alle mit allen koalieren. Ich finde es auch verrückt,
dass wir so nah, also überlegen wir mal, vor einem Jahr haben alle schon über
die bayerische Landtagswahl geredet, als wäre sie morgen, weil Söder die ganze
Zeit im Kampf war und so weiter.
Diese drei Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland nächstes Jahr.
Rolle irgendwie, wo ich mir denke, wollt ihr nicht so langsam mal anfangen?
Ne bitte nicht! Naja, also... Stefan, alles...
Ne, jetzt kein Scherze. Hier braucht man das immer noch 14 Tage vorher machen.
Ich als Ossi kann dir sagen, die Landtagswahlen nächstes Jahr sind eine Zäsur für Deutschland.
Ja. Also das wird die Nachkriegszeit auf eine gewisse Weise beenden und man
wird einen Neustart des Verfassungsgefüges diskutieren, weil alle Parteien in
einer Koalition, um die AfD irgendwie draußen zu halten.
Wohl wissend, dass Björn Höcke sich händereibend daneben setzt und sagt,
klar mache ich hier die größte und einzige Opposition, weil die nächste Landtagswahl
kommt bestimmt, klar habe ich noch mal fünf Jahre Geduld. Das kann man sich nicht leisten.
Und das ist aber der einzige Ausweg, wenn man jetzt nicht schon darüber diskutiert, was dann ist.
Also die alle jetzt immer so diesen, nee, der Friedrich Merz wird das schon
überleben nächstes Jahr.
Der wird Kanzlerkandidat, auch wenn er dreimal gegen die AfD im Osten verliert.
Und ich denke mir irgendwie, Seid ihr sicher, beziehungsweise seid ihr verrückt?
Es ist doch nicht die Frage, ob Friedrich Merz es übersteht,
CDU-Chef zu sein, sondern ob es die ganze CDU einfach zerreißt.
Ob die komplette ostdeutsche Landesverbände einfach verliert.
Die sich dann sagen, nee, Leute, wir gehen ja alle zur AfD. 20 Prozent kommen
nicht mit, ja, scheiß drauf.
Also das, was Gra gesagt hat, das ist das, was droht.
Unter der Maßgabe finde ich diese Koalitionskalkulation für ostdeutsche Länder
nächstes Jahr ... Ich bin selten da, wenn ich da bin, bin ich erschüttert.
Und ich weiß jetzt wieder, aus welchen Gründen.
Weil da grummelt es gerade wirklich, da brodelt es.
Es ist ja auch in Thüringen nicht nur, da werden derzeit einige Parteien gegründet,
denen gleich mal ein Fraktionsstatus heute schon attestiert wird,
weil sie einfach auf so ein Reservoir an Wählern treffen.
Das ist nicht nur Sarah Wagenknecht. Das ist nur für uns hier in Westdeutschland
wieder interessant, weil wir sie halt kennen.
Aber diese Thüringer Landtagswahl, sich wirklich jetzt schon mal angucken. Also da droht einiges.
Mit dem Thema Osempic und zwar unter der Maßgabe ökonomische Argumentationen, sonst keine.
Also Osempic muss man noch mal hinzusagen für die Leute, die das nicht so ganz
mitbekommen. Das ist der Lusttämmer. Das ist eine Spritze, die man sich dann
regelmäßig setzt. So wie ich das verstehe. Dann hat man keine Lust mehr auf
Essen, aber offenbar auch auf viele andere schöne Dinge des Lebens nicht mehr.
Man haut sich Osempic rein, das hält dann fünf Tage. Wir hatten es ja mal so
beschrieben, man haut sich das montags rein.
Fünf Tage funktioniert man dann einfach. Am Wochenende Okay,
kann man ein bisschen genuss und dann Montag geht's wieder weiter.
Also man blockiert einfach jedes Lustempfinden, insbesondere beim Essen.
Wie in Severance, ja.
Genau, so hat sie das besprochen. Und jetzt kleiner Gegenentwurf von Scott Galloway.
Also explizit gegen, als hätte er uns zugehört, das nimmt unsere Lust.
Denn Scott Galloway macht folgende Argumentation auf, folgendes Zukunftsbild für die Menschheit.
Ich denke, das ist die größte Geschäftsstunde im Jahr 2023. Ich denke,
das ist wahrscheinlich die größte technologische Veränderung seit dem GPS oder dem iPhone.
Wenn man darüber nachdenkt, United denkt, sie würden 80 Millionen Dollar pro Jahr verdienen.
Aber schau dir die zweiten Effekte an. Knie-Veränderungen würden sehr hoch gehen.
Ich meine, fast das Essen.
Keiner geht in Arby's und denkt, das war eine gute Entscheidung.
Literal. Niemand denkt,
okay, ich bekomme schäle Fleisch,
das hier in einem gelatinierten Kubus geliefert wird, und dann wieder verheizt.
Alkoholverbrauch. Die Leute, die Ozempec trinken, verbrauchen 62 Prozent weniger Alkohol.
Ich denke, du kannst sehen,
Cara, ich denke, du kannst einen Babyboom sehen,
weil Menschen, die schlimm sind, sich besser fühlen, So, Osempic hemmt unser
Lustempfinden, weshalb wir weniger konsumieren, und zwar durch die Bank.
Es spart uns Geld und es macht uns gesünder und schlanker vor allem.
Was bedeutet in dem Moment, wenn das abklingt und wir kennen alle die Diskussion,
heute schon mal an die Bikini-Figur denken. Also man nimmt ja gerne wohl vier,
fünf Monate in Kauf, um dann zwei Wochen einen geilen Urlaub zu haben.
Was wäre, wenn man in diesem Urlaub sein Ziel tatsächlich erreicht hat und sich
wirklich erstmal in sich selber verliebt, weil man sich das erste Mal im Sommer
wieder in einem Bikini sieht oder in einer Badehose und denkt, gar nicht so schlecht.
Dann geht man auch anders in die Welt und auf andere Menschen zu.
Da steigert sich es umso mehr ins Lustgefühl rein. Da hast du endlich dein demografisches
Problem gelöst, meinst du?
Ja. Also ich halte das für, also ich hatte doch damals auch einen Clip vorgespielt,
wo gesagt wurde, ich habe das jetzt mal getestet und ich war dann auch so generell
lustlos und das bezog sich durchaus auch auf das Amoröse.
Ja, aber du kannst es ja als Phase, du musst es ja nicht als grundsätzliche
Lebenseinstellung. Okay. Klar, aber man macht doch eine Bikini-Figur-Diät für
vier Monate, um dann all in zu gehen. Ja. So, und das schaltest du ja nur temporär aus.
Wir gehen jetzt wieder in unser Lieblingsthema. Wir haben jetzt wahrscheinlich
vier Stunden Israel-Nahost-Konflikt und jetzt kommen wir zu den meisten E-Mails.
Ich will nur sagen, ich habe dafür keine Beweise,
aber ich sehe hoch sexualisierte Körper bei Instagram und TikTok bei gleichzeitiger Abwesenheit von Sex.
Also diese Schlussfolgerung, hier gezogen wird, irgendwie attraktiver,
körpersportlich, was weiß ich, irgendwie und wird kombiniert mit regem Sexleben,
würde ich mal sehr in Zweifel ziehen, ob dem so ist.
Genau das Gegenteil. Die Leute haben keinen Sex, weil sie sich selber schon nicht mehr mögen.
Nein, nein, nein, das hat andere Gründe.
Werden wir sehen, denn die Olympic Revolution kommt jetzt. Also der nächste
Sommer wird wohl Also ein richtiger USEMPIC-Sommer. Also das ist ja...
Scott Galloway macht Beobachtungen. Das kannst du ja nicht wirklich annehmen. Also das hat doch...
Ich sag so, es ist jetzt Oktober 2023, wir hören uns diesen zweiten Clip an.
Scott Galloway ruft die USEMPIC-Economy aus.
Und ich sage, da ist was dran. Du sagst, nee, es spielen ganz andere Sachen
und so weiter eine Rolle.
Meine Vermutung ist, also ich möchte ihm einfach, Ich möchte ihm recht geben, affirmativ.
Und ich denke aber auch, es ist nicht ganz unwahr, was er sagt.
Denn wir leben nun mal in einer Welt, in der es ist, wie es ist.
Die Menschen sind mit sich selber unzufrieden. Wir haben diesen Text im Spiegel gelesen.
Ja, aber die Menschen werden ja mit sich unzufrieden bleiben.
Ich glaube, das ist eine andere... Mal sehen. Nee, nee, nee.
Also das will ich nur noch gerade klarstellen.
Diese ganzen tausenden Videos, wir hatten das ja auch hier schon als Thema.
Junge Männer, die eigentlich gut aussehen, aber nichts anderes im Sinn haben,
als irgendwie ihre Jawline zu vergrößern und so, die sind ja,
die brauchen kein Osempic, ja, die sind, die, die, die, das ist eigentlich alles, alles ideal.
Die? Und ja, aber die sind trotzdem die ganze Zeit unzufrieden.
Ja, das ist ja auch, das ist wirklich was anderes.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, und ich glaube nicht, dass, dass irgendwas, also, dass die ja...
Wie er trainiert es oder so, etwas mit der Häufigkeit von Sex,
dann ist ja Sex noch nicht gleich, also wir sind ja da heute,
wir haben ja da einige Möglichkeiten, ist ja Sex nicht gleich mit Nachwuchs
verbunden, wie wir wissen.
Also da diese Verbindung, die er da sieht, er sieht jetzt so ein neues dynamisches
Amerika offenbar vor sich mit Ozemkic.
Ich habe meine Zweifel, aber wir lassen uns überraschen, also vielleicht.
Du siehst mich ermattet in Vorfreude auf einen Schnitzel. Ich werde jetzt all
die Argumentationen in meinem Kopf.
Ich sage dir nur, sie ist da. Ja, also wir gehen jetzt gleich Anti-Ozempic machen.
Und ich lasse aber jetzt noch Scott Galloway die Ozempic Economy ausrufen,
weil ich glaube, da ist was dran.
Ich bin nur aufzudrehen. Ich denke, dass das Industrieessen,
das Snackessen, Ich denke, dass einige der großen Box-Retailer,
die Industrie-Obesität-Komplexe, die wir nicht mögen, die Krankenhäuser,
die Kompanien, die Knie- und Hüfte-Veränderungen machen, ich denke,
dass Sie diese Kompanien in den nächsten 12 Monaten auf dem Markt kapitalisieren werden.
Hm, das ist eine gute Vorstellung. Wenn plötzlich 100 Millionen Menschen weniger
essen und trinken und all die Veränderungen,
ob es um Diabetes, Hüfte- oder Knie-Veränderungen, Depressionen oder Therapie
geht, denke ich, dass es weniger Therapie geben wird.
Du wirst mehr Sport haben. Es wird auch viele Gewinner geben,
die wir nicht einmal vorstellen können.
Jeder redet über AI und es wird die meisten Berichte haben, aber in den nächsten
fünf Jahren werden die größten Veränderungen in der Markteinheit aufgrund der
ozempischen Wirtschaft oder der Obesitätswirtschaft, die gerade abzudrücken ist, passieren.
Die Leute erkennen einfach nicht, wie viel von unserer Wirtschaft von Obesität ausgedrückt wird.
Glaube ich schon. Also wenn sollte, ich muss einschränken,
sollte Osempic tatsächlich diese Wirkung haben, die man dort unterstellt und
sollte sich das so durchsetzen können und das auch gesund seien,
das dauerhaft zu machen, dann kann ich mir das durchaus vorstellen.
Lass mich zum Schluss noch zwei Clips bringen, auch wenn wir heute nicht in die Oper gehen.
Da will ich aber noch noch ein Wort zur Oper verlieren, nämlich Waltraud Meyer,
die wahrscheinlich größte lebende Wagner-Interpretin, Sopranistin, hat abgedankt.
Sie verabschiedet sich jetzt mit Mitte 60 von der Bühne.
Sie ist seit neun, seitdem sie 19 ist, Opernsängerin, hat mit,
ich glaube, 25, 26 schon die Kuntri Gesungen ist also eine der ganz, ganz großen Stimmen.
Und wer sie nicht kennt, einfach mal Waltraud Meyer bei YouTube eingeben und
Liebestod dahinter schreiben. Dann sieht man, wie sie die Isolde singt,
diese acht Minuten sich mal reinziehen. Es gibt mehreren Versionen,
singt sie das. Es ist herausragend.
Und Waltraud Meyer hatte jetzt ihren Abschied an der Staatsoper unter den Linden.
Ole ist sogar hingefahren in Elektra. Wir haben das ja auch schon mal in Frankfurt gesehen.
Und sie hat aber nicht Elektra gesungen, sondern Clütemnestra,
also eine Rolle, die sie unbedingt machen wollte.
Auch deshalb wollte sie es machen. Sie hat also hier nochmal in dieser berühmten
Patrice Giraud Inszenierung ist sie aufgetreten.
Patrice Giraud war für sie ein sehr wichtiger Regisseur und wir hören erstmal, was sie sich wünscht.
Ich würde mir wünschen für die Oper, dass das Augenmerk nicht so sehr nur auf
die Augen gerichtet wird, sondern eben auch wieder aufs Musikalische.
Was ich natürlich jetzt ganz glücklich bin, dass Christian Thielemann hierher
kommt, weil der hat ein Ohr dafür und das finde ich ganz fantastisch.
Und eben, dass mehr darauf geachtet wird in Regie, auf Emotionen.
Also, dass nicht nur wahnsinnig viel auf der Bühne an Spektakel passiert,
wo man nachher zwar sagt, oh wow, da ist furchtbar viel los gewesen,
aber ich möchte Menschen sprechen lassen.
Ich möchte, dass Menschen Emotionen ausdrücken Und dass diese Emotionen,
dass die sich übertragen auf die Menschen, die im Zuschauerraum sitzen.
Und da können wir, denke ich, aus unserer Erfahrung in Frankfurt auch sagen,
dass die schauspielerischen Leistungen wirklich sehr, sehr gut sind und dass
da das Menschliche, was sie jetzt hier anspricht, sehr transportiert wird.
Ja, jedes Mal, wenn wir hier podcasten, ich gucke ja genau auf meinen Stapel
der Bücher, der Programmhälfte. Es sind jetzt zehn oder elf.
Alle fanden hier in Frankfurt statt und ich saß nie weiter hinten als in Reihe
drei und zweimal waren wir im Bockenheimer Depot und saßen in Reihe eins.
Ich weiß also nicht genau, worüber sich spricht, denn wenn ich in die Oper gehe,
sitze ich ganz vorne, sehe nur Menschen, höre nur geile Musik und Spektakel auf der Bühne.
Ja, sie meinte, dass es ja durchaus Regisseure gibt, die starr ein Konzept verfolgen
und dann gerade dieses zwischenmenschliche Spiel, das auch stattfinden soll,
eigentlich ziemlich unmöglich machen.
Also, dass man mehr Konzepte auf die Bühne stellt als Menschen und sie wäre
jetzt dafür, dass man tatsächlich mehr Menschen, also mehr die Sänger da.
Und du weißt ja, ich mag es ja, wenn auf der Bühne was los ist und es möglichst voll ist.
Naja, du willst immer.
Aber wir haben ja bisher auch nie ein Defizit an Emotionen.
Nein, nein, aber man kann ja sehr minimalistisch große Fülle herstellen an menschlichen Emotionen.
Aber wir haben jetzt heute so viel über Kontext geredet und als hätte ich es
geahnt, habe ich jetzt noch etwas mitgebracht von Waltraud Meyer.
Und zwar wird sie dann gefragt, wie sie denn jetzt an diese Rolle der Klöte
Mnestra drangegangen ist. Denn das ist, kann man wohl sagen,
eine der grausamsten Figuren auf der Opernbühne.
Die Mutter von Elektra, die hat ja nun wirklich nichts Gutes im Sinn,
wie wir wissen. Das ist ja eine Existenz, die da in der Nacht rummarschiert,
von irgendwelchen Träumen heimgesucht wird, mit Schlafproblemen hat und und und.
Und diese eigentlich sehr, sehr finstere Gestalt,
eine der finstersten Gestalten sicherlich der Operngeschichte,
die wird jetzt von Waltraud Charakterisiert und sie zeigt uns jetzt plötzlich
auch die ganze Geschichte, das gesamte Bild.
Sie zeigt uns also auch den Menschen, den wir darin erkennen müssen.
Patrice hat immer gesagt und wir waren uns da so völlig einig, dass,
von der Clytemnestra ist tragisch. Die ist ja nicht irgendwie eine böse,
verkommene Person. Ich meine, man muss ihre ganze Geschichte auch wirklich betrachten.
Erstens mal wurde sie zur Hochzeit vergewaltigt.
Dann wurde ihre erste Tochter, die Ephigenie, als Opfer gebracht,
damit die Männer in den Krieg ziehen konnten. Dann kommt nach zehn Jahren der
Mann heim, bringt die Geliebte mit.
In der Zwischenzeit hat sie den geheiratet, den sie eigentlich geliebt hatte.
Also ich meine, ihr Schicksal ist ganz schlimm. Ich will, oder man spielt ja
auch, dass sie diese wahnsinnigen Gewissensbisse hat, aber man muss die ganze Geschichte verstehen.
Man muss sie deswegen nicht rechtfertigen, aber man muss sie verstehen.
Insofern ist es für mich ganz klar, mich damit auch zu identifizieren.
Ich meine, ich habe mich schon immer mit allen Personen auf der Bühne,
die ich gespielt habe, voll und ganz identifiziert.
Das ist es ja gerade, die Inkarnation.
Das ist es. Ich muss in den Text, ich muss in die Gedankenwelt,
ich muss in den Körper dieser Personen
reinkriechen und muss sie für meine Wahrheit nehmen. Nur so geht es.
Doch, was wir machen, wenn wir in die Oper gehen, dass wir die A- und die B-Seite
sehen und wenn eine Inszenierung das auch noch uns ein bisschen erleichtert,
dies zu tun, dann umso besser. Und wenn die Sänger stimmen, wunderbar.
Und man kann vielleicht doch mit dieser Art des Blicks auf die Dinge vielleicht
dann viel mitnehmen für die politische Wirklichkeit, die wir ja heute hier versuchten
von mehreren Perspektiven zu betrachten.
Wobei, wenn die so darüber redet, also ja, aus ihrer Sicht auf der Bühne,
gut, wenn ich so als Publikum da sitze.
Immer klar. Allerdings das Angebot ist ja es nicht zu reflektieren.
Da wird gesungen und das Singen ist nicht das typische menschliche Verhaltensmuster,
sondern es ist ein Artifizielles, das im besten Fall dann einfach untergeht.
Ja, es wird halt gesungen. Also man nimmt es dann so als es ist normalisiert.
Naja, man reflektiert nicht in dem Moment, dass man gerade nicht im Theater
ist, sondern in der Oper.
Achso, ja, ja. Das ist ein sehr guter Gedanke.
In der Hinsicht ist es grundsätzlich so ein, es ist eine Identifizierungsblockade
da, weil die da halt singen.
Achso, so siehst du das, okay.
Und in dem Rahmen können die aber hinter dieser Identifizierungslinie dann richtig
all in gehen. Ja, aber es ist halt trotzdem immer noch so ein,
man weiß halt, das ist halt, das kann man jetzt in diesem Kontext,
passt ja heute besonders gut.
Wir sehen politische Diskussionen von Menschen, die sprechen im Fernsehen.
Die gaukeln uns vor, dass sie jetzt gerade ihre Probleme, also dass sie sich
über Themen reden, die sie sich zu eigen gemacht haben, was nicht so ist,
denn die steigen danach in ihre Autos, Lassen sich nach Hause chauffieren und
nehmen an dem Leid, über das sie reden, nicht teil.
Machen Liebenbekenntnisse zu dem. Ja, ihr könnt gerne machen,
was ihr wollt. Ich nehme ja nicht teil. Dieser unausgesprochene Satz.
Bühne wird dir das nicht vorgegaukelt, diese Art der Identifikation,
sondern man identifiziert sich als Schauspieler mit einer ausgedachten Figur.
Und das dann aber all in. Ohne dem Publikum vorzugaukeln, wir lösen hier gerade
die Weltprobleme. Sondern ne, die singen auf der Bühne. Wenn wir nachher rausgehen,
singt da keiner mehr draußen auf der Straße. Und das ist der Unterschied.
Und der wird immer klar markiert.
Und das wünscht man sich eigentlich auch für den politischen Diskurs.
Dass da Leute sprechen, die einfach sagen, guten Abend, Publikum wahrscheinlich
sind sie einfach ein normaler Deutscher. Hier auf der Bühne stehen jetzt zwei
Millionäre und die stellen Fragen an vier Millionäre.
Und das ist der politische Diskurs. Und da müsste man eigentlich mit zum Augen
zwinkern. Tut uns leid, dass es so ist, aber das ist der politische Diskurs, den wir ihnen anbieten.
Und dann kann von mir herumgejammert werden über Armut und was auch immer.
Aber das sind nicht deren Probleme.
Und in deren Sicht ist das schon ganz gut, wie die Waltraut Meyer das sagt.
Und ich will trotzdem noch mal anmerken, Ja, aber die singen. Auf der Ebene ist da...
Bravo, bravo, bravo. Denn ich hatte das, glaube ich, schon mal angekündigt,
aber ich kann es jetzt noch mal sagen. Am 16.
November bin ich im Staatstheater Wiesbaden. Es gibt noch Tickets.
Wer da kommen will, sehr gerne diskutieren da mit dem Chefdramaturken Konstantin Mende über die Oper.
Und er hatte den Einfall, dem Abend den Titel zu geben. Wie politisch ist die Oper?
Und die zweite Frage. Und warum singen da alle? Ja, sehr gut.
Und du hast ja jetzt schon die Vorlage geliefert. Ich nehme das alles mit auf
die Bühne am 16. November.
Warum singt man in der Oper? Das ist wirklich die Frage.
Warum singen alle? Gut, darauf ist dann auch hingewiesen. Ich weise noch darauf
hin, weil ich gerade drauf gucke, dass dein Buch Alten, die Alten Republik als
Taschenbuch erschienen ist. Ich habe vergessen anzusagen, letzten Wochenende.
Ja, deswegen machen wir das hier.
Also als Taschenbuch jetzt zu erwerben.
Und ich weise dich darauf hin, aber natürlich auch das Publikum.
Du als Freund auch des Digitalen.
Gerade heute ist mein Buch als E-Book erschienen. Mit den Bildern?
Die Bilder sind trotzdem drin. Ja, natürlich. Also wer das als E-Book haben
möchte und nicht so schwer tragen möchte, geht das auch.
Zum Schluss noch mal, wir lesen im Salon Hyperpolitik von Anton Jäger ein Essay
bei Surkamp erschienen. Nicht dick, aber hoffentlich reichhaltig.
Dann lesen wir eine recht opulente Studie. Triggerpunkte, Konsens und Konflikt
in der Gegenwartsgesellschaft.
Da heißt es schon auf der Klappe, Konflikte werden gesellschaftlich hergestellt.
Sie werden entfacht, getriggert und angespitzt.
Worum es da geht, dem wollen wir uns nähern.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch schon wahrscheinlich dann eine ganz wichtige Grundlage
für die Wahlen, die im Osten stattfinden.
Allerdings. Also das wird uns da begleiten. Ich kann noch sonst fast nichts ankündigen,
außer, dass ich dieses Technik-Optimisten-Manifest von Ant Treason Orbits will
ich da mitbringen. Übernimmst du es?
Okay, gut.
Ja, denn das ist so ein libertäres Manifest. Die Technik wird es machen.
Sie hat es immer gemacht und jetzt müssen wir das alles entfachen.
Dann lasse ich es mir von Siri auch einfach mal vorlesen, damit ich so grob
bin gespannt, was du rausholst.
Ich werde, weiß auch nicht genau, weil ein Text liegt da, die New York Times
hat so im Hinterzimmer im Orga-Büro der Trump-Wahlkampfadministration.
Wie schafft man es, die GOP zu übernehmen, bevor man dann das Land wieder übernimmt?
Und dieses GOP übernehmen klappt ja wieder hervorragend, gerade mit dem neuen Speaker und so.
Und du hast mich jetzt dahin getriggert.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich bis zur amerikanischen Wahl per se davon ausgehen,
dass Donald Trump die Wahl gewinnt und das auch immer so im Satzbau verwenden.
Als wäre es schon geschriebene Geschichte.
Das ist ja unsere Zeitenwende, liebes Publikum.
Genau, weil...
Ich erinnere mich, nachdem Trump abgewählt hat, habe ich ja noch gesagt,
und kannst du mir das dann versichern?
Also, mein ernsthafter Gedanke ist, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Ah ja. Ich will aber auf gar keinen Fall eine Diskussion über siehste,
siehste, siehste. Okay. So, deswegen gehe ich jetzt all in, ab jetzt, in meinen Podcast.
Der November 2024 ist Zeitpunkt, an dem Trump wiedergewählt wird.
So, wer also mit mir eine Diskussion über Trump führen will,
dann über Donald Trump, den dann 47. Präsidenten. Oder 46. Präsidenten.
Dann kann man von mir aus jede süße, süße, süße Diskussion führen.
Aber Donald Trump ist dann Präsident und zwei Jahre später ist Le Pen Präsidentin.
Ausflüchte mit, ich hab ja mal gesagt und so weiter, sondern nee.
Der neue, also mich interessiert ein Gespräch über Donald Trump nur unter der
Maßgabe, was ist, wenn er gewinnt?
Wenn er dann nicht gewinnt, ist er ja wirklich weg vom Fenster.
Warum sollten wir darüber vorher reden? Also wenn wir uns hoffen,
wenn wir uns wünschen, dass er weg vom Fenster ist, dann jetzt bangen und Angst
haben bis dahin, das ist ja auch Quatsch.
Dann gehen wir lieber davon aus, dass er gewählt wird. Wenn er dann nicht gewählt
wird, erlösen das. Okay, jetzt ist er wirklich weg vom Fenster,
weil noch mal vier Jahre später, das muss er dann auch erst mal,
also irgendwann ist ja auch wirklich mal so eine Altersgrenze erreicht, so, aber ja, je nachdem.
Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns.
Und so werden wir auch im Salon dann den Trump-Text lesen.
Und den Salon erreicht man, wie gesagt, über Steady, über Patreon,
aber nur wenn man bei Patreon schon ist, ist das über Patreon empfehlenswert.
Wir sagen lieber über Steady, das ist zu finden über neue20er.de oder auch,
wenn man bei Spotify den Button anklickt, kommt man auch zu Steady.
Und für die, die bei Apple sind und Apple auf keinen Fall verlassen wollen,
die können das auch alles über Apple buchen.
Und ja, das Archiv ist groß. Viele Bücher sind schon gelesen und neue kommen jetzt dazu.
Und das ist die Möglichkeit, über die wir uns freuen, wenn ihr die wahrnehmt,
den Podcast zu unterstützen.
Und sonst wünschen wir einen halbwegs angenehmen Monat. Bis dann.